hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be having an excel fill course but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without any
further ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's discussion
first we will get started with some
basics of microsoft excel then we will
understand the sort and filter functions
in excel
followed by that we will dive deep into
the functions available in microsoft
excel then we will move ahead by
learning conditional formatting data
validation in excel then we will
understand the pivot tables and charts
provided by microsoft excel then we will
start the data analysis in excel once we
are done with data analytics we will
understand the macros and visual basics
in microsoft excel and followed by that
we will try to create excel dashboards
using the analytics what we perform on
the previous topics and finally to help
you grab that dream job in data
analytics we will also help you with
some most frequently asked interview
questions based on excel i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda now let's
get started with the first topic that is
microsoft excel basics
now let's look at a scenario here so one
day in a startup
one professional speaks that their
business is growing and they would need
an efficient way to work with the data
they would have to find a way to work
faster with storing and analyzing data
now to that another colleague responds
well we can make use of microsoft excel
to do this job
the question is will excel be able to
cater to
their business needs
now
the colleague responds well we can make
use of excel in several ways and it also
is a cost efficient
option
now in that case
the colleague who posed the question
says let's go ahead with excellent let's
train our employees in excel
and
the suggestion is welcomed which would
make the job easier for them
and they would basically
decide on using excel so they decide on
taking a training right away and
basically starting to learn excel
now
before we move to excel one of the
question is why should we use excel
so let's look at some of the points here
so excel proves to be a great platform
to perform various mathematical
calculation on large data sets which is
one of the biggest requirements of
various organizations these days
various features in excel like searching
sorting filtering makes it easier for
you to play with the data
and excel also allows you to beautify
your data and present it
in the form of charts tables and data
bars
now when it comes to reporting reporting
accounting and analysis can be performed
with the help of excel
it can help you with your task lists
your calendars and goal planning
worksheets
excel also provides good security for
your data excel files have the feature
of password protection
this way your information can be safe
now when we talk about what is excel and
how it can be used
so excel or you might have heard a
spreadsheet can be basically used for
a lot of different tasks than just
storing the information in so called
tabular format
now
microsoft excel is an application that
is used for recording analyzing and
visualizing data it is in the form of a
spreadsheet
let's have a look at few of the
functions and formulas used in excel and
before we do that we can also
quickly take a
small tour to understand how to work
with excel now to do that what we can do
is we can
type in in our search say for example
excel and just select your excel app
which is installed and here you see you
have a lot of options which says take a
tour drop down list get started with
formulas make your pivot table
going forward with pie charts and much
more so we can click on this one which
says take a tour
and that basically pops up a window
which says welcome to excel and
if you have always wanted to be better
at excel you have this
which can help you so let's click on
create and that takes us to the store
window now that says instructions for
screen readers which basically talks
about 10 different steps in which we can
learn excel
and using the spreadsheet app
so there are more than 11 sheets
which we see here at the bottom end and
each one gives us a simple example which
we can work on
so for example if i click on add
now that takes me to this page which
says
how do we add numbers now you might be
provided data which we can
upload by loading a file from our
machine or getting data from a web
source or even connecting to a database
so there are various options which we
will see in some time
so here we have an option which is
called data you can click on this one
and this basically has
options where you can use existing
connections if you have created some you
can always click on from other sources
and you can get your data from sql
server from analysis services
from odata data feed you can get in from
xml from data connection wizard or also
from microsoft query you can be running
in different queries here which shows up
in the option which says new query there
are connections which you can use
and that basically will display all the
connections
for this particular workbook which we
did not have as of now but we can create
them but let's look at simple examples
now you can follow these instructions
here which says basically
adding up the numbers and that could be
easily done by just placing your cursor
here and what you could do is either you
can type in the formula that is
from which row to which row you would
want to add the data so for example i
could just do a sum here and that shows
up all the different functions which are
available then we can open up a
paranthesis and we can say i would be
interested in totaling the amount
from
column d and i would select for example
d4
so
i could be doing this and then i could
say d4
onwards till d7 so that's the data which
i'm interested in you can close your
parenthesis and hit enter and that gives
you the total
there is also a shortcut for this which
you can always do is we can first delete
this and you can just
place your cursor here and just
use your alt and equals that
automatically selects the numericals
which we can anytime
expand or basically collapse so i will
basically select this which says this
function needs two numbers which is
number one and number two and then you
can hit on enter and that gives you the
total
so similarly we can be getting in the
data
here by selecting all the fields
so here it also says that you can use a
shortcut now what we can also do is we
can add numbers over 50
by selecting the yellow cell here and
then giving a condition
such as so i can basically use something
like sum if
and then open a paranthesis i can select
i would be interested in this row and
then i can even drag and drop
till here so that tells me d11 to d15
you can then put in a comma here and you
can give your condition say for example
we would say i would be interested in
numbers only above
and we can select this
close your quotes and then just close
your parenthesis and that's your formula
so you can do this and that basically
gives me the total is hundred now
similarly we could do that for the
amount here i could select this now
there is also an option i can click on
home and i can go for something like
auto sum so that's one more way of doing
it which anyway says sum is alt plus
equals so it automatically adds up your
values and i can try doing an auto sum
that automatically selects my rows and
then i can get my total now as per this
activity here it says try adding another
sum if formula here but add amounts that
are less than 100 and the result should
be 160. so what we can do is we can
basically
select all the numbers which are lesser
than 100 so the way we did earlier here
there can be always a shortcut so you
can always for example if you would want
to avoid typing in the formula you can
always copy it from here
and then
just hit on enter so you are back into
this cell and then i can basically go
here and paste
the number and then as per the
requirement we are required to select
anything which is lesser than 100 so
what i could do is i could select here i
could say let's say g
and then i can change this value to g15
and that's one more way now we see our
selected rows have been changed so i can
hit on enter and i can check what is the
result so we would be interested in
looking for numbers which are lesser
than 100 so i will have to also change
this one to
a lesser sign and that basically gives
me the total which is 160
so that's how you can simply add numbers
you can use autosum you can type in the
formula you can select the fields or you
can just place your cursor where you
would be looking for a sum and then you
can just do a alt equals and that
basically populates the sum
now let's look at
some easy options of filling your cells
or automatically populating the values
in your
cells within your excel sheet
now here we have an option which says
100 now we can click on this and that
basically says it is making a sum of
column c4 to d4
so if i click on this one i can check
that this is
row number 4
which shows up here
and i also know this is column c i also
have d so this equals is basically
giving me a sum of c4 to d4 now what we
can do is we can always place our cursor
here at the right corner and then we can
just drag and drop and this basically
gives me a total of all the numbers for
all different rows
so this is one shortcut which we can do
to get the total excel will
automatically give the totals which we
call as filling down
now what we can do is in the same way if
we would want to get the totals here we
can first check what is this 200 and
this tells me it is c11 to c14 total so
it is totaling the rows from c11 so
column c and 11th row till 14th row and
that's the sum now what i can also do is
i can similarly like above we can do a
filling right which basically means
bringing your cursor here and then just
dragging and dropping it all the way
where you would need the totals and this
basically gives me the total there is
one more quick way to check if this is
right
so the easiest option would be to select
this cell now what i can also do is i
can just select all of these fields by
just highlighting and selecting all the
fields once it is selected
press on control r
and that gives you the total now if we
would be doing this top down then i
could select all these
rows
for this particular column and then i
could do a ctrl d so that's your
filling down and this one was filling
right so this is an easier option of
doing a fill when you would want to have
the formula applied to every row as it
occurs in the first row or the last row
we could test this by for example
selecting these fields i could delete
them and i have here which says 130 i
could just place my cursor here and i
could drag it all the way up
and that should also do the same magic
which we were seeing from top down so
this is a simple way wherein you can
fill up your cells and you can also
automatically
propagate
or move your computation to all the
cells
let's
look at the split option which basically
helps us in splitting the data when we
have some kind of pattern or when we
have some kind of delimiters in our data
in say one particular column and we
would want to derive the values out of
it so we can always use the splitting
option now the easiest option would be
so for example we have our email column
which has the email ids and which we can
clearly see has a first name dot last
name now i see that there is a last name
smith filled up here first name is empty
so what i can also do is i can just type
in say
nancy here
now that's the first name i can again
start typing the second name and as soon
as you do that you would see a faded
list of numbers and that's your clue to
hit enter and once you do that you would
see all the first names have been filled
in here if you would want to maintain
the case sensitiveness you can just go
ahead and delete these and let's type in
as it occurs so let's say nancy as the
first name go down to the next cell and
just type in andy and there is your
grade list so just hit on enter and that
basically fills up your first name
what we can also do is
we can just select this particular field
and either we can type in control e
which basically fills up all the options
now i can just do a undo by typing in or
clicking control z
and that's basically gone
what i can also do is i can select a
particular field
and then i can go into home option and
under home
you should have an option here which
says fill so you can select this and
then you can do a flash fill which is
what we are doing here so click on flash
fill and that automatically fills up the
values so in this way you can work
within your spreadsheet and you can be
filling up the values where a delimiter
by default is understood and we can
split the data now however sometimes you
might have some data which has a
different kind of delimiter and there is
again a smarter way of splitting your
data
so you can always scroll down here and
that says splitting a column based on
delimiters so we have some values in the
data column and
these values in each row are separated
by comma so
select this
your data is already selected text to
columns delimited
comma is selected
and now click on next so it basically
says
what is the destination let's select
this one
and i can choose what would you want to
have so that shows me this would be my
data preview now i can basically select
this one
i can say finish
and say okay
and now if you see our data has been
placed in
in the columns appropriately so this is
how you can split your data based on a
delimiter and then organize your data in
a better way now there are some advanced
options which we can learn later but
this basically tells about using a
formula so this is something if say if
we have some name in one cell and if you
would want to split it into first name
your helper column
your middle name last name so that can
also be done using formulas and this
basically tells how would you extract
characters
from your left
cell and how would you place them in
your right cell so you can try this
activity
which is a little more of advanced
option the benefit is that you can
always use this
wherein
if you
do some kind of transformation using
your formulas if your original data gets
updated then the split data will also
get updated and that's the benefit of
using formulas where you can place
values from one cell into multiple cells
based on execution of your details in
the formulas
how about using the transpose option now
you might have heard of situations where
you would want to
switch or turn your rows into columns
and your columns into rows and that's
where transposing comes into picture it
might be useful when you have your data
uh in your x and y axis or as i would
say in rows and columns and you would
want to switch your rows to become the
columns and columns to become
your rows so what we can do is the
simplest way is you can select all your
values so here we basically have six
columns and i would say two rows now i
can select all of these and then i can
select an empty field for example the
one which is highlighted here well you
can always do a control alt v that's a
shortcut what you can also do is
once you have selected all your fields
you can just copy them so just do a ctrl
c
and then click on an empty cell and then
what you can do is you can do a special
paste or paste special so under your
home you have the paste option and here
you can go for paste special
and once you do that you need to select
the transpose option over here and click
on ok and now you will see that the
columns and the rows have been
transposed so your row name was item and
that has become the column heading you
had row name as amount and that has
become the column heading and all your
values have been transposed
in
this particular format now there is
another way of doing that and again
that's using your formulas so what you
can do is you can transpose with a
formula also and that basically
works
when you have similar kind of data so
this has six columns
and basically two rows so you can
basically do this so you can
select this and earlier we were doing a
copy but now what we would want to do is
we would want to just look at the row
numbers which tells me it is c 33 c 34
and it starts with c and ends in with
your h column so what we can do is we
know that we have six columns and two
rows so transposing that would actually
give me two columns and six rows so what
we can do is we can select
two columns
and six rows in our excel sheet i can
then basically start typing in the
message or i can just go to the address
bar and here i can say
transpose
let's go for c33 h34
it basically selects my data
and now i can just do a
control shift and enter and now if you
see all the values have been populated
now you can just place your cursor in
one of the cells but if you see the
address bar the formula remains the same
this is because this is an array formula
so we can read more about an array
formula here it's basically something
which performs calculations on more than
one cell in an array
and in the example here the array is the
original data that is c33 to h34 so your
transpose is just changing
the horizontal orientation to the
vertical orientation so this is a very
simple way in which you can basically
use the
excel's capability to transpose your
data and convert your rows into columns
and columns into rows
apart from
working on
additions subtractions filling up your
data
sorting
the data or basically splitting your
data
transposing your data one of the other
requirements is sorting and filtering
your data now that can be very handy
when you're working on huge data and you
would want to sort it in a particular
order say ascending or descending or
might be based on a particular field or
if that field was or if the cell was
highlighted with a particular color
sorting the data so let's look at how
excel can be used for sorting and
filtering examples are pretty simple
here so
let's check that so if we're going to
sort and filter and say this is the data
i have say for example i would want to
sort the values in the department column
alphabetically so what i can do is i can
select department column and i'm already
in the home tab i can straight away go
here which says sort and filter i can
then say sort a to z and that's
basically alphabetically sorting your
department column
and once once i do this you would see
the data has been sorted but it's not
just this data we can just do a ctrl z
and check what are the values we have so
here we have meat which is beef and 90
000
hundred ten thousand the values
then you have bakery which should
ideally be the first
row if we sort it in alphabetical order
which goes with bakery as deserts you
have the values so we can check this
again so select department and then just
with sort and filter and let's say sort
a to z and if you see the data has
changed but it's not just in changing
your first column but then it has taken
care of all the data however the data
has been sorted based on the department
column so you have bakery which aligns
with deserts which has the values and
now we have all the data which has been
filtered now what we can also do is
we can sort december's amounts from
largest to smallest so what we can do is
we can basically click any cell in the
december column let's say 20 000
and then what i can do is i can go into
sort
filter and then i can say sort largest
to smallest so if you see bakery breads
is the row which has the smallest data
or might be you have delhi sandwiches so
that one looks also smaller so let's do
a
larger to smallest and if i do this you
would see the values have been shifted
now so it is no more based on the
department column
because now the data is being sorted
based on the values in the december
column and you see bakery which was
alphabetically the first one has become
second last so either you can sort the
data based on a department column which
goes
based on the values these are all string
values or words so it sorts
alphabetically if you have numbers might
be you can give some values and you can
sort the data
you could anytime do a custom sort and
you could basically select
if you would want to select the data so
i could do a custom sort and then i
could choose
which is the column which we would want
to use for sorting what is the sorting
needs to be done is it cell values is
its cell color font color conditional
formatting and then you can also choose
the order so that's one more way to do
that
now if you scroll down that also shows
how you can sort by date or a color so
for example if you would want to sort
based on the expense date so there are
different options so what i can do is i
can select this date field i can just do
a right click i can go into sort and
then i can choose i would want to sort
oldest to newest so since i selected the
date field it basically has sorted all
the data
and it has taken the expense date into
consideration now there are these
filters which you see on the row
headings we could have also used those
so i could have selected this and that
basically says or mentions which are the
dates i would be interested in looking
at
i also have sort by color here
i can do a sort oldest to newest or
newest to oldest so i could also use
these filters which have been applied
here now we have the data which is in
color so if i would want to basically
select
the color columns or color cells i could
select this i can basically do a right
click here and when i go into sort i
could choose
put selected color or cell color on the
top
and that basically will make sure that
my data is sorted and it has also sorted
that in a descending order so in this
way you can sort or basically filter
your data what we can also do is we can
add filters so sometimes we can go for
formulas which we would want to use what
we can also do is we can
basically select the filter which has
been applied here now how does the
filter come in there so if i would
select a particular row i could select a
particular row and then i could decide
if i would want to just add a filter to
this one and that's how the filter has
come in so we have the filter what we
can do is we can basically click on this
drop down
and then you have something like number
filters so we can always go here we can
basically choose one of these so we can
basically choose above average so i
could select this and then basically it
shows me the values we could also delete
the filter by clicking on this one and
we could say well i'm not interested in
this filter anymore so i could clear the
filter and that shows me all the values
or i could say
that let's click on some other field for
example food i can go in here i can go
into number filters and then i could say
well i'm interested in
values which are below average above
average might be greater than and then i
can choose what is the value so for
example if we say i'm interested in food
which is
greater than 25 dollars i could give a
value here i could say okay and now i
have applied the filter similarly you
can select this and then you can just
clear your filter and your data is back
so remember no data is lost
it is just hidden or basically based on
the filter not shown
so that's good enough for us and in this
way you can sort and filter the data so
for more details obviously in all the
sheets you have the links which point to
more information on the web and you can
always refer to these so this is simple
way in which you can sort and filter any
amount of data which has been stored
within your excel within a particular
sheet now that we have learned about add
fill split transpose sorting and
filtering it will also be good to learn
how to work with tables or basically
converting your data into a tabular
format and then doing some easy
computations so click on this tables
option here now here we see there is
some data which is in
five columns and n number of rows so i
can basically select this data and then
what i can do is i can insert
choose the table option
and then it says my table as headers and
we'll be okay with that i'll say okay
and now if you see this is the table
created it basically has different
filters which we have learnt earlier how
to use and this is basically my table
which is a collection of cells which has
some special features so we can easily
add rows to this table we can add
columns to this table and we can even do
some calculations so for example here i
can click on this one i can
basically enter some field
and then i can hit on enter and we see
that this row has been inserted wherein
we can easily fill in values for example
i would say chocolates
i could give some value here size 25
000.
might be 35 000
and then
basically i can given some values here
now what you can also do is you can
continue adding rows in this way
and say for example you would want more
columns so you can select this
option here in the top bottom right
corner you can just drag it towards the
right and that basically has
automatically created
columns for my next month
wherein i can feed in the data so this
is a simpler way wherein you can keep
adding more rows and columns to your
data if that has been converted in a
tabular format now let me just do a ctrl
z that basically deletes the columns
again ctrl z deletes the last row which
we added and i can stop here or i can
even remove my values by doing multiple
control z and removing my rows so this
is how i converted my data into a table
and then i can easily work on this what
i can also do is i can do some
calculations so what we can do
we have a table here we have a total
field and what we can do is we can just
select one cell here now as we have
learned earlier we can do a alt and then
equals
and that basically says
what
is this doing so it says it is
calculating the sum of
the last three months and if that's what
you would want to do just hit on enter
and it has automatically calculated
the totals for
all your rows for these three columns
so the sum formula is getting filled up
now i can select any particular cell and
i can look in my address bar so it has
already given me the formula where it
has started
calculating the sum from the october
column till the december column and has
given me the calculated values of the
columns what we can also do is we can
get total rows in the table
now that's a simpler option so what we
can do is we can select any cell in this
particular table
and then
we see that there is a table tools
design option showing up here now i can
select this and then it says
well let's get a total row so let's
select this and it automatically
populates the total here
and if you would want the average then
we could select this and from the drop
down i can select what i'm interested in
so for example i would want the average
values and not the total i could just
select this and that gives me the
average of these values
so we can always do simpler computations
here
by converting our data into table format
let's learn about one more efficient way
of working with the data and that's
using your drop downs so let's see how
drop downs work here
now
say for example you have this data which
has the values in the food column and
department is empty and say for example
you would want to
enter the values in department however
you would want to select
the department should either have
produce or meat and bakery and these are
the only three options which should be
available for any user to fill in the
values how do we do that so we can
basically create a table by
pressing ctrl d so what i can do is
under my department
here i can select one of the cells
and then i can do a control t that
basically converts this into a table i
can say ok and my table is created now
what i can do is once this part is done
we can
select all the blank fields here where
we would want this drop down to be
applicable
now under your data tab you can go in
and select data validation and this has
an option called data validation click
on this
which basically says allow any value so
here i will select i would want to give
a list of values and then i can type in
my values here which i can say produce
say for example meat and then say
bakery now these are the values
so we can click on ok
and once we have done that we basically
have a drop down here next to apples
which will only show us the values which
we can feed in under the department
column so i can go into every cell and
then i can basically choose
what is the department which handles
this and then basically i can select one
of these from the drop down so this is
an easier option of creating your drop
down and then feeding in the values from
the set of values which you have defined
here on the right
so this is a simple example of using
your drop downs
working with your tables working with
your sort and filter transpose split
filling up your data adding in some data
here and similarly you can use excel for
more than
one use case using its inbuilt features
to easily work with your data
let's see how we can import data or
bring in data into our excel from
your local machine or from an external
web source
so what we can do is we can open up a
blank excel sheet and say for example
you have been provided a text file or a
csv file and you would want to import
that data into your excel sheet that can
be easily done so right now i've opened
an
excel sheet now i can click on data and
here i have an option which says
existing connections from other data
sources
so or you can click on connections if
you have already created some so we can
click on from other sources
so this is one option where you can
connect to your different data sources
and you can get the data
from
one of these what we can also do is i
can click on connections now it says
there is none i can click on add it says
well show the connections where
connection files on network
connection files on this computer so i
can say let's get some files from this
computer
now if that does not show up something
so say browse for more and that
basically shows you different options so
let's basically select a folder where i
have
some data sets i'll click in here
and this is basically a folder where i
have some data sets now let me select
this particular file and i know it is a
csv file
so let's click on
open now if you would want to verify
this you could have gone and looked into
the properties of the file and it says
it is a dot csv file which is what we
are interested in so i'll take this file
i'll say open now this basically shows
me
the text import wizard option which says
is the file delimited i'll say yes
click on next so i will select comma as
my delimiter
i can say text qualifier is none
now this is my data so my data preview
is already showing me the data is
what is the data in the csv file you can
click on next and then you have an
option which says data format is general
you can go for date format you can go
for advanced options so i'll just say
finish
and basically now this has been created
here
so we basically have this and now i can
click on
close now once you have done that you
can click on existing connections it
shows me the data
which we have here the connection which
we have created say open
and then it says do you want to
import this data or bring this data into
existing worksheet
you can also say add this to a data
model if you are doing some data
modeling so click on ok
and now this data is automatically
inserted in my excel file i can
basically save it
into
this particular sheet now what we can
also do is we can also start a new sheet
and that does not have a data and we can
get some other data from web so what i
can do is i can go into my github
and let's say i would be interested in
this csv file
so i can select this and this is my
github path a path on web so i can click
on draw and that basically gives me
the raw path where this particular file
is now you can select this
copy this particular path and here you
can come back to your excel sheet we
would be interested in getting the data
from web might be from a text file where
we will have to specify the delimiters
or let's go to web
and here
i can given the web path from where i
would be interested in getting the file
let's give the github path which is
publicly available and then click on
import now once you click on import it
tells me there are two fields data and
value
these are
within double quotes separated by comma
so first let's click on import
now once we do this it will basically
get the data from web and put in here it
says existing worksheet so we had
already created a new worksheet so let's
click on ok
and now you have the data coming in but
then this basically shows me in one
particular field
so what we can also do is we can just do
a control a that selects all my columns
here
and that's my data so we can then
basically
filter this out so we can say text to
columns
it's a delimited file click on next
we can select comma and
let the text qualifier be quotes
it shows me data
preview click on next
so you have the general format it shows
the destination that's the column
click on finish and now your data has
been split and you have the data which
you have imported from web so this is
the data which is coming in from web
this is the data which came in from my
local machine and similarly we can even
create connection with an existing
database
so i can basically click on connections
if i would want to do that so i have an
option called connection here
and it says where the selected
connections are used
i can basically click on add
i can basically choose
if i would want to get the files from
network or from computer like we did
earlier
i can click on browse for more which
should
show me
different other options to create
connections say you would want to create
a new sql server click connection you
can connect to a new data source coming
in from different place you could
basically choose what kind of connection
you would you want so these are all the
different options which we can go for
and we can basically connect to a
database for example
if i have some database
and say for example access database
i can see if there are some files with
that particular database and i can
import it
so similarly we can also
uh click in here which says new query
and that also gives you an option of
getting the data from your files from
all these folders
from databases so you can basically
click here and then you can import data
from a mysql database provided that is
set up on your local machine or on a
particular server you can go from cloud
you can get it from online services you
can get it from other sources which says
from web
from your hadoop file system from active
directory from a blank query and you can
even combine queries wherein you can run
a power query editor
you can get the data from different
sources and then you can bring it into
your excel so in this way you can get
your data from different sources into
your excel into your spreadsheet and
then you can continue working on those
data sets
we have
already learned some basic operations
which you can do in excel and let's
implement our knowledge by working on
this particular data which is coming in
from housing data set now here if we see
some fields we have agent date listed
area list price and this is basically
the data which has been
sorted in newest to oldest order of date
listed
so how do we
arrive at this so what i can do is i can
just click on data listed
and then
i can either
go in here
i can select sort i can get into custom
sort
and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to sort the
data so i would look for the newest data
to the oldest data that means that would
be in a descending order of dates or you
could say the oldest date or the
earliest month will be towards the lower
side of your sheet so here we can select
date listed now i can say let it sort
based on cell values and the order what
we have here so we have newest to oldest
so let's select this
i can say okay and now if you see the
date has been sorted so we have your
10 18 2007 on the top so that seems to
be the latest date and as we go down we
will see
an earlier month hour
and
earlier month than that in this date
listed so we have sorted our data into
newest to oldest order and that's based
on your
date column so the result shows up here
now what we can also do is we can have
different questions which we would want
to answer so for example i would want to
sort the data in ascending order of area
and descending order of agent name how
do we do that so let's look into this so
this is here i already have the result
here and how did i get this so i'm
looking for ascending order of area in
descending order of agent name so we can
start with any particular column that
does not matter so for example if i look
into this excel sheet i have my agent
name select this which we want in a
descending order so we could either do a
sort and then go for
descending sort z to a we could also use
the filter option here on the top right
and we could do it or i could just say
sort z to a and then it
has arranged the data
based on the agent column being in
descending order now i can go into area
and then i can again do a sort and i
wanted my area column
to be used for
sorting the data ascending to descending
and that basically not only changes the
order of this particular column but for
my complete data so let's do that and
now if you see we have the
data which has been sorted so
we can see how many values we have here
and the area values which we see and
this is how you get your result so i'll
just do a ctrl z and
again and i'm back to my original data
and this is the sorted result which we
are seeing at
similarly we can answer other questions
for example sort the data according to
the following order
of area
that is we are saying county
central
and then your county so we can basically
choose
in which particular way we would want to
do it so it is county central and then
again county so if i look into my sheet
3 so here
i basically have my data which is
having some south county then you have
your central and then you have your
north county so we would want to
sort the data to solve our problem which
is
according to the following order so
first we go for area then we go for
south county central and north county so
what we can do is we can basically
have area field selected
and
i would want to sort this particular
data so i have south county central and
north county so i can basically go for
custom sort
and then i can choose which is the value
or column which i'm interested in let's
go for area
we will go for something like
cell values well you can also try to
explore conditional formatting icon
if this is what you would want to use
or we can basically go for just cell
values
and here we can say
if i would be interested in first
getting my values for
south county so
for example i can say custom list
and then i can basically given the new
list here so i can say
s dot county
and then i would want central
and then i would want north county
so let's select this
as it exists we can
basically say add
and that's basically the order which we
want to say okay
and then say okay here
and now what we would want is we would
want our data so we can compare that
with the values which we see here it
starts with kelly
you have in the 12th row something like
lang and that's what we are doing so we
can basically arrange the data in a
particular order by choosing a custom
list and then sorting your data
so that's one more simpler task of what
we have done where we have sorted the
data
in the order
where
under our area column we first wanted
south county
then we wanted central data and then we
wanted north county so this is how you
can do it
now
let's look into one more problem so it
says find all the houses in the central
area
and we would want to basically apply a
regular filter let's let's see how do we
do that so we can click on this and here
we have the data so the problem
statement is we would want to find all
the houses in central area now how do we
do that we can do a sorting but
we would want to use the filter which
you see here
is implemented so how do you do it so
you can select this area and say for
example i would want to apply filter i
can just go in here and i can say let's
get a filter on my first row and now i
have
filters applied so we are interested in
looking into the central area houses
let's go in here
it says
all these fields are selected that means
it shows everything
wherein your area has all these values
let's unselect this and then i will only
be interested in the central so let's
say okay
and then say okay so now you see that
the area
filter has been applied and we are
looking at the central column so what we
have done is we have applied a symbol
filter and we are looking at our data at
any point of time if you do not
want
the filter
then
what i can do is i can select this and i
can say well i'm interested in all the
data
so i could do this or you can clear the
filters from area
and you get your data back
so that's in one way you can filter out
your data so let's look at an example of
sort and filter where we might have to
filter the data based on two columns
or multiple columns with different kind
of values where it could be and and or
condition now say for example this is
the data i have and this is the question
which we need to answer such as find the
list of all houses
in the central region with pool
and south county without pool now if it
was a simple filter based on one cell i
could have
just selected my
header row
i could have then applied the filter
and once i have the filter i can look in
area where i have three regions so i'm
only interested in central and south
county so i can get rid of north county
and that's fine but then
we have two different conditions here so
we need
the
data in central region to have
the value for pool being true
and for south county the value has to be
without pool now how do we
do that so what we can do is we can
first create a copy of these headers
here
so let me do that now the area has to be
south county so basically i can
either just select this and i can choose
this value
and then i can select this and then i
can choose central so that's the
criteria which i have
and the pool value has to be
so central region should be with pool so
then this one
basically has to be true
and
this one has to be basically false so
south county is without pool so let's
select one of the values here and this
is my criteria now
to get my result
we can always place your cursor here and
you can check this is m column and
eighth row
okay so we would want the result here so
let's go ahead and now click on data
and then in filter you have an option
called advanced and here what i can do
is i can say i would want to filter the
list in the place but that's not what i
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location and here if you see the
list range will tell me that this is the
data so a1 to j126 so a to j column
selected and all the rows
criteria range is basically based on
what i've given here so that is m
from 1
to v
which is 3
so i am selecting these columns and then
i am saying all the way whatever
criteria i have given and copy 2 i am
saying m8
to v8 so that basically will give me my
filtered result so you could basically
just say okay
and now i have my data which has been
filtered
and i have my area which is south county
that is without pool central with pool
again south county without pool
and then if you look at your central
value that's pool so this is an advanced
filter which we have applied where
simply we have filtered the data based
on two columns and then we have our
result so in this way you can have your
customized filter applied on two
different columns and get your data
which can be either
replacing the existing content or
in the same sheet in different set of
columns and rows you can have your
result let's look at one more example of
filtering where you are trying to filter
the data based on an and condition
condition being met in two different
columns and then you would want to
filter out the data for only specific
columns so the situation is the agents
with a house in north county that should
be county
area having two
and a single type family so we are
talking about two bedrooms
and
we would basically have a single type
family and here the criteria is that we
would want to only populate these
columns which is agent area bedroom and
type now what you can do is as i
explained earlier that you can get your
result in
the same sheet in a different location
so here i have created these headers
which says agent area bedrooms and type
now this is basically a copy of all the
columns what we have here agent data
listed area list price bedrooms bath
square feet and so on so you can
basically create a copy of the headers
here and this is where we will give our
advanced criteria to filter the data so
the conditions which need to be met is
we need to look at north county
so for example here in area i can
basically go ahead and select one of the
values north county
now the criteria is having two bedrooms
only so let's say
bedrooms and let's say the value should
be two
and then basically i am saying a single
type family so when you would want the
single type family so here under type i
can give the criteria
single type
so
this is my and condition so we are
saying north county area having two
bedrooms and the type is single family
now this is the criteria which basically
means if i select this this one tells me
that this is m
one row onwards till v
two
so this is what we have
and we would want to filter based on
this
so let's go ahead and then go for
data filter advanced
and here in advanced it says filter the
list in place now that's not what we
would want to do so i'll say copy to
another location
this basically selects the list range so
which is telling me
a1
to j126
so that's the
columns and rows selected criteria range
is based on m1 v2 which we have given
here and copy to i would say for example
from m7
to
p7 now this is the area where i would
this is the place where i want the
result let's say okay and now i get my
data which is
based on the question which has been
asked that you would want the agents
with a house in north county area having
two bedrooms and single type family so
in this way you can basically do
advanced filtering
get your data and get it stored in the
sheet anywhere at a different location
well i could have
also done filtering in place and that
would have replaced the data
which we have but that's not what we
want we would want the filtered result
in a different place so this is how you
can do some advanced filtering we can
also use excel to filter out the data in
one particular column which might be
conditional or say
using some numerical filters now here
say for example the problem statement is
that you would want to display all the
houses whose list price is between
45 000 to 600 000
or say for example we would want to
filter out the data to something else
say for example let's say i have
i would want to filter out the data
between 300 000 and 400 000 so we can
basically update this
say for example i am saying i am
interested in 300
000
to
400
000 and that's the criteria to filter
out the data now there are two different
ways or there are two easier ways to do
it one is
i would want to
look at the list price so i can select
this
i can go ahead and do a filter here
and in the list price now this is where
we would want to do the filtering so
it's pretty easy you can click on this
one and then you can go into number
filters and you can choose between now
that's one easier way of doing it so i
could basically select this i could say
i'm looking for value which is greater
than or equal to 300 000
and then is less than or equal to 400
000 so if i just do this
i have applied my filter and i have my
data which is filtered based on my
criteria right so that's one easier way
of doing it or let me do a control
z
now
let the filter be there which you can
anyways use but what we can also do is
as we have seen earlier methods so get a
set or get your column headers here
and then
you are giving two columns here now the
only difference between
my
this set of columns which i have 1 2 3 4
and then you have 7 and 10 columns and
if you see here
we have 4
5
6 7 8 9 10 11 right so whenever you want
a and condition you will basically
add the columns where i can give add
condition if it is the same column if it
was a different column then it would be
same number of columns but and
conditions will lie in the same line and
all condition would lie in a different
line now here i can give this value so i
am looking for listed price
being
between 300 000 so i'm saying it should
be greater than or equal to
300 000 and then i can say less than or
equal to
400 000 now that's my criteria
and then i need my result here which is
in m7
so what i can do is once i have given my
criteria which i'll be using
to filter i can get into data i can get
into advanced and then i can say copy to
another location so it is selecting my
a1 to j126
criteria range is based on m1 to
w2
and then i would want my result from
this particular column
so let's say okay and now you have your
data filtered out in a different
location in the sheet
which has been filtered based on your
and condition so you can filter out the
data in this way or you could just apply
a filter on a column and give the
conditions
now let's solve one more interesting
problem and here we would want to use
excel where we would have an and and
an or condition so say for example this
is the data given to you and the
question is that you would want to find
all the houses in north county again
that's a spelling mistake but then the
north county area with a list price
greater than 300 000
and having three or four bedrooms so the
bedroom
has conditional so it has r three and
four
and then basically you have
list price which is greater than three
hundred thousand now i could have
obviously
selected the columns and then basically
gone for a filter
so i can just do a filtering here and
then i'm looking for list price being
greater than 300 000 so which we can
always give a number filter and i can
say greater than
and then i can say greater than or equal
so i can say greater than and then i can
give three thousand thirty three hundred
thousand
and that's basically the filter which we
would want
and
here i would want to select the bedrooms
which should be just either three or
four
so if for example here i go in here and
i unselect this and then i say three and
four
right so i am getting my data which is
greater than 300 000 and it should have
the bettering values which will be
either three or four selected now that's
one way of doing it let's do a ctrl z
and get it back to as we were or you can
even just say clear filter so you get
your data back as it was so what we can
do is we can here
give the criteria
so for example i have my
list price now this is what i would want
as a condition so let's say greater than
three hundred thousand
three hundred thousand and bedrooms
should be three
and then i can say greater than three
hundred thousand
and then i can say four
so this one basically gives me a
situation where your list price has to
be greater than 300 000 and bedroom
should be either three or four so we
have given our filtering criteria
now to get the result what we can do is
we can go into data we can go into
advanced
and we can say copy to another location
so our list range is selected which is
columns a to j
row number 1 to 126
your criteria range is given in m1 to v3
where we have specified and we are
saying the result would be in m7 to v7
so if i do this now i have got the same
data which we were seeing earlier and
here the bedroom values are three or
four
and basically the list price is greater
than 300 000. so this is a simpler way
in which you can create your filters and
all this advanced filtering what we are
seeing it will be saved with your sheet
you can always go back and change this
value or
you could do filtering where one person
has to look into the filter to see what
values have been selected
now that we have looked into
some operations which we can perform in
excel using filter or sorting the data
creating your tables let's also quickly
look at functions and formulas which can
be used
for
doing some easy calculations or
computations now excel can be used in
different kind of data analysis so for
example you have different inbuilt
functions which can be used
and we can always check for a particular
function so for example if i had
if i wanted to look at a particular
function i could just
type in here
something for example is and then it
shows me all the possible functions and
you can always have a look at the detail
of the function for example you have is
even which will return true if the
number is even
if we would say is logical
so i could search for
is logical and that tells me whether a
value is logical value true or false and
returns your value true and false
now we can obviously
say subtotal so you can search for any
of these useful functions and that tells
me what this function can be used for so
returns a subtotal in a list or a
database
you have many other such functions such
as integer sum
average
you may be interested in working on
truncating
some data getting the absolute value
getting the square root
basically getting a count or getting a
max value you can look for any
particular functions within your excel
sheet
now you also have other functions such
as now
or time for example let's look at now
function so i can search for
now
and here it is
so this is returns the current date and
time formatted as a date and time so
this is the function which we would want
to use
and if i just give the function it tells
me what is the current time
let's first look at the description of
time here so
say for example i would want time it
says converts hours minutes and seconds
given as numbers to an excel serial
number formatted with the time format so
for example if i would say
2 hours
and then
30 minutes
and 30 seconds and if i do this it has
basically converted this into your time
format so you can always use different
inbuilt functions for your work now we
will also look at some advanced
functions like sum f or sum ifs
you have count f and count f's
and you can be working on various
functionalities
of excel to
easily help you in doing some
calculations computations working with
your data
working with your different cell values
so let's look at some example of using
functions like sum or sum if
so for that
let's go to this sheet and here we have
some data now i have already applied a
filter which can allow me to filter out
the data so it says find the total units
that were sold in the east region now we
know
that in region we have east
and
i have multiple regions i could
basically be
saying
unselect all and select only east
and say ok
and that basically gives me the units
which were sold and if i place my cursor
here and then if i did a auto sum
so it would basically give me
the function which is being used so
something like subtotal and it is
basically working on
your
rows which is e2 to e44
and here
we can just do this so that gives me the
total but this is this is fine you could
do that but
it would be good if we know how do we
use a function like sum if to do that so
here i am seeing this is the subtotal
where i am looking at the values and
basically what i have done is i have
filtered out the region
and
then basically i am getting a count but
this does not give me clearly how
a sum was calculated from all the values
which were listed what we can also do is
let's do a ctrl z and let's get it back
so now we have our data and we would
want to get the total units that were
sold in the east region so what i can do
is i can start typing in my formula
and for that i'll use an inbuilt
function so for example i would be
interested in going for sumif now it
says sumif adds the cells specified by a
given condition or criteria when you
talk about some ifs this is when you
could give set of conditions or multiple
criterias so let's look at some if
let's do this now obviously this gives
me an error because the formula
is not right so we have to basically
come in here
and let's start with sum
if now when i say sum if it shows me
there is a function with
sumif which we would want to use and
here
once i open up the bracket it tells me
okay what is the range of data which you
are interested in so i'm interested in
all the units that were sold in the east
region so we are interested in the
region
which is here
so
i can basically be
selecting this
and this tells me
you are interested in the data here so
let's not take the header value so let's
say b2
and then we can
go all the way to the end so we can
basically select this way
that's the data we have select this and
hit
enter
so
now here
it has selected b2 to b4 but we need to
basically now give the criteria so the
criteria is either a value or you can
point it to a cell
which has that particular value so as
per our problem statement we are looking
for the units which are sold in east
region so i can select the value east
here
and then
my sum if needs the range on which you
want to
calculate a sum so
let's select this and now we are
interested in finding out the sum of
units so that's basically this column e
column so i can basically type in
instead of selecting so i can say e
and i'm interested in e2 2
e
44 so that basically selects the area
or all the values and now let's do this
so that basically gives me the sum is
691
right now this is the criteria where i
have pointed it to a cell and whatever
value that cell has well i could have
done
something like this so i could have
selected east giving the value
and then doing it it still does the same
thing and in this way you have more
clarity that you are using sumif you are
filtering the data so you have given the
rows
you are given the criteria and then you
have given the range
on which you would want to sum up the
values
now similarly if the question was what
was the total revenue generated from
binder
now
we would want to find out what is the
total revenue generated from binders
that means
my filtering criteria will be binder
and then
i want to find out the total revenue
generated so we have the revenue
generated field also here and we have we
don't have any region to be filtered we
are just looking for binder so let's
again start doing the same thing so we
can go for some if we can open the
bracket now it needs the range
so we are interested in
revenue generated now that's the
summation we want and we would want to
get
the range of data so here
we can basically select
d
2
2 d
44
so that's the data selected now i would
filtering criteria so let's say binder
and then we need to give the range on
which the sum needs to be calculated so
that's my
revenue column so that's g
so i can say g
2
to g
44
and that basically selects the column
and then you get your sum so it tells me
what is the total revenue generated from
binder
now i could be doing this for other
things also so
say for example if you would want to
filter out something else
you could basically just drag and drop
here and then i could come here and
change this to say
instead of binder i would be interested
in say
pencil
if that's the criteria you are
interested in
remember to change this so that you take
all the values
and here we will change
it to select the relevant rows and then
this is the data i'm getting so i know
that this is
the revenue generated
from pencil this is the revenue
generated from binder now this is a
simple use case where we are using some
if
what if we would want to use some ifs
so some ifs
let's have a look at how we get to some
ifs
so some if says where you would want to
work on
doing some calculation but then
you would want
multiple criterias to be met so let's
see how we get this
so
here what i can do is
let's work on this problem statement
which says what is the total revenue
generated from central region
where the item is a pencil
so
that's
something which i would want to check
now when we are answering this question
we can also look at the order in which
things have been asked in the question
so it says what is the total revenue
generated from central region so we need
the total revenue generated we know
there is a revenue column we are
interested in getting the total revenue
generated
we are saying the filtering criteria is
central region
and we say in that we would be
interested only in the item
if it is pencil how do i do it so i can
use sumifs where you can pass in
multiple criteria so let's start with
some ifs
and when i start with some ifs let's
open up the bracket so it says sum range
it says criteria range then it gives one
criteria and you can give in any number
of criterias so for example we are
interested in total revenue generated
now that's my g column so let's follow
in the same order so let's say g
2
so that's my first value and then i know
there are 44 rows here so i can say g
44
and you can obviously check
if that has selected all the rows
now
that's my total revenue generated so i
would want the total revenue generated
so i'm saying setting this sum range
then
i need to give the criteria range so it
says from central region so central
region
comes into column 2 that's b
so let's say b
2 to b 44
so that's my criteria range
then you have to give
your criteria but
we need to filter out the region being
central so let's select this now either
i could point to a value in the cell or
i can just
give the exact value here we can also
give a
wildcard or matching pattern so that
also works now this one is fine
we are now also interested in finding
the total revenue generated when the
region is central and the item is pencil
how do we do that so for
item we know the columns the column is
d2
so let's select d2
2
d
44
so that basically selects
all the rows in the d column and we need
to give the
filtering criteria so let's do a comma
and then just given our value so let's
say pencil
and then let's close your bracket and
that basically gives you the result
so
we need to just follow the order of our
question which says
what is the total revenue generated so
we are looking at the revenue column we
are selecting all the rows
then it says
from the central region so we need to
select the region column and give the
filtering criteria as central or point
to a cell which contains that value
and then it says
we would be interested only in item
being pencil
so then you select the column which has
all the items
and provide your filtering criteria that
is pencil
so that's your easy calculation of using
sum if which we compare with
sum if here so sum if here was
just
having
your criteria
so basically you are selecting your rows
giving your filtering criteria and then
your sum range in some ifs we are giving
multiple condition now same thing can be
done here it says how many units were
sold by sales representative john's
or jones where the cost of each item was
greater than four
so how many units were sold
by
sales representative
so when we talk about how many units
that's your e column
so let's start with that so let's say
some ifs
i would be interested in e
column
then let's give the range
so it says sum range so those are the
number of units on which we would want
to find
the sum then it says you need to give
the criteria range so we say sales
representative where the name is
jones
so sales representative is in sales rep
column c so let's say c2
to c44
now
then we need to give our filtering
criteria so let's say jones
is the sales representative where we are
interested
about whom we are interested in and then
we
the question says where the cost of each
item
so cost of each item is what we are
interested in
you have unit cost
so that's what we are interested in so
that would be f
and then say f2 to f44
and then you need to give your cost
so it says where each item
is greater than
4
so let's select this
and let's
do this so this tells me 3 0 1
now similarly let's answer our third
question which says how many units did
jones sell excluding
pencil item so we would want to find out
what was the total number of unique
units that were sold
and
that
units or that should not include the
pencil item how do we start doing this
so let's start with some ifs
now we know that you start with some ifs
you need to give the sum range so we are
interested in the number of units
so let's basically go in and select
our
number of units which were sold so
that's your column e
so i can say e2 to e44 that's where i
would want to perform this sum
now i'm saying
how many units that were sold where
we are talking about sales rep being
jones so let's see
let's select the columns
c
and then give
the range
after that we need to give our giving
filtering criteria which is jones and
then we are interested in
the items but excluding pencil so items
is in column d so let's say d
to d 44
and then
we have to give
our
criteria so we can say well that should
exclude
pencil
so i can basically say
pencil
and let's close this
and let's check so that's my formula
which says
that these are the number of units which
the sales representative whose name is
jones had
sold
and that does not include pencil as an
item let's also look at an example of
using countif or countifs now both of
these can be very useful when you would
want to calculate certain values
so for example if i would want to work
on count f let's try solving this
problem
now remember you can answer these
questions using filters and that can be
an easier way but then sometimes you may
want to
get the formulas so that you can make
your spreadsheet and your calculation
more
dynamic
in nature and that will basically depend
on the values in the
columns or rows so for example
if i have find the total number of times
gil has made a sale now if i look at my
data here it tells me that for every
sales representative there is some value
in the sale and it says sales has
greater than three
so for example jones you have sales
greater than 3
or
you have jardine which is sales greater
than 3 and so on so what we are
interested in
is
doing a quick count in finding out the
total number of times gill has made a
sale how do we do that so we can use
this count if function and if i go into
countif it says counts the number of
cells within a range that meet the given
condition now what's our condition our
condition is kill and we would want to
find out how many times the name say
gill appears or kill has made a sale now
i could just say count if
and then open up a bracket i need to
give a range so let's say
we are interested in looking at the
range
so let's say
we will choose
sales rep so i can say c
and then i can say c2
to
c44
now
that's my
range
let's not give that in quotes
so you have to give a range so let's do
a count if that selects the data and
then we need to give the condition so
for example let's here give the name
which is gil
and then
close this so that basically tells me it
is five times kill appears here we can
check this so i can go in here i can
add a filter
and then might be i would be interested
interested in looking at only gil
and that basically gives me five
right so we can always do that and we
can be using formulas like this now what
about this question so which basically
says which sales representative made a
sale more than three times now we it
might be looking a little confusing when
i say for example let me clear out this
filter
now we have sales greater than three and
we would want to find out which sales
representative made a sale more than
three times
now i could basically check for every
sales representative here if they have
made a sale more than three times and
what i can do is i can just say equals i
can start with count if
then i need
my
filtering criteria so that's your range
so first thing is we will choose for
example let's choose c2
to c 44
and then we need to
give and criteria what is the criteria
we need basically a sales representative
so i can choose the value here
in c2
and then
i can close this and then i can say the
sale has to be greater than three
and let's check so it tells me the
boolean value that yes
this guy has made
sales more than three times and what we
can do is we can just
drag and drop which basically gives me
the value for other sales rep you can
always check the value is automatically
changing to this value in cell
and for example let's go in here so this
is obviously two so it says me false
right and you can basically get the
values for all your values
so that basically tells me which
sales representative has made a sale
more than three times
now like some ifs we also have countifs
where you can give multiple criterias so
for example the question is how many
orders were placed from the east region
after this particular date so we have
a date criteria we also have the region
criteria and we need to basically
get the count of number of orders which
were placed now i can in this case use
count
ifs
and this basically says that you can
start within criteria so it says how
many orders were placed from east region
after
particular date
so date is in my
first column so for example
i could say a
start with 2
and say for example let's go a 44
that should have selected all the rows
and then i need to
once i've given the criteria range i
need to give the criteria so we are
saying
the date has to be greater than
10th feb
so let's give it
2
10
2019
and then you need to say
how many orders were placed so you need
to give the criteria second criteria
range
so we are looking at the number of
orders which were placed from the east
region
so when i would want to look at the
region that's your column b
so i can basically say b 2 to b 44
and here
i would basically
give my criteria so the criteria is east
let's give that
and once you have done this you would
want to find out the total number of
orders so let's select this
and if i do this it tells me 13.
now is that right so we are looking for
your date
your region being east and then getting
the total number of orders so here
i can just do a count if
i'm saying a2
to a44
wherein i have given the date criteria
that it should be greater than
10th feb because i do not want to count
10 feb it says after 10 february
and then you are saying the region has
to be east so we would want to find out
the total number of orders so
my region is east and that gives me the
result
now similarly you can also find out how
many times gil
sold pencils so
here we will have to give the range so
let's start with count
ifs
now here i would want
that item is pencils so we can as well
select column
d to
d 44
then you have to give your criteria so
that's your
pencil
and then
we are looking for sales rep which is
kill so
that is my column c
so let's say c 2
2 c
44
and the value should be
just kill
so it tells me
it's twice where gil has sold pencils so
we can obviously check this by
going in here
choosing my filter
and then let's search for rep being just
gill
okay and now we are interested only in
the item being pencil
so i can say well let's get to pencil
only and that tells me twice
so you can obviously re-verify using
filters but using functions or using
formulas
it is always good to calculate and that
can be making your computation and
calculation more dynamic
let's look at one more interesting
feature of excel and that's your
conditional formatting now as you see on
the screen
conditional formatting has different
rules which can be applied on your data
and that allows you to basically
differentiate or easily identify data
values which
are
based on
certain criterias or rules so when you
talk about conditional formatting you
have different options such as you can
highlight cell rules you can get top and
bottom values
you can apply different rules apply
different color scales and you
you can easily manage these rules
so conditional formatting is very useful
for people who would want to work on
huge amount of data and easily perform
some data analysis
it's easy to use as it is shown here and
with your conditional formatting
you can format cells based on a preset
condition
you can perform conditional formatting
to identify cells
you can highlight a few significant
cells and you can easily perform
conditional formatting
as shown
on the left side
now how do we work with conditional
formatting let's have a quick look
so say for example we have our excel
sheet and if you see here
i am highlighting
the sales person who have generated
revenue greater than 10 000
so
we can be looking at the values where
the revenue generated by a particular
sales person is greater than 10 000 it
has a particular
color and how do we get here so for
example let's select
this data
and what i could do is
i could go into conditional formatting
now i could basically highlight cell
rules and we could just say greater than
that's an easier way
i could also go ahead and create a new
rule but then i can use one of this
option i can say greater than
and let's give some value might be we
would be interested in looking at
any value greater than 12 000 so let's
choose 12
000
and here
it says what color would you want to
select so for example
i would say
something like
yellow filled with dark yellow text
and let's say okay so right now what i'm
doing is
i have all the values where the revenue
generator was greater than 10 000
but then i have also selected all the
sales
people who have made or who have
generated revenue greater than twelve
thousand
so i can just wait ctrl z to see the
previous result now here
i had the values which were greater than
ten thousand
and the one which we did just now
basically
highlighted the values which are greater
than 12 000. so this is one simple
example now we can look at some other
examples say for example you want to
format cells using three color scale
so if you look at the values here i have
a three color scale mainly in green
yellow and red
and how do you do this so for example i
can go in here
and i can go to conditional formatting
so i would want to
go for color scales and here
you can create different rules so
we can set up a two color scale so we
can say format
only values that are above and below
average i can format only cells that
contain something
i can get the top and bottom values so
these are different ways in which
i can
have a three color based scale now what
i will do is i will select this
and let me show you the rule which i
have so for example
i can go into manage rules and if you
see here there are certain rules which
have been specified now what does that
mean so you would want to specify a
three grade scale
so for example if i would want to look
at my first rule
it tells me that i am choosing three
color scale i can choose lowest value
percentile and highest value and that
basically will
select the cells based on their values
so what we could have done is i can
basically
use one of these values i can delete
these rules which i have created
so for example
i have all these rules
but you should always carefully remember
that the rules will be applied in the
order shown so for example if i just
delete these rules
and then say apply and say okay my data
is back now
it does not have any highlighting now i
can go in here
i can say condition sorry conditional
formatting
i could go for color scale so i could
basically go into
new rule
so i would want
the
cells
to be using three color scale so let's
choose three color scale now when you
say three color scale it says what will
be the color of lowest value
and we could choose might be any one of
this let's choose red
i can say midpoint is percentile 50
and then the highest value is green and
if that looks good let's say okay and
now if you see the lowest values have
been highlighted as red
you have mid values and then you have
the positive value so this is the three
color scale and that
easily helps me in identifying the data
based on the cell values
now in conditional formatting what you
can also do is you can
basically color the cells based on their
value so what we are seeing here is if
the revenue
generated
is greater than average then that shows
in green
and if the revenue generated is lesser
than average that's shows in orange
now how do we do that so we can
basically again manage some rules so i
can basically create a new rule
now here i can select one of the options
which says format only values that are
above or below average and that's the
option i would want to select now i can
select this and it says format values
that are above average so
in our case we had it in green so for
example i'll say above average and then
here i can go for
a particular color
so you can go for a particular size
so let's go and look into
the formatting
so for example let's choose yellow
say okay now i'm saying
wherever
the cell values are above average it
would be yellow instead of green
and let's go in here
let's go and look into manage rules so
this is
basically the rule which we are applying
now we can also add a new rule
and
i need to
select the values so for example i will
say
here so we had gone for above now we'll
go for below
we'll go for format we will choose red
we'll say okay we'll say
now
these are
basically
the rules which we have created and here
it says applies to your data so right
now it has not been applied so for
example if i select this and then
i could basically
choose my area just hit on enter and
similarly you can go in here
and then select your area
hit on enter and say apply say okay and
now if you see
i have really chosen bright colors but
then i have said wherever my revenue
generated is above average
it should be in yellow and
below average should be in red so we
wanted
above average to be in green
and below average to be in orange so
that's what we have here right so you
can always
color code your cell values based on
some rules which you are setting up now
similarly you can also
find the top 10 and bottom 10 values and
that's pretty easy so you can just
select this
and then you can go into conditional
formatting you can go for top and bottom
values top 10 items bottom 10 items
or you can go in for more rules so you
can say format only top or bottom ranked
values so you have top 10
now you can choose the color
and for example i'll go for
blue
and
i'll say okay
so now if you see my top 10 values are
blue now similarly i can add one more
rule so i can say new rule and i can say
let's go for top or bottom
let's go for bottom let's go for format
let's say orange
say okay
say okay and that's it so now you have
your values which are top or bottom 10
values
so you are using conditional formatting
where you are
basically highlighting your cell values
based on different colors
and here
easy conditional formatting based on
different rules helps us to do that now
similarly you can also
have the values
which is basically
showing you how the values are
increasing
so what
we can do is we can select our
columns
either you could apply this to all the
columns now here i have applied this
only to jan and april now i could apply
this for june so let's say june so you
can go for gradient fill you can go for
solid fill
you can obviously just select the color
and that takes care of the things
you can say for example select this and
now this is selected but i would want to
might be format this so i can go in here
i can go into manage rules now that will
tell me
what rule has been applied
in the order so i can just do a edit
rule and that basically says this is a
solid fill
which is color you have no border this
is basically color is black now i can go
for something like gradient fill
and i can say okay and now if i say
apply and okay
so this basically is like your first
column so you can use conditional
formatting for various use cases and you
can highlight the values
so anyone who would look at the value
would automatically notice which are the
higher values which are lower values
might be
here the revenue is getting generated or
was getting generated but did not grow
beyond a particular value and so on
now similarly you can also go in for
different options
say for example here we would want to
see if the revenue was dropping
or if the revenue was
if the revenue decreased
or say for example if the revenue was
going up for this particular sales
person so here we are looking at carol
so in jan the revenue generation by
sales was very high
then in feb it was falling down
in march it was
kind of stable
then in april it went way below so we
can obviously work
on this
wherein we can grade our cell values so
what we can do is we can
go in for
highlighting the cell values now you can
go for color scales you can go for icon
sets and this is where you can choose
your different shapes
so you could choose one of these shapes
so for example
i would be interested in looking at the
indicators like directional
i could go
using this three arrows i can go in for
this color i can choose directional
and then
my values are automatically
using directional now what we can also
do is we can then go into manage rules
and that basically tells me what rules
have been applied
so for example the latest one is the
icon set which i have chosen
it shows the selected columns i can
obviously do a edit rule and then i can
choose so i'm saying the format style is
icon sets
i'm not using a data bar i'm not using
color scale
now here
i have chosen the style of icons
and then here
you can basically give some values so
you have icon which is green
when the value is greater than or equal
to 67 percentage
when i say
hyphen or minus it is less than 67
it's way below 33 percentage
then you give this value so you can
obviously edit and easily
highlight your cell values based on this
icon set so i can apply this
and that's how i use conditional
formatting so conditional formatting can
be very useful
if you would want to use icon set if you
want to use your data bars
if you would want to
highlight particular values if you would
want to color code based on some
calculation
if you would want to
use a three color or a two color scale
or if you would want to just find out
values based on some simple calculation
so conditional formatting is used
extensively by data analysts
or people who are working business
intelligence teams or people who would
want to use excel to easily identify the
data
easily identify the cells which contain
particular value
or finding out
less significant or more significant
cells
to then pull out values and carry out
your computations calculations
or analysis
so let's continue learning on using
excel for various things now we have
learnt on conditional formatting and
seen how that can be very helpful
let's learn one more feature of excel
and that's basically your data
validation now this can be very useful
when you would want to work on
validating the data which is being fed
in the cells so you could limit it to
basically a number between a particular
value you could also add some messages
to it
if you would want
or you could even
circle invalid data or clear validation
circles so data validation really helps
us in validating the data which is being
fed in to particular fields
now it's a feature in excel which is
mainly used to control what a user can
fill in a cell you can decide what type
of values must be entered
you can also
restrict user to enter only valid data
and if any invalid data is entered an
error message will be displayed
now that's where you can use your data
validations so let's see how that can be
done so for data validation let's see
some exercises here so for example you
have a name column and you would want to
restrict
that the name should accept only 15
characters now how do you do that so you
can basically select the cells
or
you can just select a particular cell
and then we can later drag
the property to other fields now here
once the cell is selected so for example
let's try this out and let's see if that
works so for example i will say peter
johnson
okay
and that is basically five and nine
and 12 characters so let's say
junior
and if i do this it says
input length is greater than 15 do you
want to continue if i say yes
right so basically
it is allowing me to add the value here
but then it has
basically violated the rule
now this is giving a message to the user
that the username should be entered
less than 15 characters now how do we do
that
so for this we can basically
select the column and then we can search
for data tab and get into data
validation
so this is where you can create or
select different kind of rules so for
example i can go into data validation
i can go into settings and i can say the
text length
and that should be less than 15 now this
is the maximum i'm giving and it says
apply these changes to all other cells
within the same settings
so i can do this or i can just drag and
drop
so i can basically
apply this formula and now you can in
fact randomly check in any particular
cell is the rule applied so it says text
length less than 15. so we can basically
control data validation in this
particular column
and that will allow only 15 characters
it will pop up a message
if the user really wants to go beyond
the particular limit
now you also have similarly date of
birth so the restriction is date of
birth should be between 10 jan 1990 to
30 december 1998
so this is what we want to restrict how
do we do that so we can select the field
we can click on data validation and if
you see here i have selected date and
then date is between and then obviously
you can give a range that is 10 jan date
1990
12 30 1998 so that's the start and the
end filter which has been applied
and once this is done you can also check
your input messages which says
when cell is selected show this input
message enter a valid date
so if you see here on the left there is
a pop-up which is coming up it says
enter a valid date now i can also say
when user enters invalid data show this
error alert so i can say stop
i can say invalid entered
and this is how i have set a rule so for
example if i just do
something like this
and that says invalidate entered i can
do a retry it will take me back here but
unless and until
i did not
give the right format the date will not
be accepted and again the same thing
applies to all the cells
similarly email so we are saying the
email should have at the rate present in
the value provided now for this we can
use a formula and we can select well i
would want to apply this rule to
all these rows starting from c 2 to c 14
so let's get into data validation let's
look in settings and here we are
choosing custom
now within custom i am choosing
what is the formula so i am saying is
number
and then i am saying find
at the rate for
the rows c2 to c14 so the only thing we
are concerned about here
is the value should have an email
icon
you can input a particular message you
can say what has to be done for
error alert so for example we can
basically go in here and we can say
invalid email
that's the title i'm giving and we can
say
email
should contain
at the rate
so if i do this and if i say okay now
you can test it so you can say abcd
and that says email should contain at
the rate and basically that will not
allow me to add the values so now you
have the field called salary it says
salary should be greater than 50 000 now
we can limit the values by
choosing a whole number so for example
for salary i can go into data validation
i can go into settings so here i can say
something like
decimal or i can go for whole number so
both of the things are fine it depends
on what kind of values get into this
particular field so if i say whole
number and if i say it has to be greater
than 50 000
so i'm saying the minimum is 50 000
or i could have given a decimal and then
i can say greater than less than equal
or anything or even between so i can
select greater than and then i can just
say okay
now for rank the rule is rank should be
between 100 and 200 so again we can use
a whole number so ranks will
generally not be decimal so this would
be whole number salary
is
can be a whole number or it could be
decimals so we have chosen decimal here
and in rank if you click on data
validation i have chosen whole number
i've set data between 100 and 200
input message nothing error alert
nothing but that depends i can give this
so this is how you can just do a simple
data validation and control the values
which land in the cell okay so now let's
also understand how we can
restrict the values in a particular cell
which might be
based on a list of items
now for example here if you see i have
two columns so one column basically has
the values of city
names and then you have places within
that particular city so if i would want
to
implement a data validation based on
this so for example if you see here city
and that basically shows me only the
four values which can be entered and if
i go to place then it tells me for
maharashtra i can only enter pune mumbai
nasik now how do i do this
so say for example you take an empty
field and you want to restrict the
values of city names so i could
select data validation i could basically
select list
and then it tells me you need to enter
the list values that is the source so
you click here and then i can just
select these fields now if i do this and
if i say okay
it has implemented a data validation but
if you look into this
it will show me
the same thing but then it shows me some
empty cells
which did not have any value so this is
fine but it would be better if we do it
in a different way so i can select this
and i have already given my city names
here so i can just do a data validation
and here in the source
let me get rid of this
now
i can just
have my cursor here
i can select these values and then if i
say okay so now if you see my city names
have been restricted to these values and
that's how you can implement your data
validation so i have
this data validation here but i will get
rid of this one by just doing a control
z now i'll come here and say for example
i would want to implement the same data
validation now the easiest way would be
in
doing this for all my four cities now if
you see here i have
data validation i could choose bangalore
and if you come and check here there is
no data validation but we have
implemented data validation here now how
is that done so i could select this or
for example i can go in here i can
select data validation
i can select list
and then here in the source
i will say for bangalore the value
should be these
and then
if i basically say okay
now
if we see these are the values which are
fed into bangalore
so we could do this or like what we have
done here so if you can check the data
validation rule
i have used list and then i have said
indirect
f2 so basically i am giving in a formula
which relates to the value which is in
for the city maharashtra so we could do
this or in a simpler way we could do
this and then just drag and drop here so
we could check for maharashtra what are
the values
let's choose a different city so for
example kolkata and here i will choose
now since we did a drag and drop it has
basically taken the values of bank load
so that's not right so we select this we
go into data validation and here i can
either
feed in the values
that is such as bangalore i could
basically say something like this
kolkata
and i could say okay so now if you see
it shows me the places in kolkata
now here
we have let's choose a different city so
for example let's go for delhi
and here i can go to data validation and
i can just say delhi
so this is an easier way of doing it or
if you remember the formula
then what you can do is
you can just give in
indirect
and then basically
give the
value of the cell
for which you would want to
keep in the values so this is how you
can do list validation so you can
provide a list of values and then you
can restrict the values in a cell which
should be
belonging to a particular list
so this is how you do a simple data
validation by restricting the data in
the form of a list
now let's learn about pivot charts and
tables which is one more very useful
feature of excel and which allows you to
work with your data or perform data
analysis
now pivot table is a summary of your
data
it is used in cases where there are
numerous rows and columns in your data
set
and it allows you to group your data in
several ways so that you can derive
meaningful information from it now the
visual representation of a pivot table
is termed as a pivot chart now how do we
do that so let's see an example now here
is some data here you see we have some
row labels which basically gives me some
category of
items here it also tells me the sum of
sales
and basically it gives me per item what
is the total sum of sales which were
made now how do i get this here so for
example if i would want to delete this
and i would be interested in getting the
total sales under each category of items
now we know that we have
different data here and it's huge for
example on the
row end if i just do a control and right
arrow it tells me what's my right last
column
and if i just do a control and down
arrow it tells me there are
9994 rows
now i can use this
and what i can do is i can basically
work on
insert and go to pivot table now this
basically tells you need to choose the
range now since i have chosen my first
row and first column it basically has
selected the data and that's fine now do
you want the result in a new worksheet
i'll say existing worksheet and i can
choose a location now that basically
needs me to select a field might be we
can just select this field
and that should be good enough
so
for example if i close this or if i say
okay
so
this is basically an indication that my
pivot table
will be created now what are the fields
we are interested in so as per the
problem we need to find out what the
total sales for each category so let's
go in here and let's select the field
category now as soon as you do that it
shows that
the rows
which are
being selected are for this column
category and now we are interested in
getting the sales so we would want the
sales per category so let's select this
so you see some of sales is selected now
close this and that's it that's that's
your data so it shows you row labels
it tells you what are the different
categories
and it also gives you
sum of sales which is per category now
this is
one easy example where we have solved
the problem where we have tried to find
what were the total sales under each
category of items so for example let's
have
another data set so again you can just
check how many rows we have and it is
basically the same 9994
and if i look in columns it basically
shows me profit is the last column
and
here
we would want to find out
which category
so for example let me get rid this with
subcategory of items sold the maximum
under each category so
we have some categories here which says
furniture and it shows some sub
categories
and then it shows me office supplies and
then some sub categories and same thing
with technology now we know how we got
this data but this is different than
what we were seeing here so here we were
just getting the categories but but we
did not have any breakdown
of subcategories within this particular
category and here you see there is a
breakdown and then basically you can
also apply a filter which basically says
what is the data you want and if you are
interested in finding out a particular
value now how do we do this so for
example let me get rid of this now we
know how we can find out the category of
items but we would want to find out
which sub category of items sold the
maximum under each category so here we
are not looking at sales but we are
looking at the quantity
okay
so what we can do is we can go to the
first row and first column click on
insert click on pivot table data is
already selected let's choose existing
worksheet let's choose a location in our
worksheet where we would want to have
this so might be i can select this
particular field and then just close
this
so it says
this is the existing worksheet say ok
and now you need to select your
columns
so for example
if i would want the data for categories
so i can select this now i know that
within category these are the options
which we have and then there is a sub
category so let's select that and if you
see here
now we have the data which will be
filtered so based on your category and
sub category and then we will choose
quantity so it automatically understands
that this is something on which
summation can be done so let's select
this and close on this now if you see
here we have got our items
where we can see
the sub categories within a particular
category now i can basically close this
and that just shows me
high level categories here so here
i can
again
select a particular
row and column i can go for
either a new pivot table so we could
basically select this the row is already
selected
existing worksheet is what i want so now
i will select
this particular place
say okay now we do the same thing like
what we did earlier
so we will select category subcategory
and quantity so the data has already
come in
just select this and now you already
have all your data but this is not what
we want we want to basically apply a
filter
to this now how do we do that so we can
go for
slicer so i can go for insert slicer and
then it tells
what are
the sub categories which you are
interested in so for example
if i go for something like
sub category and say okay
so this tells me
what are the categories you are
interested in so for example we know
that furniture has furnishings with the
highest value so i can select say
furnishings
and then
i was interested in office supplies
so within office supply i can basically
search for
here
binder so i can just do a control and
select binder
and then i can also know for technology
i can select phones so i'll say control
and select phones
and now if you see the filter has been
applied
and we have these sub categories which
are selected so we have our data here
now we don't need really this so i can
just delete this
and i have my data which shows me
furniture being the main category and
that has only furnishings office supply
having binders and technology having
phones and that basically
is a filter applied on the result of
your pivot so this is how we are seeing
which sub category of items
were sold
maximum for each category
so this is how you can easily use pivot
tables and you can do some analysis
let's look at some more examples
now
let's see if you have to answer this
question which says which were the top
three states for each region
that made the highest average profit
now how do we calculate that
so for example this is the data we have
and as i have instructed earlier you can
select the first row and first column
you can click on insert go into pivot
table
and that basically selects all your data
we will choose the result should be in
this existing worksheet so select this
click here
and then basically
let's select
this cell
and
i will say okay so now my pivot table
will be here so we are interested in
finding out top three states within each
region which have made the highest
profit or which have made the highest
average profit so for that first we will
select
region so when we select region it shows
here region and within region you will
then select state so
within every region you have multiple
states so that's what we are selecting
and then we are interested in looking at
the profit so let's select profit and
that automatically shows up here
so we can now say close this
so basically we have all the data but we
are looking at the sum of profit but
that's not what we want
we are looking for
top three states
from each region that made the highest
average profit
now how do we change that so here we
have sum of profit so i can do a right
click
and basically i can say summarize values
by average so now i'm getting the
average here and that basically tells
per region
i have the average profit
but first is let's sort this data so
let's go into sort more options and here
i have average of profit
or for example as i said you can select
region say okay
and now it is
basically having the
regions
and then you have your state value so
again we can do a
sorting here and i can say
let's go for more sort options i'll say
descending
the state values should be based on
average profit so let's say okay and now
if you see
in particular region we have
the data which has been
sorted
wherein you have the highest average
profit on the top
now what we can also do is we can
basically
then go for filtering we can say top 10
but i am not interested in top 10 so i
could reduce this to top three
and this is the items average of profit
say okay and now you see per region
you have
the data which is
showing me top three states what are the
average and then you are also looking at
the subtotal so which basically says
average profit for your west now if you
would want to arrange this
your west and south and east and central
in a particular alphabetical order if
you would want to sort it you can always
do a sorting and you can choose sort z
to a
if that's what you would want to do or
you can go for
sorting
more sort options
and you want to
sort the region which is as of now
based on descending z2a let's make it
ascending say okay
and now you see the data has been
filtered so it says per region
now you can always select this and you
can say what is this so this is
basically your average of profit now
we are looking at
each region and the states the top three
states as we wanted
within the region and what is the
average
now we have one more question what is
the percentage contribution of each sub
category of products under each category
to the total sales so we know there are
different products
there are different categories and
all the categories contribute to the
total sales so we would want to find out
what is the percentage contribution of
each sub category
of products
under each category so we not only want
the
category percentage but we would also
want what is the contribution of each
sub category
to
each category to the total sales how do
we do that so for that we need to again
just place
our cursor here or select the first row
and first column
click on your insert click on your pivot
table and now the data is already
selected existing worksheet
place your cursor here
and then let's select this
cell say okay
now your pivot table fields are here so
we are interested in category
so let's select category
and then within a category we will have
sub categories and we are interested in
the sales data
wherein it is already going to give us
the sum of sales but we would want this
in the form of percentage rather than
just the sum now we can click here value
field settings
and it says if you would want to
summarize this it says show value as
and
what are the values you would want so
you can straight away go ahead here and
say percentage of grand total so we
could do that because we know
we will get a sum of sales and grand
total now i could basically say
in the percentage of grand total say
okay
and then
just close this
so once you have closed this you see
already the data is in
percentage so now we have our data with
subcategories but we also want the data
to be sorted might be in a descending
order which tells which subcategory is
contributing more than others we can
select how many subcategories we are
interested in so we can basically select
one of the sub category cells
right click now you have option filter
and you have sorting so we can say more
sort options
now here i will say descending and
you want the
descending to be sum of sales which is
already showing as percentage
click on ok and now you see for each
category
it shows the percentage contribution
towards the sales
it shows the sub categories contribution
to a particular category and also to
total sales
so technically speaking if you look at
all these values which are sub
categories and if you would total them
that would be your total grand total so
this is how we can solve a simple
problem like this what is the percentage
contribution of each sub category of
products under
each category to the total sales
the next question is which customer made
the lowest profit in the home office
segment in each state now here we know
that we are looking for
home office segment
we are looking for customer which made
the lowest profit
we are also looking for the state
as the main
criteria so
in each state
we would look for home office segment
and within that we would look for
customer which has made the lowest
profit that means
the lowest value
of the profit so how do we do this so
let's say let's get into
selecting our row and column we will go
into insert i'll say pivot table
i'll say existing worksheet
and let me get my result here so let's
say okay
now that gives me the pivot table so the
first thing is we are looking at
per
state
and
i would be interested in
home office segment or i could first
start with segment
now here we have segment and in segment
i can basically select home office so i
can just do a uncheck and select home
office only
and now i can select
state
so that will be my
sub category within segment and then
within state
we would want to find out the customer
so let's get the customer name
and we are interested in finding out the
lowest profit so let's select profit
and here we have sum of profits so the
fields are selected close this
and now you have your data
which basically shows me
the names of customers which made the
profit but it's
it's not sorted so we can sort this
and we have state entries also so that's
fine so what i can do is here
i can basically say sorting go to more
sort options
i can say i want to do a descending or i
want to do an ascending and ascending
based on
sum of profit so let's do that now you
see
the top most value is the lowest value
per state
within home office segment now what we
also want is we just want one value per
state
so how do we do that so we can just
go for filtering go for top 10 values
i'm interested in bottom value and in
that also
i'm looking for only the
lowest value so let's select one
say okay and now you see we have data
for home office segment
per
state customer who has made the lowest
profit
so we have easily answered this question
using our pivot table
now say for example we have a question
which says find the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions
so the data has to be divided quarterly
and use order year as a slicer we can do
that by selecting what data we would
want to slice
and then we would want to create a pivot
chart also so for example how do we do
that
so for example i will get rid of this
i will get rid of
this my pivot chart which we can
recreate
so find the sales made in each quarter
of 2016 for all the regions
so this is what we want
now how do we do this
so for example let's select this
we will do a insert pivot table we will
basically say existing worksheet
and then i can select this particular
cell i'll say okay
and now
i am interested in data quarterly so
first let's select
our field here so we should basically
have
if all our fields are selected say for
example if i say order date
now
you see we have quarters and years which
are selected
now we could be selecting these fields
which says
quarters years
and if i would want data to be filtered
based on years i could do that or i
could get rid of here so i have quarters
i have order date
so
that's being already selected now
what else we need we need to find out
for every region so let's select the
region
and we can also add region as a column
here so that will basically give me all
the regions
as different columns and then finally we
want the sales so let's select this
and now
let's look what we have
so if you see here
we have our data
which is
for each quarter
it gives me the total data but what we
would be interested in is not looking at
the total data but we are only
interested in quarter of
2016. now how do we do that so what we
do here is we have row labels
so let's click on this so we have date
filters
and then in date filters we can go for
between and then we will say
2016
and the value has to be 1
and then let's select
this and let's change this to 2016
and
this is 12th month
and then we can say 31.
so we are saying the date has to be 2016
and it basically says not a valid date
so let's select
let's select a particular date and see
so the month has to be here
so let's see in this and let's make it
date
and say okay
and now we have our data which is
for
2016.
so for example i could basically select
this
and here i could be
looking at
what are the filters we have so it says
clear filter from order data
so we have applied the filter on order
date
and
these are your date filters which is
basically
date
16 oh this is wrong so this one has to
be changed to 2016.
so select this and now we have our data
for
2016.
so we have found the sales made in each
quarter of 2016 for all the regions the
grand total
for a particular quarter if we are
looking at the value
or for individual months in a particular
quarter
and we have sliced the data now we could
have also
introduced a slicer by selecting
which field we would want to implement
so for example if i would select a
particular field and then i could click
on slicer i could choose i would want to
slice the date based on order date and
then could have done it or we have just
given the
date for 2016. now we just need to
plot a graph for this and that's very
easy so you just need to select
the complete pivot data and here you
have the chart options so let's go for
line chart
and that basically shows me the line
chart
so we can select this we can just drag
and drop it here
and then
we can basically check if that is
showing us the data so if you see here
this is line chart where it has divided
the regions in different colors
so we have all the regions we could
filter out in pivot chart a particular
region
we have
the quarterly
time here in order data the filter is
applied it says it is 2016
in quarters it tells me it is 16. so we
have our data we have created a pivot
chart
and basically we have sliced the data
for
2016.
let's answer one more question and
that's finding the profit made in each
year
for all the categories of products
in east and west regions only and then
we would want to create a histogram for
the same pivot table so histogram
usually gives us the frequencies so
let's look at how do we calculate the
profit made in each year for all the
categories so what i can do is i can
basically
select my
row id here and now i'll do a pivot
table
so the data is already selected i'll
choose existing worksheet let's select
this particular cell say okay now what
are we interested in now if you look at
the fields we don't see any
years or quarters and so on so for
example here i can just choose order
date
and then basically
i can choose say for example
years or quarters
the data which is coming out from my
order date so here i will just select
years now
then i have my order date
so
we are interested in the years
orders and
we are interested in
let's look at our column or the question
what we had here
so we have years
find the profit made in each year so
let's select
profit so that basically says sum of
profit
but then
i'm on also interested in
for all the categories of products so
what i can do is here
i have my field which is category and
that i'll add to the columns so that
shows me what are the different
categories
and this looks fine now i'm also
interested in east and west regions so
that is basically in the region so
either we could add a slicer or we could
do a filtering here by adding the
filters so first is i'll click on region
and here it says select all i'm only
interested in east and west so let's
select this
take this
put it here
let's say okay and now
we have the data which has been filtered
based on the region so here we have
region so you can always look at the
filter it is east and west
and we have
our year data
per year we have
different categories you can always look
at what are these column labels so this
is my different categories
and this is the profit per category
and then you have your grand total so we
have already our data now let's say
close this so we have our data for all
these years different categories the
profits made per year
and if i would want i could go into an
year and i could look into different
months so that also
is showing up and now we would want to
basically plot a histogram with this
data so i can just
place my cursor here i can select this
and then i can go into insert and here i
have different options so we can go for
bar chart
we can go for insert hierarchy chart
we can go into waterfall funnel stock
surface or radar chart so there are
different options what you have here and
we will go for a simple histogram which
is two dimensional
let's select this and here you see you
can obviously select different regions
you have your years
which shows up
you have your order date
and then you have your categories which
can be chosen for your histogram or for
your bar chart and that basically is how
you use your pivot table you use some
calculations and then you can plot your
needed graph to visualize the data and
understand it in a better way let's look
at an example of
one more useful function
in excel and that is vlookup now vlookup
is used to see if a value exists in a
range of values and we can create a
range of values which is nothing but
a block of cells which has a name
and can be referenced so
mainly to use vlookup we need to create
a named range
and that can be referenced anywhere in
the workbook or the other option is you
can always drag and select
uh the range of data in which you would
want to search something now there is
also
uh other functions such as hlookup which
pretty much does the same thing however
it does it horizontally that is left to
right instead of vertically there are
other functions like lookup and x lookup
and so on so when we talk about vlookup
let's see how we do that so for example
this is the range
of or this is the data which has been
given to you and here is the question
find the employee name with employee id
107. now assume that you might have huge
amount of data and you may want to
search something so how do we do it now
here i have created some column and then
some basic formatting i have given it as
an employee id i have given employee
name now what i can do is i can create a
range of data now how do i do that or a
named range so what you can do is you
can select the data and then you can do
a right click now here you have
something like get data from table range
so you can do that you can define a name
so you can click on this
and here
you can give a
name to the range what you would want to
call it so for example let's say our
search
now that's the named range i'm creating
and just say okay so the scope is
workbook and i've created a named range
which you can see here so it shows for
search our search so you have created a
named range now how do we do a vlookup
here so for that we can use a formula so
for example i would want to search for
employee name where employee id is
whatever you would want to search for
so employee id we can give here 107. now
that's what we would want to search the
employee name for
and employee name is what we are
interested now what we can do is we can
use the function option here i can do a
insert function and that shows me
different functions which are here now
vlookup is showing up because i have
recently searched for it or
you can
basically just type in here look
and you can do a go so that shows you
all the look of options what you have
like look up h look up match vlookup and
so on so we would be interested in
vlookup so let's select that and click
on ok now that basically opens up this
function arguments and it shows what
does this function do so it says looks
for a value in the most column of a
table
and then returns a value in the same row
from a column you specify
by default the table must be sorted in
an ascending order now you can
basically say this is what you would
want to search for what is the lookup
value if you place your cursor here it
says what is the table array that is
nothing but the range which we can use
our named range here we have the column
index number which basically tells me
what is the column number in the range
which we want so what is the value we
want from which column and then
basically you have range lookup which
basically is the fourth option
and range lookup is nothing but
it can have two values so true or false
so true basically means closest match
and then false should be an exact match
so let's do that so for lookup value we
would want to
give a particular value which is nothing
but
we would be interested in say employee
name
so i can
basically
search for a value based on the lookup
value now how do we do it so we are
saying we would want to search for
employee id which is 107. so what i can
do is i can select this
cell here which tells that this is the
value
or employee id for which i would want to
search the employee name i could
actually select the cell here which is h
so that whatever value you feed in here
you can search for that value so might
be we can select this one which is h6
and whatever value we key in here we
will be searching for employee name for
that employee id
now table array is we would want to give
a range so what we can do is we can give
our range so for example we had selected
something like our search
and if you see here that already selects
or shows me employee id employee name
email address so it gives me the range
now
column index number so which
column are we interested in that means
what is the value we are searching for
so we are searching for employee name
which is the second column so i can just
say 2
and that basically is the column number
and then you have to give a range lookup
which is a logical value so either you
give an exact match
or
you can basically give a
closest match so we can say for example
do a 0 which basically means false or
you can say 1 which is true so let's go
for 0 now that's our formula so it says
vlookup you will search for the value as
per h6
in the range and then you are looking
for employee name which is column number
two and then true or false so let's
click on ok
and that basically gives me the value
which is parallel up
birch
so here i'm searching for employee name
and you can basically drag this
for other columns and you can do that so
if it finds
employee
id here now say for example
if we had an employee id somebody enters
an employee id which is not in the range
for example let's try
121 and then you see this is basically
an error right because
it does not have any employee id with
121. now how do i take care of this so
there is a formula which is called if
error and that can be used to take care
of this
so if the value is not found then it
will
show whatever i would want to
show here so what i can do is i can
still select this
and what i can do is i can search in
function
say for example this is the function we
are looking at but what we can do is
we can test it here so for example if i
look in function and if i search for
error and say oh
go
so there are lots of
functions here and this is the function
we are interested in if error so if i
say ok now this takes the value and what
is the value if error
so for value what i can do is basically
i can select
the value from here which is nothing but
our vlookup formula and value if error
so for example
i will basically say for example not
found so we can try this and we can say
okay now here it says not found so
whenever it is n a it is not found
now
if we look at the formula here it says
if error it takes the value of h7 which
is nothing but our vlookup and then it
is
showing us the value which we have
entered so for example if i would say
107
like earlier and then hit on enter so it
says panel of cruise and it shows us the
value
right and if we enter something else
then basically
here it shows any and it shows not found
but what we want to do is we want to
merge these two so what i can do is i
can get rid of
or i can basically take this one
now
what i would want is i want this formula
to
be here
so what i can do is i can say if error
and then
basically
given your vlookup
option or function here and then say for
example not found here
not found now that basically will take
care of any kind of error if the value
is not found so when we say 121 it
basically says not found but if i say
107 which is found then it shows me the
value so we are using vlookup but then
we are also using if error which will
take care of our error message or
basically the not applicable
pound not applicable replaced with
whatever value we key in
similarly we can do the same thing here
so we have the find the job title so we
are interested in finding out the job
title once the employee name is given
now employee name can basically have a
value from the cell or whatever value
you would want to key in
how do we do it so we basically start
with our v
lookup so that's the
function we are interested in
so you can just do a double click
now you are interested in finding out
the value whichever is given here
so that's the lookup value
and then you are interested in
finding out the job title from the range
so i will still give our range which
basically
also shows for example let's do a
double click here and that basically
selects the range
and now i'm interested in finding out
the job title so that's column number
four
and then i can just give zero which is
for false so now we have given our
vlookup but that shows not applicable
because we have not given any employee
name so we can key in the value here
which says fred stone and now
if we are basically giving the value so
fred stone now
we will have to search if there is any
job title which is fred stone so here is
the value so that should be showing up
let's check what has gone wrong so we
are giving our range
we are interested in
finding out the value but what the
mistake what we did here was
that when we want to search for a value
say for example let's take this vlookup
and let's replace this value of h12 with
the
value here so fredstone
and then basically we will give our
range we will save which is the column
we are interested in and then give true
or false
so
we can also
basically take care of this error
message so for example let's take this
complete formula from here
and just
just copy this formula
and now we can put in here the formula
but then this is where we were searching
for h6 which was employee id
now that's not what we are interested in
we are interested in finding out the
value
so
let's take this one and replace this
with
the value given here
and then i give my range i say which is
the column i'm interested in so i'm
interested in looking for job title
and then let's search so it basically
tells me
not found so let's check this
now the error which we were facing was
because when we talk about your vlookup
let's look at the formula again and here
say for example i go for function
and then i select vlookup and say for
example i say okay
now just look at the description here
looks for a value in the left most
column of a table
now earlier the range which we had
selected had the left most column as
employee id and that's why it was giving
an error so how do we fix that so for
example let's
basically
remove this function from here
now what we want to do is we would want
to search for the stock broker now if
you see here i have given a range which
is b
1 to d 21
so we would want
the value for what we would want to
search say employee name that should be
the leftmost column so
so that's how
we have our function so let's do that so
say for example the name is given here
so we want a range so either we can
create a range like earlier by selecting
say for example this data
now am i interested in salary no i'm
interested in job title right so i can
basically just three columns
and then i can define a name so i can
say our
search
to
and let's give a named range and that's
only because we would want to easily
reference or use that named
search or name range now here we would
want to use vlookup but we would also do
an if error
now within that we can say
we
look up
and then you need to
select what is the value what your
function takes
so basically this is my function we will
say if the value is not found then we
will give this so you can create an
external structure
and then within your vlookup we will say
the leftmost column which we are
interested in
so
that's your employee name
so in employee name we have the value so
either i can directly select the value
here in the column b or i will give the
value whichever is fed in here the
employee name
then i need to give a range so let's
select our range so that's your hour
search too
and then you need to select the column
number
so we are interested in finding out the
job title so that's the third column so
let's say three and then just give a 0
and then hit on enter so it says not
found because you have not given any
employee name now
let's
try to find the job title of fred stone
so i can just select or i can say equal
and then i can just given a value and
that basically shows me the job title so
this is how you use vlookup
we have also used if error which
basically takes care of error message if
the value is not found so for example we
can test this
here we have fred stone
so for example if i
just empty this and i point it to
something which does not exist so that
shows me not found or if you just select
this and then key in a value it shows
you this might be we can just type in so
if i say fred
then basically it says not found because
we are looking for exact match now if we
had changed this to the closest match
something like this then it would have
tried to find something but then we
don't have anything which is just with
this
so there are different ways of doing it
so what we can do is we can always go
for the exact match
and that's basically the value
and here we can basically key in any
value for example i would be interested
in finding out
this one
and let's give this so you can search in
this way so you can also have statements
which can be searching one related to
other
now here the question was to find the
job title of fred stone so let's type in
fred stone and that basically shows me
the job title which we are interested in
so let's search for
job title let's go for exact match and
then search so it is stock broker so if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now that we have looked at vlookup it
would be interesting to see how
horizontal lookup or edge lookup works
it basically works in the on the same
lines but here
instead of vertically searching through
the columns the range is more of
horizontally defined so we search
in rows rather than in columns so for
example this is the data which has been
given to you and you have various
columns so you have employee id you have
your employee name
you have employee email address
you basically have the job title of
different employees
and then basically you have the salary
so this is the data which has been given
to you and you are asked to search or
you are interested in finding out say
the salary based on employee name or job
title based on employee id so what we
need to do is we need to define the
range here
now range can depend on what you are
searching for so for example when i am
searching employee name and salary so i
am interested in these four rows when
i'm saying employee id and job title
then might be this is the range and i
don't need salary so i can create a
named range if we are interested in so
that we can easily search for it or we
can straight away give
the
the first cell value which is basically
a 1 here
and then the last
value here which is g and then you can
give 5 so you can do that or you can
create a named range whichever way you
would want to do it so for example we
would want to create a named range for
our first question which is
find the salary of eden connell using h
lookup so we are interested in this so
let's select
these four rows all the way for your
columns now
like we did earlier we can just define a
name
might be we can call it our
search 3
and we can just give ok so that's the
named range which we have created
now what we would want is we want to
search for the salary based on employee
name
so here we can insert our function so
let's look up
and let's search for look
and just click on go so here you have h
look up and basically that's the
function i'm interested in say okay
so this says what is the lookup value
which you are interested in so we are
interested in finding out the value
based on the employee name
so for example let's select this cell
that gives us more dynamism and you can
add in any name and you can search for
the salary
or you can basically give the employee
name exactly from the employee name
value here which is d
two so we can give edin conal from here
so let's select this now table array so
we need to give our range so let's say
our search three
then you need to give the row index
number now this is different than
vlookup in vlookup you have column index
number and here you have row index
number so what are you interested in
searching for so we are interested in
searching for salary now in our range
that is basically the fourth row
remember we created a range from
employee name
to salary so let's give the row index
number which is 4 and the range lookup
will say 0 which is basically exact
match and that completes our formula so
click on ok and that basically gives me
the salary for edin connell now that's
basically because we have fed in the
value here
and that is basically giving me this so
i can again
do if error if i would be interested in
to basically take care of error message
if the value is not found for that you
can look into the previous example which
is vlookup now similarly we are
interested in finding out the job title
for employee id 1 0 5 how do we do that
so we need to use edge lookup
well we could have done with vlookup but
here the data is more arranged in the
form of rows
so how do we do that so we can again use
hlookup but and we can give a range
or named range or let's for this time
let's basically key in our range
manually so we can do that so let's go
for h lookup
now what do we want to search for so we
will say this is the value
then we need to give a range
now as i said if you would want to give
a range manually so for example i will
say a
and then i will say a
1
colon and then i'm interested in
g
and then the row will be 4 so salary row
is not what we are we are not interested
in so let's say g
and then we can give 4 so that basically
gives me the range
right instead of having a named range so
we can do that and then we need to give
the row index number so we are
interested in finding out the job title
which is basically in our range the
fourth row and then give zero for true
or false so if you see here it tells if
it is one it is approximate match
false is an exact match and we can close
this bracket that completes our formula
it takes the value which is given in
employee id and then it will try to
search for the job title so that
basically shows wherever the employee id
is 105
the job title is fabricator again you
can use if error
wherein
your if error can then be working on
hlookup and can take care of error so
that if an employee id is keyed in
for which there is no matching value
then
it will
not show you
a not applicable error in
instead of that it will replace with the
word whatever you have specified so in
this way you can easily use hlookup to
search
from the range of data which is
horizontally arranged and in the
previous example we were seeing how you
use vlookup when the data is arranged
vertically
so we have looked at
vlookup and hlookup and what we have
seen is vlookup has a limitation in one
way that we need to basically give a
range where the leftmost column is the
one which is
used now instead of that we might be
interested in searching in specific
columns and not all the columns well
that can also affect the time taken to
search for the data
wherein we can select particular columns
or particular ranges rather than
selecting all the data which has to be
searched for
so for example we have this question
find the salary of hank saunders
now that's the employee name which we
have here and we would want to find out
the salary so what are the columns we
are interested in so one is your
employee name and one is your salary and
these are the only two columns which we
are interested in so instead of using
vlookup now like i've shown earlier you
can create a named range for these two
columns and you can use that
or we can manually give the range here
so let's go for lookup function here and
lookup function will basically help us
in searching what we are interested in
so we are interested in finding out the
employee name
and we are interested in finding out the
salary based on the employee name so how
do we do that so here in lookup i can
first give the value which is here
employee name now
whatever
employee name is keyed in here we will
be searching for salary of that employee
now lookup function needs a lookup value
so we are searching
based on employee name then it says
lookup vector so we will basically then
say
what is going to be our lookup vector so
here we need to give a range so what are
we interested in we are interested in
finding out the salary based on employee
name so first goes our range
based on which we need to search so
that's your employee name so let's for
example select this one so that's our
range b1 to b21
so that will basically have the employee
name in which we will be searching for
and then we are interested in searching
out the
the result vector that is basically the
column from which we want the value
that's our salary column so let's select
this
and that completes our lookup function
so now if you hit on enter it shows that
for this employee where the name is hunk
saunders the salary is 5400
now you can test it by
basically giving some other name so for
example if i replace this with
say
fred stone
and that basically shows me the value
for fredstone we can replace it to the
question which we have that is hank
saunders and that shows me the salary so
that's a simple example of lookup which
allows you to search by selecting a
range of columns rather than having the
left most column which has to be
referenced similarly we have one more
question find the employee id
of
this particular email id so we need to
again use our lookup function so we'll
say lookup now what are we interested in
we will search based on this email
address so i will select this
then i need to give
that based on email address we are
searching the employee id so email
address is in this column so let's
select this range
and then we are interested in employee
id so then goes
our result vector so select this column
and that basically completes your
formula so close this bracket and hit on
enter so that basically shows me the
employee id for an employee with this
email address so this is how you use
lookup now as i've explained earlier you
can be using the if error and you can
basically see how
your
index match can be used now here is an
example of if error
so basically this shows how if error
helps so say for example as i showed in
your employee james bond if the value is
not present display not found and what
are we doing we are basically nesting
our vlookup
inside if error with a not found option
which basically says if the value
given in this cell h
is not found then basically
it will
display not found so here you also
notice that the range which has been
given has been selected that is b1 to
c21 now we could have used a named range
which basically helps us in searching
for multiple functions
we are searching for 2 that is the
column number 2 here that is employee
name
so check for employee james bond if the
value is not present or no so we are
basically just searching for employee
name
here and then give your zero or one so
that's basically usage of your if error
which i have shown earlier and the same
thing can be applied for your edge
lookup also
now suppose you have been given some
additional questions for example
you know instead of using your vlookup
or h lookup or lookup examples what we
have seen
say for example you are asked to find
the salary of peter daniels now we
already know how to find that using
vlookup
right so for example we want to find out
the salary for this employee name which
is peter daniels i can use a vlookup
however sometimes we may also want to
use a index match an index match is also
one useful function to do that so we can
basically search based on that so we
have to define the range
of data we have to then say what do we
want to match so that's basically an
employee name
and then we are interested in finding
out
say for example
based on the range
of
employees you would want to find out
the value of salary so we are then
giving a range and doing it how do we do
that so for example here i can use a
function which is called index
and if you see here it says returns a
value or reference of the cell
at the intersection of a particular row
and column in a given range so this is
where index function can be useful now
we can start with this function it says
it needs an array that's nothing but a
range so we can basically select all our
data so i can say a1
all the way to e21 so that basically is
my range
now i would want to find the salary of
this employee name which is peter
daniels so i can use internally here
basically you need to give a row number
so what we can do is we can do a match
so we can use an internal function match
now we need to basically
give it correctly so we need to say
match
now how does this match function work so
we need to basically match for a value
so for example we'll select whatever
employee name is given here so that's
peter daniels now that's basically what
we would want to match now where do we
want to match this so we want to match
in the column b which has employee
names so we can give a range which is b1
to be
21 so that's basically
within the employee names we are looking
for a match
which is given here that's in h6
and we want to do a match so we want to
do a exact match so let's do a comma 0
and then
we are interested in finding out the
salary
based on this match and salary is in our
fifth column so let's basically give the
column number here and then just close
this bracket
so that basically
completes your function and just hit on
enter so that shows me
the salary of peter daniels right so
this is an easy way when you can use the
index function remember first you give
the range
and then you need to give your matching
condition so when you say match i would
take the value whatever is given in this
cell
i will search in the range of values
which is employee names
i will find an exact match and what i'm
interested in is finding the salary for
peter daniels now similarly say for
example you have been given a question
find the employee id with salary 10 000.
so you want to find out the employee id
wherever the salary is 10 000. so we are
obviously looking for an exact match now
how do we do that so we can start with
our index function and with an index
function we need to give a range
so for example i am interested in
finding out
say for example
our range which is a 1
2
e 21 so that's what i'm interested in
or you are actually interested in
searching
based on
say your
salary so you are interested in
searching the employee id so maybe if i
just do a 821 let's see what happens
here
now then i can just do a match
so match will be now done based on the
value which is here h
13
so i will do a match for this one now i
need to give a range
so let's
basically give a range which will be we
are interested in
searching employee id based on the
salary column so that's your e column so
i will say e1 to e21 that's what i'm
interested in searching
finding a match for this salary we want
an exact match so first let's close this
one now
that's fine i mean we are interested in
finding out the employee id
based on the match which is within this
range
and
then what we would want to do is we
would want to
basically find the employee id employee
id is in my
column a so what i can do is i can
additionally give a match here
and then i can say i'm interested in the
finding out the value for employee id
and that basically needs a range so the
range here will be just the
the column headings so we will give a1
all the way to e 1 so that's the range
in which we would want to search and we
would want to find a match for employee
id we want an exact match so let's close
this one and that basically closes my
match and we need to close our index
function so now that shows me employee
id where the salary is 10 000.
so this is how you can do your index
matches where you can give a range
then you can say what you need to match
within which particular column whether
it is an exact match or approximate
match and then the column from where you
are interested in finding out the value
so same thing we did here
we basically gave a complete range and
if you closely see
we were only interested in finding out
the employee id so here i gave a range
a1 to a21 which is basically this
particular column so that's where we are
interested in finding out
match basically will give your lookup
value so that's h13
then we gave a range which is salary
that's what we are interested in and
then we said when we are doing a match
we are only interested in finding out
the employee id
which is in a range of column names and
then doing an exact match so this is how
you can use index match instead of
lookup which can also give you
some exceptions and searching for
specific columns or specific rows
now if error we have already discussed
where you nest your vlookup or h lookup
inside it
so this is how you can use your lookup
functions hlookup
vlookup
lookup or index match to search for data
some function like this which shows up
xln dot x lookup
and then you're trying to search for
something so don't be
surprised with that so xln is basically
a prefix added to functions that don't
exist in the version of excel you are
using
you have excel 2013 and say your friend
has a new version of excel say office
365 or excel 2016 and basically he uses
your new cool function and sends the
file to you so that's where
you will have this excellent prefix as i
am showing up here so for example what
is the job title of xavier power is what
you would want to search and here the
function which shows up xl and x lookup
and then you are searching so this is
basically something which is the
function now if i just select what it
has selected here and if i hit on enter
it shows that this does not work in my
excel here and that's because of the
version but what i can do is i can fix
this by removing this
details here
and that basically shows lookup we are
searching for
job title based on employee name which
is in this field h6
and then we need to give a range so we
need to give a range of names employee
name
and then basically
the
job title range which is basically the
job title so now if i just hit on enter
it gives me the value so it's as simple
as that similarly here what is the
employee id of the person with this
email we have already looked at the
lookup function so if it shows your xlnx
lookup all you need to do is remove this
and then keep the lookup function
searching for the value
based on the range of values and then
searching for a value within a range of
values so just hit on enter and that
gives you the value and same thing goes
for this job title so what is the job
title and salary of employee name
so we have this function now what i can
do is
here i'm interested in finding out the
value for this particular function how
do i fix this i can basically select
this
and then just do a lookup
based on the values and
it basically says you can't change part
of an array so we can fix this
now what we need to do is we need to
basically search based on
this particular value so we will
basically say i want to do a lookup
now lookup should be based on employee
name whatever name is given here
then you need to find the job title in
salary so for job title i want to find
based on employee name so i will give a
range
and then basically i will say i'm
interested in finding out the job title
so i will give a different range
and then basically close this so
that basically shows
now this is basically because of the
function which we have here so basically
to fix this what we will have to do is
we will have to delete all the columns
here which were selected such as
employee name job title and salary
because that was giving you
an error you cannot delete a part of an
array now what we want to do is we want
to find the job title and salary based
on the employee name so we can do that
using lookup as we have done earlier so
we will use a lookup function
now what we are interested in finding
out is the job title based on employee
name so we can select this cell which
does not have any value
then we need to basically say
from which range or based on what you
want to search so we want to search
based on employee name
and we want to find out the job title so
we can basically give a range of values
and then we will be interested in
finding out the job title
so let's select the job title range and
that basically completes our lookup so
let's close this and hit on enter now it
says obviously error because this does
not have any value
we will fix that by giving in a value
here
same thing we can do for salary so for
example i can just drag and drop it here
and in this one instead of
basically having a range which is your
we will be interested in finding out the
salary so
let's see what is the range we give
so the range should be employee name
so we will basically select employee
name as the range
and then
we are interested in finding out
the salary so we will select this
particular range
and what we are interested in finding
out is basically
employee name
or we are interested in finding out
based on employee name so let's select
this particular column and then hit or
enter so both of these are any values
now just feed in an employee name so we
will say for example eduardo and that
basically gives me the job title and
salary so that's how you can fix
your
excel fn error so same thing goes here
so it shows you xln is what you would
want to search might be if you don't
find something you would want to
push in name not found so first is we
will have to fix this part so we will
have to remove this because that's not
supported in my excel and then i have
lookup i'm searching based on h24
which is basically employee id you are
giving a range which is a2 to 821
because we would want to find
name not found
for a particular employee id so i'm
giving a range which is a2 to 821
i'm trying to search for the name which
is from b2 to b21 and then i'm giving
name not found so
say for example we can do this lookup
but then
with lookup you don't have this direct
option what we can do is we can use if
error
if error and then basically try to
search so that gives your lookup value
and then you will have to close this one
and then again if it gives you some
error like this we can obviously go for
vlookup and fix this so here we are
searching for a particular range
and then let's search for this value
and basically to fix this what i did was
i just use a vlookup so we know that
employee id 121 does not exist so i'm
just using if error i'm doing a vlookup
where i'm searching for the value given
in h 19
and then
i'm saying that i would want to search
from a range which is basically b1 to
c21 that is in employee name and say
email address for example
and we would want to basically search
for name not found so we can
instead of giving b21 or b1 to c21 we
can restrict it to just b1 to b21
we are searching in column two we are
searching for exact value and if it does
not find then it says name not found and
that's how we do it so we can always
replace and fix this excel fn
errors
if you
are
using
uh some spreadsheet which was or excel
which was sent by
um someone else who is using a different
version let's quickly see
some more examples of doing data
analysis using excel and for that we can
use
some inbuilt add-ins which can be added
to our excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive analytics
or descriptive analysis on your data say
for example getting your descriptive
statistics such as your mean median mode
and so on so we can do that and we can
use excel for it so for example you can
if you are given some data say i have
temperature price of ice cream units
sold and i would want to have
descriptive statistics on this what i
can do is i can click on file
and here in file you can click on
options and within options click on
add-ins
now within add-ins you have excel
add-ins which is selected here so click
on say go for example and that shows
what add-ins are available and you can
choose which ones are you interested in
so for example i have chosen analysis
tool pack
and solver add-in and click on ok now
that basically should add more options
to your excel so if you click on data
so here you see data analysis and solver
and this is what we would want to use to
get our descriptive statistics for these
three columns
so for example let's say
temperature
or you can even give the names later
once you get your descriptive statistics
so for example let's go for data
analysis
and here it says what are you interested
in there is a two factor with
replication you have correlation
covariance descriptive statistics you
have histogram so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on ok now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said
grouped by so let's give it a range so
for example i will say say temperature
now if i do this and i have selected the
heading just look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking here
let's
select save fields here
and this is where i would want the
output now it also said what options do
you want so it has output range we can
then select summary statistics
confidence level so i will say summary
statistics is what i'm interested in say
okay and this says input input range
contains non-numeric data now why is
that because we chose temperature the
heading also so click on ok and here we
will alter the range
so this one
is our range should be
only
the values numeric values on which we
would want the descriptive statistics we
have output range already selected we
have summary statistics
and now you can click on ok
and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here
i could basically
given a value for this so i can say
temperature
and that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature might be i can just do some
formatting
and
that's it so that gives me descriptive
statistics for the values here
now similarly we can do it for price of
ice cream
so what we need is
we need to basically
go for data
data analysis
descriptive statistics say okay
now you need to give a range so here i
will
change my range to these values output
range is already selected
now we are interested in summary
statistics click on ok
and this says output range will
overwrite existing data press ok to
overwrite data in range
i will say cancel no that's not what we
want to do we need to give a new range
so let's select our new range which is
here
and now click on ok
so now we get the values which is for
your price of ice cream so again we can
basically
select this and say price of ice cream
and we got our descriptive statistics
for price of ice cream and like we did
earlier i can select this i can
basically do a merge and center and that
gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this
now i can go into data and i can go into
data analysis
descriptive statistics so we know that
we had selected this b2 to b8
and this one which is h6 to h19 we would
want to shift it
might be two columns up so might be i
can just say h5
and i can manually change it to h17
and let's say okay
and
we will basically get this and i can get
rid of this
so i can have it in the same range
so similarly so this one will have to be
renamed and i can basically say price of
ice cream
and that's basically my descriptive
statistics for my price of ice cream
and similarly we can do it for the third
column which is units sold
so we would want to have this now let's
see we can click on data we can click on
data analysis descriptive statistics so
we need to give the range correctly so
this time our range changes to units
sold
now we can also say labels in first row
okay if
we were selecting the heading so let's
do it in this way so in my range
in my range
let me empty this
i can basically select this which we
know
has non-numeric data in the first row
say for example i'll say labels in first
row i'm interested in summary statistics
and this range will now have to be
changed from h
to basically something like
j
so let's say j
and let's select these values so that
should take care of things and now you
see you have your units sold you did not
have to manually rename it
and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis
using data analysis here
you can basically get your descriptive
statistics for your columns and then you
can do whatever needed formatting you
need
to basically make your data look
in a
good way now let's look at one more
example of data analysis
where we may want to look at the
frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures you have been given some
pins where you would want to identify
how many values fall into the range of 0
to 20
20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50
and the easiest way to do that would be
creating histogram now histogram is
usually used for data analysis where you
would want to look at different
variables or say features for example
temperature is one such feature might be
there might be one more
variable or feature such as sale of ice
cream and you would want to see
if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in
sale of ice cream might be a sale of ice
cream is a is a response based on
temperature so it depends so sometimes
you may want to find the relationship
between two variables whether they are
positively or negatively related or you
would want to do different kind of
analysis and in certain cases we may
want to
first do analysis on one single variable
look at the frequency of values might be
also look at the defects and for which
we can use something like pareto chart
so we can go for histogram and that
basically gives us the frequency of
values now how do we do that so we have
already added the
[Music]
add-in which is data analysis earlier so
we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay
now
i have already selected input range so
if you see here my input range is
temperature which is also with the
headings
and i have bin range which is basically
the range of values so for example i can
select this and that's my pin range i am
selecting
or the option labels because i'm using
the first
row which has the heading such as
temperature and pins now we need to give
it output range so for example let's say
i would want my data here
and that becomes my output range so you
can have a sorted histogram or basically
a pareto chart
so if that's what you are interested in
looking at the frequencies for your
different ranges and here i'm also
selecting chart output because i would
want to have a visual histogram which
gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on ok
and now you get your bins
so it basically tells you frequency of
values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the values 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20
so we have 0 to 20 that is 2 so we can
basically say there is 120 here with the
20 being the maximum value and then
there is one more 20 so that's your 0 to
20
then you have 20 to 30 which shows three
values so might be in that case i can
say 26
is one thing then i can say 30
that's the second one
and then basically i can look at 22
so
basically this one does not select 20 as
the lower range but it basically selects
30 as the higher range so i do see 20 to
30 there are three entries similarly we
can see values for 40 and 50 and since
we have selected pareto or sorted
histogram that shows in a descending
order what is the highest frequency of
values within a particular range
so that shows me highest frequency is
five and then you have three and three
and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable
now
as discussed earlier as i said sometimes
we may
be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to
find out the correlation between one
variable to another variable or we would
want to find out the relationship
between variables
are they linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on and for that we can use the
correlation
of your data analysis add-in so for
example you want to find out correlation
of temperature and units sold and what
we can do is
we can find out that using a formula so
for example if i search for something
like
co
relation
and let's search so there is a function
called correlation which we can use and
we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select
the range of values for temperature and
then i am interested in finding out the
correlation of temperature in units sold
so let's select this
and that basically gives me a range of
values it gives me the correlation value
which is 0.2859
okay and that's your value
so similarly we can do it for
temperature and price ice cream so let's
go for
correlation so that's the function we
are interested in you need to give a
range of value so here we are interested
in temperature and price of ice cream so
let's select temperature
and then the second array or list of
values is price of ice cream let's
select that
let's close our bracket and here we have
the correlation value of temperature and
the price of ice cream similarly you may
be interested in finding out temperature
and units sold like what we have done
earlier so we can do the same thing
based on function so this is same as
correlation of temperature in units sold
so i can get rid of this one now how do
i do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what we need is we need to
go into data we need to click on data
analysis and here you have the option
called correlation let's select this
now that basically needs an input range
so we need the range now i might be
interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
i've selected all the columns here
we will say group by columns obviously
we need to select labels in first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading
now output range you can just give one
simple cell and that's where your data
will start from or you can give a new
workbook so click on ok
and that basically gives you
that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values
based on the values what we have here so
we have basically
temperature
and price of ice cream
and that basically shows me 0.96149
you have temperature in units sold so
you have 0.2859
now you can also look at units sold
and say for example price of ice cream
you can look at these particular values
so if i would be interested in finding
out
what is the relationship between these
variables i can easily find using
correlation so i could be
basically writing in a formula here and
selecting what are the cells so here we
were selecting a2
and c
here we were selecting a and b now might
be i'm interested in price of ice cream
and units sold and if that's what i'm
interested in then i will give a range
of b2 to b8 c2 to c8 and similarly you
can get your analysis or correlation
values
so it's very simple in excel and you can
use either the data analysis tab
and
get your correlation or you can use
formulas and do that
now one more important part of data
analysis is doing your sampling now
sampling could be periodic sampling or
random sampling so sometimes you may
want to look at a variable and you may
want to
get some values based on periodic data
that means
might be i'm interested in range of
values i'm interested in seeing a sample
of values for
a particular period which could be
basically
a range of values or you could just do a
random sampling so for example if i go
for periodic sampling so out of these
values which i see here might be i want
to see
say periodic sampling that is a
frequency of two values how many times
we have these values occurring here or i
would go for random sampling so
basically randomly i would want to pick
up
say three temperature values now how do
i do it so for example here i have seven
values now if i go
for periodic sampling
the sample
or periodic sample value which i need to
give has to be lesser than the total
input values
so for example we can do this let's go
in here
and let's go for data analysis so we can
go for sampling here click on ok
and that needs a range of values so we
will select a2 to a8 now i could have
selected all the values for this one
temperature and in that case i can give
labels which is going to take care of
the first
row
now here we can go for
number of samples which you are
interested in or giving a period so
let's go for period and say for example
i have seven values so what if i select
five
so for example if i say five
that means
i could just get one value so basically
when i'm saying five out of seven so
that's just giving me out of five i want
one value
so i can then just give an output range
so here i can basically select this cell
i'll say okay and now you see
it just shows me
one value
so out of the first range that is i have
said five it has given me the fifth
value that's your periodic sampling so
for example we want more values so let's
reduce this period
to might be 2 which basically gives me
every second value so i can basically
say for example 2 and say ok
and then
say ok so that shows me
26
then you have 35
then you have 40 and then well this one
does not have any more values so that's
your periodic sampling now if you go for
random sampling that's basically
randomly picking up values and you can
choose how many values you want so go
for data analysis
go for sampling i'll go for number of
samples how many you want so for example
out of seven values randomly i want
three values
and i can just give this say okay
and then
we will do a cancel because we need to
change that range so let's select this
and say okay and that gives me random
three values from this
values of temperature so we can use
excel to do a simple sampling and we can
choose whether we would want to go for
periodic sampling or
random sampling now we have seen
sampling histogram correlation
descriptive stats and now also let's
look at regression now what is
regression so when you talk about
statistical modeling regression analysis
is used to estimate the relationship
between
two or more variables and basically we
would want to look at
two or more variables
and
basically a relationship of those
variables with the response or the
target right so for example if we look
at our data here we have temperature we
have price of ice cream and then we have
units sold and we can
go ahead and make
predictions so for example when you look
at regression here you see something
like this which is regression statistics
you have anova
you have different plots which we have
here which is x variable
x variable 2 and then you have normal
probability plot
now we have already seen how you can
have your add-in that is data analysis
which helps you in doing different kind
of data analysis here right now how do
we do this so we have our variables here
which is temperature price of ice cream
units sold and when we talk about
regression we need to understand which
one of these are
independent variables which one of these
are dependent variables right so when
you talk about your x
that's your independent variable or we
can say predictor or explanatory so when
you talk about your independent
variables or as we say predictors
or explanatory variables
these are the factors that
might influence the dependent variable
and when you talk about dependent
variable that's your response or target
that's the main factor you are trying to
understand or predict
so we can plot a scatter plot to see
relationship between variables
if they are linearly related are they
positively related negatively related
and so on we can also
get values such as r square which is
coefficient of determination
regression line and then
analyze the relationship between
variables so
here is one of the links of one of my
edits other videos where we are
learning on machine learning and also on
regression but that's programmatically
and using a processing framework such as
spark
now here let's see how do we do this in
excel so basically we would want to use
our variables which is temperature price
of ice cream units sold
and then get these plots so what we can
do is for example i can get rid of this
and might be i can just say
no borders
and
when it comes to these plots
we can have them generated again that's
not a big deal
using your data analysis
add-in tool
so we have been given variables here now
as i said when we talk about your
regression analysis we need to
understand whether we have one variable
or we have
multiple variables right so you might
have heard of univariate analysis
bivariate analysis and so on well
here we are focusing more on using excel
to do our regression analysis so i'll
not go deeper into regression topics but
certain things as basics should be known
that when we talk about regression
analysis
what does it do it helps you understand
how the dependent variable changes
when one
or more independent variables vary
and it basically allows us to
mathematically determine
which of those variables really has an
impact
so technically when we talk about
regression analysis model that is based
on the sum of squares which is basically
a mathematical way to find the
dispersion of data points so
mainly the goal
of the model is to get the smallest
possible sum of squares and draw a line
that comes closest to the data so that's
what we mean by our regression line or
basically looking at the points and
seeing if the points fall on a
regression line
if there are residuals that is points
which do not fall on the regression line
and in terms of statistics
when we talk about
statistics we differentiate between a
simple and multiple linear regression so
you have something called a simple
linear regression
models
which basically gives you the
relationship between dependent variable
and one independent variable using a
linear function and if you use two or
more variables that is explanatory
variables to predict the dependent
variable we are actually dealing with
multiple linear regression so if the
dependent variable is modeled as a
non-linear function
because the data relationships do not
follow a straight line
we have to use non-linear regression
now what we will do is we will see how
we can work on this so here we have some
variables and if we look at this
might be based on temperature price of
ice cream we would want to find out how
many units were sold now what we can do
is we can basically
start looking in by creating a simple
scatter plot which is quite easy in
excel so if you have been given
variables what you can do is you can
click on insert
you can then choose the kind of plots
which you want and here you have
insert scatter plot so we can choose
this and you can choose the first option
so that gives you a blank layout
and what you can do is now you need to
select data so for example let's click
on select data and then you can say add
so what we would want is we can give a
name so we want x values and we want our
y values right so when you talk about y
that's your dependent variable or your
response or target so that is in our
case units sold and x values are one
set of features or variables or multiple
variables so here i can click on this
series x values and then i can
select this
now in y values what i can do is i can
select these
and then i can just say okay
so that shows me that it would be giving
me a
regression scatter plot
now let's say okay
and we have some points plotted here now
if you would want to see the impact of
one individual variable such as
temperature or price of ice cream you
could as well do that now what you can
also do is you can add more meaning to
this
by giving in a title or you can also go
into quick layout and you have various
options here so you see it gives you
what is the access title what is the
series and i would prefer to use here
something like this one so that gives
you your regression line that also gives
you your r square and that gives you
your y and x that is your coefficients
so let's select this one and then we
have some values which we can use to
compare this also shows me the
regression line and you can keep this
for reference if you would want you can
change
the chart title to something else a
scatter plot
of
dependent
uh was independent
variables and you can give any name
which has more meaning
and we can get rid of this one so we
have series and we can say what are
these points if you would want to add in
legend if you would want to do that or i
can just get rid of this
and
i will keep these values here which we
will
see when we do a data analysis we can
always
compare these values so here i have
created a simple scatter plot
and then i can look at dependent ways
independent variables
or i could have selected one particular
variable so this is just for reference
now we can add more details we can say
what is my x-axis what is my y-axis so
basically you can here
say for example just say y
and might be here i will say
x
and we can rename that later
now
how do we perform data analysis or get
into regression
right now what we would want to do is
we would want to get
or we would want to do the regression
analysis to demonstrate the relationship
between
dependent and independent variables
so normally when you talk about your
linear regression equation you might
have known about it so it is basically
why
when you say y equals
you can say
bx plus a
plus c
and this would be normally the
mathematical equation for a linear
regression when
x
is your independent variable
y
is your dependent variable
your
a is the y-intercept
which is expected
mean value of y
when all x variables are equal to zero
so basically on a regression graph
that's the point where line crosses the
y axis and that's your intercept
when you talk about b that's basically
your slope of regression line which is
the rate of change for y as x changes
and then you also have
your constant right so that's your
sorry that's basically your random error
term right which is basically
the difference
between the actual value of dependent
variable and its predicted value so your
linear equation
always has an error term because in real
life predictors are obviously never
perfectly precise
right now what we can do is we can also
reduce this
equation to
y is b x
plus a
and that's the equation of a line we can
look into this and the linear equation
can be understood mathematically in this
way now how do we do it in excel so
what we can simply do is
[Music]
here let me
yeah
so
we need to get into data and then here
we have our data analysis add in you can
click on this one and from these
different options you can choose
regression so that's what we would want
to do now we'll say okay now here you
need to give your input y range so as i
said you will have to select
the dependent and independent variables
right so we would want to do some
regression analysis here and here we
have your x and y
so y
being your target
that's basically your units sold so we
can select this along with the labels
when it comes to x either you can select
one variable or multiple variables so i
will select temperature price of ice
cream
and then since we have chosen the
headings we will go for labels
right
now we can always look at the confidence
level we can change that so you can say
whether you want it in a new worksheet
or you can just say output range and i
will probably
just click here and select one of the
cell here
now we can also choose the other options
which we would want to see as a part of
this regression analysis
so basically we have selected input y
range which is your dependent variable
you have selected x range which is your
independent variable and if we are
building a multi regression model then
we
have chosen temperature and price of ice
cream both
now we can choose the labels which we
have done we can choose your output
range which is basically on this sheet
and then we can select the residuals
so that basically gives you
your residuals now we can also get your
line fit plots which you were seeing
earlier
you can also go for your normal
probability plots and then basically
just say okay
and
let's say okay
and that basically gives you
your regression analysis output
so we
basically have your summary output
we also have anova
we have our serial output that's from
the previous one
and basically we can get rid of this
that's not required
i can get rid of this one
yeah so now we have our regression
statistics we also have our plots so we
can basically look into these
so we have our normal
let's get rid of these
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
this and then what we can do is
since we had some existing data it has
overwritten so let me get rid of this
and i'll repeat this step again
and
let's say water yeah
so now what we want to do is we want to
do a reaction analysis
so we go get into data we get into data
analysis we choose regression
we have already chosen our y range which
is column c
x range is multiple variables we have
gone for labels
output range which we would want to
select a particular cell
so let me select this
i am going for residuals line fit plots
normal probability plots and say okay
so now
we have our plots
we can just separate them to have a
better understanding
yeah and that basically shows you the
variables so here it shows me units sold
and then what are the predicted units
sold and here the variable is
temperature
here the variable is price of ice cream
right so that's your one variable and
second variable and then you also have
your normal probability plot now to
interpret this
or to understand what we have here where
we look at your
summary output so it is good to
understand what excel is helping us out
so basically when we do a regression in
excel it is performing all the
calculations automatically the
interpretation is something which we
need to understand so basically we are
looking at
multiple r value here
and we can
let's also fine tune this one
here
we have our values here and if you see
we have our r square now
we can then basically look at
our multiple r so what is your multiple
r that's your correlation coefficient
which basically measures the strength of
linear relationship
between two variables so
this can be any value between your when
you talk about your correlation
coefficient
it can be any value between -1 and 1 and
its absolute value indicates the
relationship strength
so
the larger the absolute value the
stronger the relationship so 1 basically
means a strong positive relationship
minus 1 means a strong negative
relationship and 0 means no relationship
at all
now when you are looking at r square
that is the coefficient of determination
which is used as an indicator of the
goodness of the fit
so it basically shows how many points
fall on the regression line so your r
square value is basically calculated
from the total sum of squares
when we say precisely it is the sum of
squared deviations of the original data
from the mean
now when we talk about
looking at the value of your r square
so it is basically we can be
seeing
that this is
8 0.45078 that's the value which i'm
talking about so it basically means
45 of our values fit the regression
analysis model
so in other words
45
of dependent variables that is your y
values are explained by the independent
variables that is your x values
so normally if you have r squared value
higher then that is considered as a good
fit
and here we have considered multiple
variables
now when you talk about your adjusted r
square it is the r square adjusted for
the number of independent variables in
the model
so
you would want to use this value instead
of r square for multiple regression
analysis
such as in our case
now you also have standard error so
that's basically
goodness of fit measure that basically
shows the precision of your regression
analysis so the smaller the value the
more certain you can be about your
regression equation
so
when when we talk about your r square
that represents the percentage of
dependent variables variance
that is explained by the model and
standard error is basically an absolute
measure that shows the average
distance that the data points fall from
the regression line so you will have to
look back into regression
statistics
terminologies to basically understand
more of this and if you're already from
data science background that
then you already know what i am talking
about we are just seeing how excel
easily helps us in doing these things
now
we can also look at observations here
which is basically the number of
observations in our model which is 7.
now when we talk about regression
analysis and if we look at analysis of
variance that is your anova values here
so we basically see df you have ss
f and significance f
now to understand these
so basically what we are doing is or
what excel is doing is it splits the sum
of squares into individual components
that give information about the levels
of variability within your regression
model so when you talk about your df
that's basically the number of degrees
of freedom associated with the source of
variance you have sum of squares that is
your ss
so smaller the residual ss compared with
the total ss
the better your model fits the data
right now when you talk about ms that's
your mean square you have f is basically
the f statistic
or you can say
f test for the null hypothesis
basically it is used to
test the overall significance of the
model and then you finally have your
significance f
which is the p value of f so
uh when we when we usually talk about
seeing simple linear regression the in
anova part is
not
really used or it's rarely used
right but when we look at the
significance f value that gives an idea
of how reliably
or statistically significant our results
are so if significance f is less than
0.05
that's 5 percent our model is ok if it
is greater than 0.05
we will have to better choose another
independent variables
right now we can also look at the output
of coefficients and that's what we would
want to look at
so you basically have your intercept
here so when you talk about your
intercept
temperature price of ice cream so we
know we are looking at our variables and
then we are also looking looking at our
intercept which basically gives you more
details on your coefficients
so the the main important thing when we
talk about regression analysis
is basically your coefficients it
basically enables you to build a linear
regression equation
in the form of y equals bx plus a which
i explained earlier
and then basically we can understand our
regression analysis
output better now when we look at the
residual output which we are seeing here
so that gives you your observations how
many observations we have it shows what
is the predicted units sold and then it
also gives you your residuals so we can
compare the estimated and actual number
of sold umbrellas based on the
observation
so we have
11.209 here and if you compare that's
basically 12
the second one is 15 and here it is 13.5
you have and similarly you can compare
all the values of actual units sold and
what our regression has predicted
so basically what we can do is we can
compare these
and
we will see if there is any difference
or no
right
so
obviously there will be or there would
be some difference because independent
variables are never
perfect predictors of your dependent
variables
and the residuals
basically help us in understanding how
far the actual values are from the
predicted values
so that's what we see here in the
residual section
so for example when we look at this one
which is 11.209
and the actual is 12 we see what is the
residual and how far is the predicted
value from the actual value
so
similarly we can also look at the
percentile values so that gives you your
probability output and this is what we
have in our graphs
so we have basically our variables
we are looking at our variables and also
the units sold and the relationship
between them we can basically
add in more details to this particular
plot and you also have normal
probability plot which is basically
getting
your values from your
probability output here so this is how
you can perform a simple regression
analysis and now what you can do is you
can
as i said you can basically be looking
at your scatter plot you can be looking
at your y and x and your r square values
right but remember what are the
variables which you are selecting
and then you can compare these
with basically the values what you see
here
so remember here i have chosen
my both set of variables
and you can choose
one variable and then basically see what
is its impact on the response or on the
target
so
it's pretty simple here you can
add more details to your scatter plot or
the plots what we have created
or
some people prefer to do it using
formulas
so
basically we have some statistical
functions that can help you do linear
regression analysis such as
you have
linus you have slope you have intercept
you have correlation and so on so
basically
you can use these particular functions
and what you will have to do is
you will have to
basically go in for a function if that's
what you would want to do
and then you can search for functions
and say for example i'll just say lin
nest
and say go and here i have my function
so if i would want to really use this
one i can do that what i will have to do
is then select the variable so if you
just say okay and that basically says
your known y's known x your constants
your stats and basically you can use the
formula also but we are not covering
that here might be in the later videos
we can do that so just try out and
perform some regression analysis
and try to look at your different
variables and try to interpret that so
that basically gives you
an easier way of performing regression
analysis
using your data analysis add-in in excel
well hello everyone this is iphone 7
from team simply learn in this tutorial
we will be talking about macros used in
excel and also the visual basic
application programming for macros
so what is excel macro you do certain
daily tasks and daily reports or monthly
reports that you generate and you use
data from your excel and you scrub data
and you basically have the same things
performed or done on the excel sheets
every time and every
day or monthly or bi-weekly or any
number of times that you open your excel
you
remove certain columns you add certain
things and you
change certain values and
these are the things that you do
an n number of times on an excel
and this can all be done
by simple automated
wave which is macros so what it
does is it is a set of tasks that you
can execute as many number of times as
you want
when you create a macro basically what
it does is it will record all your mouse
clicks and keystrokes
basically if for example you have your
monthly accounts report that is there
and it comes every day and you have to
put it and
extract certain data and remove certain
columns
that you do every time that you open
that sheet for instance you remove that
column i
which has the absolute values offer of
your accounts or the sheets
that you have and you remove that column
and you edit some names you add such
things every time that you open that
report and then you format it in a
proper way and send it to your
management so this can all be done
in a simple
running script called macros so what you
do is you record those
mouse clicks and keystrokes and record a
macro for it save it and next time
tomorrow when you come you just run that
macros
and this will do everything for you and
you do not have to do that same tedious
task every day so this is basically
a set of code or a task that you can
execute and automate and it can be done
a number of times
so
it makes your life easy
now
so next thing is how you actually
activate the macros in your excel
it's a simple uh tab that you need to
add
in the ribbon section which i'll be
showing you across
and this will enable the macros on your
excel so you go to files
go to options
and then you need to customize ribbon
click customize ribbon
and then there is a developer tab which
you see here it should be activated so
you just need to select that
click on the
tick mark and just click ok
so this will add a developer tab here
and
this will enable the macro so now you
you have your data and you can run
macros or record a macro and run it over
on your excel
there is also an option to do it a
different way right click on any of the
tabs on the ribbon
customize ribbon and you can
add or remove
your macros from here so this is two
ways that you need to that you can
activate your macros so how you record a
macro is the next thing
so here i have a work orders sheet that
i receive every day or one of you will
receive every day and how you record a
macro you have certain set of tasks that
you do
and
you know this report has so many things
that are obsolete which you do not need
which has to be put across to your
management or your
for your use so how you record or
start a macro you go to the developer
tab and start recording a macro as soon
as you click on this record macro button
it will start
recording your keystrokes on the mouse
mouse clicks
and you can save that and run it as a
script in the next sheet that you do
so
this is the sheet that i have
and
we'll try to run a macros on this and
see what it does
so here i have and
this actually works this way
i need to go to the developer tab and
start recording a macro
so when i click a record macro it
starts uh recording my mouse clicks and
keystrokes so in this sheet i have to
you know remove some columns and
the columns that are obsolete and the
data that looks
weird here should be removed and all
what i need is the work order number the
district and the tactician name and the
kind of service that we provide and
the
requested work date
the cost
and the payment so this is what i want
and i do it every day when i receive the
sheet and i have to
make these changes and
send it across to the accounts team so
what i do is i simply
automate this by running a macro
so
i go to
let's see how it records the macro
i click record macro i save it as work
order
accounts
and i'll add a little description like
work orders
for
account scheme
cost
click ok
and
see what i do is basically i
add the
borders first
so that the data looks proper
and then i do not want this column i
delete it i do not want the number of
technicians that are there
i do not want all these and i also want
the labor hours the account and what
kind of payment this is very crucial for
the fms team i do not want any of these
obsolete data
so i just delete this
okay
and then
i just want to have some cosmetic
changes done so
i make sure this
doesn't have any border
and
that's it this is the task that i
perform
every day i still don't need this
and i go to the developer tab and click
stop recording so now i have the macro
save and when i have it i have
you know automated these all these steps
in one simple click
and how i execute it in another sheet so
i will show it across to you
the next thing so here i have the next
report that has to be uh changed or
formatted and send it across so i simply
go the next morning and go to the
developer tab
and
go to the macro and i have this macro
save which we ran the just now and i
simple with a single click i will be
able to do these daily tasks
and execute in a flash so i just click
run and it does the rest for me i have
my report ready and is in a proper
format that is required and it can be
sent across so here as we see it is done
in a single click by running
a simple macro continuing our
work on macro we can simply do this by a
single click of a button by adding a
button so
what you have to do is go to the
developer tab and in the control section
you will see the insert option
when you click on the insert drop down
you will see a form controls and you can
say select a button
and here i select a button
and the mouse changes to across
and you can add
your macro and assign it
so as we have saved it work order
accounts as a macro and when i just
assign that macro to this button
i can edit the text by
making it as
work order
accounts just to make it simple
okay
and
now if you see if i just click this
button it will run the macro
and format our sheet
so this is how we run the macros in a
single click of a button by adding the
button
there is another alternative way to go
to the macros in instead of the
developer tab and you go to the view
button
and then go to macros at the end
you can view macros you can record and
you can edit your mac
so when i click view macros it will show
you what are the macros that i have and
that i can run
and you can simply run it
alternatively
and you can record a macro as well
instead of from the developer tab
if you just click on record macro it
will do the same functions that we do
from the developer tab
the next thing is to edit the macro how
do you edit your macro you have
to use a simple application in excel
which is the bba visual basic
application to edit your macro you go to
the developer tab
and then click on visual basic this
literally opens another window
like this and you will see the module
that you have been working on
and you can edit the
macro here
so as we see
if you go back to the excel
we see that
our sheet we have been working on
the sheet and it has the column still k
and the actual sheet is this
so if i go to the visual basic editor
and
i'll make sure they know i remove the
columns that are existing from the
column m
and i just delete that
and i click
run
i go back to my sheet
and you see
these changes are not there
okay
this is your old
macro and this is our new macro
as we see this sheet has the rush column
which is the priority
of my orders
so these are the things that we can edit
with the vba
in this tutorial we will be talking
about the visual basic application
programming for macros so here we are
what is vba visual basic application it
is basically a visual basic application
language that is used for macros in
excel
so what it basically does visual basic
for application is a programming
language of excel that helps you
automate task by writing macros we have
seen how we use macros how it simplifies
our tedious daily tasks
by running a simple macro
now to help us
you know
write these macros and help us get the
best use of our
abilities to
ease our work and automate our task we
use vba
so
why vba there are many advantages of
using vba and why we prefer vba in
macros for excel
so
basically it is a very simple language
it saves time in
performing tedious tasks you have number
of tasks that you do every day as we
have seen in the previous
section
how we uh you can simplify your daily
task by just running a simple macro and
this vba helps us in performing those
steps
in a very simple manner
another thing is it supports
english like statements there are
multiple statements that you can use and
which are very basic english language
statements and this can help us or it is
very easy to program or
code or edit these commands you can
select a range you can it is like
if an else statement
and things like that we will look into
those in details in the next sections
now one more thing is it improves the
functionality of excel by allowing you
to make excel behave the way you want
there are multiple functions that you
perform in excel like selecting a number
of rows or columns or selecting a set of
cells
in particular you do it on a daily basis
so these things can easily be performed
and easily be edited and executed by
using vba
we will look into those in detail now
what is the vba editor interface this is
particularly
an interface which you will have uh look
in detail bar section of the vba editor
interface the next thing is the menu bar
menu bar as we all know it is simply it
shows you the menu wherein you have all
the options like file edit view insert
insert is the one very important uh menu
bar option
and when you can insert different
modules and buttons and all we'll look
into those in details run is one more
important thing all these things fall
under menu bar
the next thing is the vba code window
maybe a code window as it says is the
code window where your actual code
resides
wherein you can go into it and edit the
code or write the codes and select the
different range of functions that you
can perform and this is basically the
bdb vba code window
where you
edit your or write your codes
the next thing is the project explorer
project explorer is simply like a
windows explorer but this is in
particular is specific to your
vba
wherein it shows the different options
that are there the
the excel sheets or the worksheets that
you're working on or the modules that
you have saved
and so on basically it is an explorer
for your vba like a windows explorer
which is for the file explorer
the next thing is the properties window
properties windows shows you the
properties of the worksheet that you're
working on
for instance here we are working on the
sheet 2
and it shows the properties what are the
kind of
[Music]
worksheet that we have the page breaks
the right to left whether it is enabled
or not the name of the sheet and so on
whether it's visible and things like
that
the next thing is the immediate window
and the watch window
now what is the immediate window
immediate window is basically a tool
or a window wherein you can run and
execute simple
lines of codes individual excel code
that you can run it will allow you to
test individual lines
which is very useful and handy when you
are writing and debugging codes
the output if the
lines that you execute can be seen here
in the immediate window whereas watch
window watch window is similar to it but
it displays the value of the watch
expression in its current current state
so this can be extremely useful again
while we are debugging the vba code
adding a watch is a great utility and we
will see uh the use the
advantages of having a watch window in
your
vba interface
so these are the things that we'll learn
and look into it in detail in the coming
section now we continue our topic for
visual basic for application
for macros and
i'm going to show you how to
you know run some codes and run some
macros and codes and
perform some simple to complex tasks
using the vba for macros
so
there are two ways to open the visual
basic application
and the first thing is you can run alt
f11 click on the sheet and then just
press and it will open the
visual basic for application window or
alternatively you can just go and click
on the visual basic and it will open the
sheet folder i mean the code window for
you and as we have discussed before
these are the windows that we see this
is the code window and this is the
project explorer
and
this is the immediate window
i will you can run some
testing codes immediately it will show
you the output so here we see the
project explorer window where we see the
modules
for our visual basic for applications
so as we see the code is empty here
we'll try to record a macro and see
how the code develops okay so i just go
here and click
record macro
and i save it as
a format
and
columns
okay
this quickbook and i just saved it click
okay
and it has started recording so now what
i'll do is
make it simple and i just delete some
columns here
okay
i do not need this
i delete this derivate i want this i
want the amount of payment
parts cost labor hours i do not want
this number of technicians forget it
okay
and i go for the left and see what all
do i need i need i don't need this
i delete all these and
i just expand this so that it's clearly
visible
and then i want to change the format i
mean the hot
so
i select this
[Music]
and i change it to time stream
okay
go back to my
developer tab click stop recording it is
saved
okay
now go back to my
code
and see
the
macro here
so we see the macro here and
we can see
in detail what it looks like so
we see the code what it's doing and what
the macro
run has generated the code
so we see we have basically the name of
the macro is format columns
and what it is doing we're just
selecting the columns and
deleting some we are checking the range
on some columns ee select that is the e
column that we have selected and then
again so on
and
the next thing is the font selection
that is mentioned
we are changing it to times new roman
size is 11 so
it is basically
a basic vba code so it starts with the
sub and it should end with end sub so
this is the code or a format of the vba
code that it looks like and we'll try to
do some basic functions with the
vba and discuss this in further details
so for ease of explanation i have picked
up a blank
spreadsheet and
i'll try to explain some basic uh
functions and
the commands and the codes that we use
to
accomplish the
task that we with vba
so as we see this is a blank sheet and i
have selected a new module for it
so here i uh start the code and it says
it starts with sub and
i am specifying the
module name as
number so i'll just try to make it quite
simple and
you know so we as soon as we enter the
sub it sends with the end sub and so
this is the
start of the code and this is the end of
the code and whatever is there should be
here and this is the name of the
code or the macro now uh i'll explain it
further about the dim statement why is
it used and what does it use for
so dim is basically a keyword which is
the
short form of dimension and it is used
to declare variables in the
vba so here i am trying to specify a
variable called x and how i'm going to
do it i
will
have it as a number or an integer or
anything so here in this example i'll
put it as an integer or a number okay
and as i put as it populates the prompt
so i select integer
and for example i select the number to
be
500
okay and here i'm trying to assign a
variable integer
a cell a value of
500 with a
keyword
so where exactly i want to put this you
will see it when you execute the code
okay
range
i am selecting
it should be under course where i'm
going to put the
value of x as and i close the backer and
what should be the value
we will
value should be x
so now as i click
run sub
or you can do it with the
by running the alt
f5 key and it will run the
code so you see here in the excel sheet
it executes the value
of the cell b5 to be 500 so this is one
simple function that you can do
with the
dimension keyboard or dim keyword
and you can assign the value as integers
now proceed we proceed further with
certain
more examples some more examples
and how we assign the string value as a
as a text or
something else okay
now i'm going to show you what dim can
be executed
used as
set variables team can be used as a
double
when double is basically a longer form
of single variable it usually takes more
space but uses
needs more larger numbers okay and then
you can set
double and i just don't specify it and
we can use date
it basically stores the date values okay
and then again string so what string
does if you use string it stores the
text it can contain numbers it will have
some text as calculations or anything
can be performed so these are the basic
thing that i will cover
and
you can also use different
values for it so i will discuss this in
the next example
okay
so in the next example i'll try to set
or
use a string value for it and
i put it as a string
substring
value
this is my name
so as soon as i hit enter it ends with
the answer prompt and now i can give my
code
so
i put it as dim book as
string
okay
now
i'm trying to use
to name a country or put a value
of a country to one of the
cells so
let's see
how it goes and
i select country
and in country i select
[Music]
okay
now what is the value or the cell that
basically takes the or we will put the
name of the country at so i have to
specify a range and as soon as i hit
it goes and i have to specify the
the cell
here so here i put it as g
and uh
okay
so i close it
and i put value to it what value i am
going to assign it is a country
okay
now
i'll try to run this code very simply
and see
g4
the name
populates as a country here so
this is a dim keyword you being used as
a string in our vba code
so
we can also use
vba to you know pop up a message or an
alert or a kind of a button or a message
pop-up pops up when you execute this
code so this basically can be
executed using
the
code here which i'm going to put
and we use the
okay let's give it a value
i'm going to name it as double value and
again the name keyword i'm going to use
the
keyword as double
okay y double is used is basically uh it
gives a longer it can be used for a
longer form of single variable takes it
usually takes more space and larger
numbers and we'll try to assign it okay
now i'm going to pop up a message in
there which says the value of a is so
and so so i'm going to give value of a
as
2 5 0
okay
and how i it pops up a message okay so
there is a message box
which you know can be used and it will
give you a value i mean it will prompt
you to enter the value what kind of
button you want and
you you can enter the text and you can
enter that so here i'm going to
write a code which
you know which gives a pop-up message a
message box saying that the value of a
is signed so
i'm going to put it in percent
code
so it actually takes the value of a
okay
now that's it
and let's try to run this and you will
see a message for popping message box
popping up
okay so the value of
the message box
pops up saying the value of a is 250
so
in the next example i am going to
write a code wherein you know you can
give a value or a string you can assign
it to a selected cell and this basically
used when you
have some
you know when you have a
task of you know giving a value to a
particular cell or you have to assign a
text
or say something about a report okay
so
this let's see how it goes and we use
the
i will say
it as
fun with some procedures
[Music]
this is the name and
again name
so here i am going to i am going to give
a user input and it will be as a string
okay you can give anywhere i mean any
string or any statement what my user
input will be i will define it here
[Music]
because
this
is the
report
for
vbq
let's make it simple
okay
and where i'm going to put it is in the
active cell or the cell
that i
have it
select okay what will be the value
the value will be the user input
i have defined user input as this is a
report for vba so this cell turns into
you this is a report for vba
i run this
and you see this
so in some cases you need to run this
and
you know it makes life quite simple when
you use vba for this as we have seen
before we have used message box now i'm
going to use the same message box
to
display my name or you can use it to
display your name so let's see how it
goes
i'm going to name it as
name
okay and it's very simple you have to
define a message box
which displays your
name
and i'm going to put it under course
that my name is
and we'll try to
run it
see here
so it pops up a message saying that my
name isn't fun so
this is a message box that you can
display and i can do anything with this
[Music]
this
is pba
[Music]
a6
okay i run it again and it pops this
message
so these are the things that you can use
to customize or you know when you
open an excel sheet or try to run a
workshop or a report and it pops up a
message customary welcome messages that
you can customize or
you know define a
report or kind of
data in it and this can be used using
run using the message box
and now i have another good example
wherein you know you can write a code to
tell excel what is the value of
a cell or what is the number that is
there in the cell so
here it is
i put this sub
okay
number
and
it will again
populate a message box
which will set it to
the
the entered
[Music]
value
is
and it should tell me
which or i specify
which cell it is
that we are going to find the value of
okay
so i give a range
of
i have to give it in codes i'm going to
go to complete it
and it should tell me the value
of the number that is present in the
cell
a1
okay
it ends let's try to run it
run it and it will give me the value so
this is how we can use excel to
determine or show or populate a message
box which will give us the value of the
number that is there in the cell so here
i can change it to
a
4
as well
and try to run it
and it will give me the number so
this is simple way of you know
populating a message box which will tell
us the
value of it
uh let me show you one more simple
example where in a message box pops up
on a welcome message that can be pop set
when you open the uh excel or worksheet
so
so let's
name it as auto
open
and then
again message box i want it to populate
and
what does it say
i put it in quotes welcome
to
our
worksheet
our workshop
[Music]
it's very simple you just run it and
see
it pops up a message saying welcome to a
workshop so these are the
one more this is one more way where you
can you know run a code or to simple
welcome message on
excel
next i'm going to show you a code
wherein you can give a value or assign a
value to a particular cell by simple
curve
so
we name it as add value
now i specify the range i mean where
i am going to specify a cell
where
the value will be given to the
cell
i'm going to
give it as v5
okay to put it as codes
close the parenthesis
what is the value that i'm going to give
value equals
2 5 0
okay so now with this code i mean i'm
going to assign a value of 250 to the
cell b5 let's see
run it see
again i do it to p10
okay
so this is how you can assign a value to
a particular cell
now i can run uh the same thing and give
a range of cells i mean
let me make it very simple here
i give it as
b1
through
b
five
as
four five zero so
let's see what it does
see here i'm going i'm specifying the
range to be b1 through b5 so it is doing
it for the whole range
okay
in the
and then i can give a another set of
range here
like
let me specify it
range to be
[Music]
c
one
i have to give it a course
give me an error
symbol colon
c4
and i separate it with a comma and i can
specify another range so the next one
will be d1
to
d4
and then i close the codes close the
parenthesis
what is the value that i give is
let's say
two three zero
and i try to run it
so it gives the value
of c1 through c4 and d1 through d4 as
230 as we specified it in the
code
so this is one of one more example where
you can assign values to the
uh
so range of cells or cells and with the
vba
one more thing i can
you know assign a value to a particular
cell by specifying these cells it's very
simple just specify the cells like
six
comma
seven
okay
and
i close the parenthesis
i assign a value to it
value equals
10.
let's see
see
here it assigns the value to that
particular cell that we have specified
row 6
and columns
okay so this is one more example wherein
you can assign values to particular
cells
okay in the next example uh there will
be a scenario where you need to select a
range of cells in the sheet so this can
also be done this task can also be
performed using vba
so i will show you how
this is our
let's say select
range
okay and
and i am going to set a dim
variable as
example
okay let's say it has example and
what i'm doing is i'm specific range
because i need to select a range of
cells
okay
now i'm going to set the variable as
set example where i'm going to define
the range of the cells that should be
selected
so let's say a
1
to
t
5. okay this will be the
selection
and what i'm going to
set the value okay i am going to set a
value
example
i'm going to give it a value of
256. so
let's see how it pans out
okay so here i'm selecting a
set of
cells a range of cells and i'm going to
assign a value
with this function
so this makes it quite simple and this
will be used in a regular daily task
when you know there is there will be a
scenario where you
have to select a set of cells and give a
give a value to it so you can do it with
a click of a button with the vpn
now i can simply tweak this with the you
know by just selecting it so
there is
i'll remove this
and
instead of assigning a value i'll just
put an option to select it
now let's just run it and see what
happens next
okay so this is one way of you know just
selecting it okay and then you see it
becomes easier for you to copy paste and
do some functions so you can select this
and you can assign a value and you can
also give a set of values to a
particular range or cells with these
codes
now what if i want to do a selection of
the same
rows and columns in the next sheet
and i can do this with the
setup another set of commands so i will
show you how
so here let's say you know we set the
same thing
and we specify the worksheets okay
worksheets
i want it in sheet2 okay so i just put
it as g2 and i activate it basically
activating it and now i'm going to
specify the worksheet
2
and what is the range that i'm going to
select the same thing okay
the range will be
a1 to
d5
okay
what i'm going to do i'm going to select
it
okay
and see what happens here
okay okay
so here i am selecting the worksheet too
and i'm activating it and i'm going to
assign range and i'm going to select it
so i can just
copy the same or select the same set of
cells in the next sheet
okay now when there will be
a as i said there will be you know by
requirement where you need to copy some
cell contents and paste it to another
location so how you do that it's uh
again a simple
code that you can write
and let's say
let's say it has a
copy
and paste i'm just making it simple
by giving something that we can
understand and relate and
[Music]
copy
paste
okay
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this range
and i'm going to copy it and paste it
somewhere here okay
so let me just remove this
and
i'll show you
first we have to specify the range where
you want to copy
the cells okay so let's say it is again
a1
it should be in course
okay let's
d5
course
and i am going to select it okay
then
what i'm going to do is
once you select this the selection that
you have
should what should be the function and i
am going to specify the selection
and the function should be
copying it
okay so i just
said that
and where i'm going to paste it so i
have to now specify the range
where i have to paste this selection
and you can just mention the
column here let's say
g
10
okay
and close it
i'm going to select it
and then where i'm going to paste it i
can do it in this sheet okay
active
sheet and
paste it
so we are selecting a range of cells
selection
and that selection what we are doing is
we will copy it
and now we are going to specify the
range where you are going to
select it and then
paste it
quite simple
let's see
okay
see
and
you can just change it so it is visible
on this
okay
so
this makes
quite easy
and you can run it
the next scenario will be like
when you need to
get the count of the number of cells
like you have to have a selection and
you need to count the number of cells so
this can also be done and it's quite
easy
i am going to show it to you
let's say the sub the
account
cells
should always be relatable so that you
know you remember and you understand
what is
the output and why you are using it and
i'm going to set a
variable let's say
i'm going to set an example for this and
what we're going to do is we are going
to specify a range first okay we will
specify the range of
the cells that we are going to
that we need to count basically
so i'm going to set a variable as a
range and
then
what we are going to do is
example
and we will specify the range
you can specify the range or your
selection where you count the where you
need the count of the number of cells
so a1
[Music]
d5
now how you want the output you want it
you want a message box to pop up
so you will set a message box
and
what should it give you will give you
the count of the
variable that is the variable is here is
examples okay so
it will count the number of cells in
this
area
okay
let's see it says
okay here i think i'm listed so i just
specify the
number here
and let's see so it gives you the number
of
count in this 20 okay
now let's see i want to
six
so it gives you the selection so it's
quite simple it will be very useful in
our daily task and then you need to
count the number of cells so this is one
way to get it
well i can further tweak this and to
determine the
or count the number of rows or columns
so it's again very simple i just need to
do some changes here i have to set the
column count
so if i want to
calculate the number of columns
just
let's see how it should calculate or
give the message
the number of columns here see
it gives there are five columns okay one
two
one two three four five okay
so it gives us the number of columns
here
if i change it to
should give me
four followers
okay similarly you can count the number
of rows here
let's change it to rows
see it says six rows out there
okay
should give me number
see
so this way you can calculate the number
of count the number of
cells number of columns number of rows
with this
the next thing i'm going to talk about
is the if statement if statement is one
of the
most widely used statement and
whoever is in programming are very much
familiar with this function so what it
does is we specify a condition if
condition is met then the output output
should be such and such we can specify
the condition and it will check
whether that condition is there
and if it is
space i mean if it is
achieved then you will have to specify
the output as well so this can be
achieved with the if statement
okay and it is very easy because it is
it understands the basic uh english
language so it's not very complicated
and i'll show you how
so the syntax can be like this if
suppose you specify a condition
and if that condition is met
then the result you specify the
condition and the result
okay so this is one thing and then you
can specify the
else or else condition
where you know you specify the condition
too
then
the result should be
this
so here you are going to
specify two conditions or multiple
conditions where you specify
this and if it is there then result will
be this if it is this condition and then
the result will be
something else
let's take an example wherein you have
to you have some scores or marks
and you have to
select a result you can't do this
manually
entering so just you can write a code
suppose for example
i have it here
okay
let's
and
i specify as
a
statement
okay now i have to specify the
variables now i have two variables i
have a score and i have a
result and the score is an integer the
number and the result is a string pass
or fail so i specify this okay dim
score
i specify it as integer okay and then
there's another variable that i have to
set
the result
as
string
okay
now what the score will be the score i
have to specify the range
score i'm giving it as a range i mean
it's in my
cell a1
okay
i specify the range
what is it it is a value
okay
sorry
should be a lot
okay
and then i'm specifying a condition here
if
score value the variable
is greater than or equal so as i said
it's quite simple and it takes the basic
english
language functions
then
the
result result is another variable that i
have said result what it should be it
should be
in quotes
pass
okay
so
if this condition is met then the result
will be this okay and now where i want
to specify my result i should give a
range for that as well so i give it in
the next column or any one
this is the basic
example
value should be
the result
okay let's see how it drops
see
says pass
change to 40.
it doesn't give me anything because i
have specified only one condition here
okay
see
so they say it's very basic condition
that you are specifying you are
specifying two variables the score and
the result
and then you are giving a value for it
and you are specifying the condition if
the score is greater than then the
result should be passed
now in the next uh section uh
we will simply tweak this and use an if
then else statement we'll attach an else
statement with it and see we'll specify
another condition
and see so here again we'll use two
variables that is the score as integer
and the result as a string and let's uh
stick to the same values
and now
um i'm going to specify it and if the
score is greater than 60
then
the result
so the result will be pass as it is
before
and then
i'm going to specify another condition
else
the result should be
should be
okay
and now
i have to put it to the end if statement
i have to
specify the nsu and the result will be
again in the value i mean the range will
be v1 so let's see if it is more than 60
then it is passed otherwise it is fake
okay this pass let's see
40.
okay so we are specifying two variables
again we are giving at a range and we
are specifying one condition if this
condition is met the result is passed
otherwise else it is fail
so another set of example
uh the next statement that we use or we
are going to discuss is the
loop statement that is the for loop
statement and why we use it there are
there are situations in
uh tasks that you need to execute and
you need to do it several number of
times
these are basically executed
sequentially it means one after another
so the first statement or the function
is executed and the next
is taken up so
and then the next and so on so
these loop statements allow us to
execute a statement or a group of
statements multiple number of times many
number of times and this happens only
when the first task or the first
task is done
and it executes that and it goes to the
next one so here we'll discuss a simple
example
of the for loop statement
so let's see how it
works
and i'm going to set up a
statement okay again the i'm going to
make it as loop 1.
so here it is i have to specify the
variable that is dim
and i'm going to specify x as an integer
okay i'll try to execute it and then
explain it what happens and how it exits
okay for x equals to 1 to
24 okay let's see
and
i'm going to specify the range
range as
so what i'm going to do is basically i'm
going to fill the
column a
from 1 to 24
with some value 1 from 1 to 24 with the
values of 1
through 24 okay
so i'm setting up a
range
and
how it ends is it gives me a value
now it excuse this and goes to the next
so i'll explain you how so we are
setting up a loop we are setting up an
integer a variable x as integer and we
are setting the value of x to be 1 to 24
so here for one it executes the first
thing is it it takes x as 1
and it fills in
a1
and then
the next value of x will be 2
and it goes to a2 and fills the value as
2. so just let's try to execute this and
you will see
the
row column a filled with 1 through 24
see
it's quite simple it executes one
condition
and then goes to the next and we are
defining it with the number of values
and the variable as x
and the number of values is going to be
24
okay so this is one basic example of a
for loop statement
now let's do some more uh addition to
this
uh step example by
you know executing another set of for
loop
and giving the output and we put the
output to be the color code advance in
the column b so how we do it it's a
basic simple example that i'm going to
take and again
what i'm going to do is i will have this
values here and i'm going to color code
the
b column with certain color index for
each number there will be a different
color so let's see
and
what i'm going to do is i'm only going
to change the
b
and what action is going here we put up
a value now we are going to select it
and with this selection
what i'm going to do is it should select
it
and
it should color the interior with word
with the color index
okay
and the value of
x
and then i'm going to specify the
pattern what
pattern it will take for the
box to be colored and i'm going to put
it as a solid in this video we'll be
creating two dashboards using a sample
sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email ids
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email
now let's begin by understanding what is
a dashboard in excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards
an advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding
let's jump into our demo
for creating our dashboards we'll be
using a sample sales data set
let me show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random it was not validated though we
have applied certain transformations to
the data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if i go on top you can see
this data set has
17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have middle east and
north africa there's north america
asia
sub-saharan africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits etc
then we have the representative's name
or you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales channel column so
there are basically two channels
whether the item was sold offline or
online
next we have the order priority column
now here c stands for critical
then we have h which is for high
priority orders then we have m for
medium priority orders and finally we
have l which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column
then we have the order id the ship date
next we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which
each product was sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column
now the total cost column is actually
the product of units sold and the unit
cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have
order month now these two columns were
actually generated using the power query
features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for revenue by order
year revenue by year and region revenue
by order priority and much more
we'll create separate pivot tables and
pivot charts and format them to make
them look more interesting and
presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields now let's create our
first report to see the total revenue
generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this
i'll click on a cell in my data set
and then i'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivot table
i click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next i want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet and let's just click on ok
there you go
so we have a new sheet where i can place
my pivot table
so first
i need to find the total revenue
generated by each year so what i'll do
is
i'll drag my order year column
under rows
and then
i'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see i have my pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order year from 2010
to 2017.
now
based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so i'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts i
click on this
now actually i want a line chart so i'll
click on line here and select ok
there you go
so we have successfully created our
first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first
let me delete
these so i'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the
buttons present on the chart
now
let me go ahead and edit the chart title
so the title i want is total revenue
i'll type it down
by year
all right next
let's do a few more transformations
so if i click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines legend and others
okay
so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total legend is gone
now let me add access titles so we'll
label our x axis and y axis
so here under x axis
i can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis i'll put
revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart style option
and go to colors first
here
i'll select
yellow color
okay
and then
go back to style
let's select a new style from this
i want
this style
okay
now
you can also add
data
labels so i'll just click on data labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if i click on this arrow
here i have more options
if i scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
i'll expand this
and under category
i'll select custom
now here
we'll give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so i'll write if
my revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
99 000
let me make sure there are 6
9's here so one two three four five and
six okay we are good to go
i'll close the bracket
i'll give a hash
give to commas
so if the revenue is greater than
9 lakhs 99 000
i'll put it in the format of millions so
within double quotes i'll write m
i'll give a semicolon
followed by another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million
let me click on add
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data
and you see here we have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and
adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up
now if you notice this line chart fusion
for example if you see here in 2010
the
total revenue generated was nearly 175
million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011
till 2014
it reached 195 million
and after 2014
it again came down to
180 million
and the revenue dropped significant 17
in 2007
the rev universe just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just name this
so i'll write it as
revenue by
year
all right
now
let's ice the revenue generated each
year in different regions
so for this create another pivot table
let me close this
i'll click on any cell
go to
and select pivot table
i just click ok so that my pivot table
is placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to
columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows
and then
i'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready
so for 2010 you can see in asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly
if you see for 2013 this was the total
revenue generated in europe
and
we have for other years as well
now let's
create a line chart based on this pivot
table so i'll select any cell in the
pivot table
and i'll click on recommended charts
from this list i'll select my line chart
and click on ok
there you go
so we have our next
pivot chart ready
so
on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the legends we have
so in two we have
seven regions
and
each of the regions have been
represented in different terms you
notice this graph
for the
sub
saharan african region
in 2012
sub-saharan africa the highest amount of
sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue
significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for
europe
this was the trend
so if you see here in 2011 the sales
were at this level then it significantly
dropped in 2012
then
in 2013
is a bike and then again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts
now
let's
format this chart so for fall let's
delete the button on the chart and we'll
also
delete the
legend
all right
now let me reduce the size of the chart
next
we'll
add a chart title so we'll
give the title as
revenue
by
year and
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of millions
so i'll write format axis
i'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category i'll select custom
and
we'll use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this
this and let me
save it
the font size or increase the font size
let me just show you suppose you want to
increase size of the chart title so you
just select it
and either also move it to left or right
or you can place it in the center as
well
for the time being let me just keep it
to the left
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region
and will create a combo chart for this
so let me show you how to do it
i'll go to my
data sheet
i have my
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on okay
all right
so this
my engine on tools
and then
i'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the net coin will be the total cost
column
all right so here we have the vote table
ready now based on this pivot table
let's create our pivot chart
so i'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview preview of the combo
chart
all right now let me just click on ok
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is
the bars represent the total revenue
which is this column
now the line represents
the total cost
so
let me go ahead and hit this chart a bit
so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next
we'll add
database so i'll click on data labels
here
okay
so these are the
the bars or
the revenue column
now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so i'll click on this arrow go
to more options so i scroll down
i have number
here i'll select custom and
i'll choose
my type that is
in millions
all right so you can see we have added
our
data
nothing we'll add
a chart title
so here i'll write as
revenue
by
region
it's actually
revenue and total
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well i'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet3 also i am going to rename it as
revenue
by
year
and region
so this
makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority
and for this we are going to create a
pie chart
so let's go to the data sheet
and create our pivot table first
i click on ok
now
i'll select order priority under rows
and under values i'll select
total revenue
so this is a
very simple pivotal so you have your
order priority so c is for critical h is
for high l is for low and m is for
medium
now based on this
let's create a pie chart
so i'll go to recommended charts and
here you have
chart
i want to select
this 3d type of pie chart
and i'll click on ok
all right so we have our pie chart ready
let me just resize it
and from here i'll remove the feel
buttons
i also don't need the legend so i'll
delete this as well
all right
now let's give a chat title so this is
going to be
revenue
by order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
i'll check this option
okay
now let's again format the sends of
millions
so here
i'll click on the last option i'll go to
numbers
under category i'll select custom
and
my type is going to be in terms of
millions there you go
let me close this
i will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you would you can change the
color of the text as well
so let's
have it in whiter and see how it looks
okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so i'll write
revit by
i'll just put op which stands for order
priority
all right
now the horizontal bar chart i'll go to
insert
click on pivot table
and sell okay
so i want my revenue based on different
countries so i'll select country
and put it under rows
and then
i'll choose total revenue and place it
under values
so here you have the different country
names we have afghanistan this albin let
me scroll down you have bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have czech
republic there's estonia france gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have india there's jamaica italy
and all the way to the bottom if we go
we have new zealand there's netherlands
philippines portugal
we also have
singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the uae united states of america
zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
so based on this pivot table let's
create our pivot chart
so i'll go to insert and select
recommended charts
from here
i'm going to the column chart you can
see the preview here and let me click on
ok
alright so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and
the revenue for each of the countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart
so first of all i'll delete
the field buttons okay
and let me also remove the legend
here i'll write
revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay let's format this chart a little
more
so i'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
i'll select
style 6
okay
and
let me now go under colors i will select
the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create a report which
is going to be part of our revenue
dashboard
and this is
revenue by items so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have
cosmetics vegetables cereal fruits this
cloth snacks households and other
products as well
so let's check the revenue for each of
these items
so we'll continue the same drill i'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time i'm going to drag
item type under rows
and we'll have the total revenue under
values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just short this
total revenue
from largest smallest so
you can see here office supplies made
the highest amount of revenue
followed by household then cosmetics
and fruits
meet the lowest amount of revenue
i'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time i'm
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
i'll select ok
all right
now let's format this chart a bit
i'll delete the buttons
and i'll delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
revenue
by
items
cool
we also want to
change the
color of the bars so i've selected all
the bars i'll go to my home tab
and here let
i have edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
14
and i'll remove the
bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
also let's get in blue color all right
finally
let's rename this sheet so i'll write
revenue
by
items
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so
let me show you how you can create the
dashboard
i will create a new sheet
and first thing i am going to do is
i click on the view tab and
uncheck grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
i'm going to insert image
so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard
so the way to do is i'll go to the
insert tab and under illustrations i
have the option to select pillars or
insert pictures so i'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
i'll go to desktop and here i have a
folder called
excel dashboard files
and i'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
all
right so you can see i have successfully
added a background image if you want you
still
pan this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so i'll click
on insert and here
i have the option to select
a text box
i'll click on a text box and
i'm going to place a text box in the
middle
and i'm going to name this text box as
excel
renew dashboard
on
sales
i'll
centralizenet
let's do some more formatting so i'll
select this text box on the top you can
see
shape format
here
i'm going to so
my text box is transparent now and i'll
also remove
the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and i'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to britannica bold
and i'll increase the size to let's say
t
all right
i'll just
drag the
text box
i'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard i'll go to
insert and i'll click on illustrations
again
and select
pictures
i'm going to add
this to pictures which is of a store and
a cut
to make it look
visually appealing so i'll
place the icons
here
and similarly let me just copy it and
i'll place the
cart and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dial
the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so i'll
hit
ctrl v to paste it
and will resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
chart as well
all right so now you can see i have
added
all my cuts and graphs to this dashboard
so you see here we have our line charts
our
column charts the combo charts this pie
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and
format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered
so let's adjust the
labels let me bring this
down
similarly i'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right
this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the
white background from each of the charts
and make transparent so let me show you
how to do it so i'll select this chart
then i'll right click
and go to
format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called no fill so if i select no
fill you can see let me also remove the
grid lines so i'll select the gridlines
and hit delete so you've also removed
the
grid lines from here
now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so i'll select this chart
go to format
and here
i'll go to shape outline and i'll select
no outline
you see this
so we have our total revenue by year
which is a line chart and this is
completely transparent now now what i'm
going to do is
i'll place this chart over a box
so i'll go to insert and insert shape
so i'll
click on illustration and here i'll
choose ship
and let me select
a rectangle
so i'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what i'll do is
i'll select this bring this to front
and choose
bring to front
and i'll place this
shape
below it
all right
now the next thing is to edit the shape
so first i'll change the color of this
box
so let me select this blue color
and
and let me increase the transparency so
i'll
right click and go to format shape
here i'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
let's say
print all right
next thing
we'll just cut the
font to white color
including the access labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
access labels to white color so it looks
better
now we'll just
adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove outline
so i'll go to save outline and i'll
select no outline
you see
we have now formatted art
let's just
pull this a little up all right
now we'll add
this blue background to all the other
charts so we'll first add the background
make it transparent and then we'll
convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable than visible so
for the time being i'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens
we have nicely formatted our dashboard
so
i've added a few goes here this is kind
of a map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the
labels in terms of millions
if you look on the y-axis even revenue
for year and region are all formatted in
terms of millions
if you want this you can also format the
year by revenue in terms of millions
so the way to do is you can select this
graph
right click and go to format access
here if i scroll down
you have numbers and
under category i'll select custom
then i'll select my type as
this format
which is in millions
and
you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to our
dashboard now slicers are you format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see the
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline
so
i'll select one of the charts
and then either you can go to the insert
tab and here you can see under filters
we have slices and timeline or
if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab
here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option
so i'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
fields present in the
data set
so i'll select
country
region and let's say
we want to
know by
item type and sales channel
so these are going to be my four
slicers i'll click on okay
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values on the region we have asia
this europe north america and others
similarly we have the different country
names for country slicers
and then for item type also we have all
the items that were present in our data
set
now
moving it we need to connect
all the slices to a dashboard
so what i'll do is
i'll right click
on this option
and i'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
clearly only one of the pivot table is
selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so click on
ok
all right
now that we have connected
one of our slicers will now connect the
other
remaining slicers
so i'll right click on this go to report
connections
and i'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on ok similarly let's do it for
the country slicer
i'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have
the item type so i'll right click
go to report connections all right now
let me just
organize this a bit so i'll
place my pivot tables
to the right
i'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
i'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
i'll add my final slicer that is
sales channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be
the profit dashboard i'll show you how
to add timing
all right
now i have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for
an item type let's say
beverage so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
so directive venue so you have the total
revenue by year for
beverages only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for
beverages item type
if i scroll down
now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages
let me just unchecked
all right
say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
india
so i have selected india here
and now you can see
my graph has changed only for
country india
you can see here it is showing for
india now
now similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to
know the revenue generated
based on sales channel so we have two
sales channel that is offline and online
suppose you want to know the revenue
generated offline so i'll just
select
offline you can see
the values have changed so this is where
the revenue is generated for each of the
items only for
this is
our entire excel revenue dashboard on
sales we created multiple charts and
graphs
then we applied
different forming we added
different icons then we formatted the
labels also next we added
slicers
and
finally how we could filter our data
based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this
sheet as
revenue dashboard i'll write rev
dashboard
okay
now we move to our data sheet and
start creating our pivot tables and dots
for the prop dashboard
all right so let's go ahead and create
my first pivot table
so i'll create
a worksheet
this time i'm going to create a line
chart
to visualize the profit for each year
so i'll drag my
total profit column to values and
my order year to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
you can saw data
to
get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
per table you can see
since i have sorted this in descending
order so 2014
had the maximum amount of profit
and 2017 the least amount of profit
i'll just do ctrl e to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my po chart so i'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart i'll click on ok
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now first i'll hide all
the field buttons present on the chart
and i'll
rename the chart title as
total
profit
by year
next i'm going to remove the legend so
i'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
we'll go to style
and
this
time i'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as the timing let's
have
this yellow color next let me add the
data labels
so again if you see here this is not
formatted properly
so let's go ahead and format the
data labels
so i'll click on number
and i'll select customer
and the type i'm going to select is in
millions
and i'll click on
close
so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which source total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right now let's move back to our
data sheet again
next
we have to
show the total profit by countries for
this i'm going to create a map
so let me first create my boot table so
i'll go to insert and i'll click on
pivot table
let me click on ok
since i want the country name so i'll
select country under rows and then i
have
my total profit under values
the next thing i'm going to do is rename
the row labels as
countries
and then
i'm going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me read the grand total so i am
going to select this pivot table
go to the design tab
here we have subtotals and grand totals
i'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again i'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right
now
we want to create a
map out of this the way to
i'm going to
select my data
copy it
i'll go on top
i'll paste it here
using this data i can create my film now
so i'll go to insert
here we have the option to create a
field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
i can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light grey color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in gray or you
can say light blue
have the lowest amount of profit
while the regions or the countries that
have been shaded in
dark color
a dark blue color have higher amount of
profit
i will go ahead and delete this
scale
okay
next
we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
i'll do is
i'll right click on this map and i'll go
to select data
here instead of the previous range i
have my new range now so
my new range
will be my original pivot table that i
had created
i'll go on top and click on ok
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so i'll
just put colors
and let's say we'll keep in color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made
least amount of it okay
now moving on
next
we want to create
a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel
so for this we are going to create
another line chart
so i'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so i'll select
new worksheet
here
since i want to know the profit by year
first of all i'll drag my order year
call to rows
and then
i'll choose my total profit column under
values
next i'm going to select my sales
channel under columns
there you go so we have our pivot table
here
based on this pivot table let me create
my pivot chart so i'll go to recommended
charts and i'm going to create a
i close this
you see here
based on this
chart you can tell
the profit generated with
online
sales were actually
lower than that of offline so here the
blue line represents offline profit and
the orange line represents online profit
if you mark clearly
in year
2012 the online profit was actually
higher than the offline profit
so
let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
i'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so write
profit
by
year
and
sales
channel
okay
so this is my
second report
before moving ahead let me just
rename this sheet so i'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say sc for channel
okay
moving ahead
now i want to
create a part
based on a pivot table that will profit
by sales channel only so this is going
to be pie chart so i'll first
go to insert click on pivot table and
click on ok
so i'll drag my sales channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table
now let's create our pivot chart which
is going to be a pie chart
let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so i'm going to select a donut
chart here i click on ok
let's
edit this chart i'll remove the field
buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
i'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
i am going to
format this label
i'll select the category as custom
and my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
i'll write
profit
by
let's say c which stands for sales
channel
cool
finally
i'm going to create a report that will
show the revenue and profit by items
so i'll go ahead and create my
pivot table first
this time i'll choose my
total profit under values
and we'll also have
the revenue column
so i'll put my revenue at the top
then
i'm going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table
let me now create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the orange line represents
the total profit
i'll click on ok
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title
i'll name it as
revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use
for our profit dashboard
next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building a
dashboard
so i'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so
first of all let's go to the view tab
and remove the grid lines
now
we'll
insert a background image
like we did for our revenue dashboard so
i'll go to insert
under illustrations i'll click on
pictures and select this device
i'm going to have the same background
i'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just
drag this
a bit to the right
we'll adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard
so here you can see i have brought my
revenue dashboard
and i'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
i'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
excel
profit dashboard instead of revenue
now
we'll copy each of the charts that we
just created for example
the revenue profit by items then we had
profit by sales channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
copy this as well
similarly i'll bring the other three
charts on to my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard i have added all the
charts and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
i have also
made some formatting for example i have
reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so i'll
select the first chart i'll right click
and i'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill i'll select no fill
next i'm going to remove the grid lines
so i'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so i'll go to design
actually format and i'll remove the
outline
next i'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dash so let me
select a blue box from here and i'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and i'll bring this to front
and i'll move this
to the back
next i'm going to change the font color
all to white
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
i'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here
i have my first
chart ready
the same i'm going to do for the rest of
the charts
okay so now you can see here
i have formatted all my charts i've also
added a blue background
you see here i have also formatted the y
labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit
similarly here i have added the data
labels this is for revenue
some of the charts also have the data
legends so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
i've also formatted the
map as well
okay
now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline
first let me show you how to add a
timeline
so i'll
select one of the charts and i'll go to
insert
under insert i have the option to create
a timeline
so i'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so excel has only
shown us two columns so i'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so i'll select my order date column and
i'll click on ok
you can see here this is called a
timeline i can expand this
now this timeline is based on months now
if i
scroll this timeline you can see here i
have
my
order year 2010 and i have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for 2012
all the way till 2017.
now you can filter this in terms of
years quarters months or days let me
just select year now
so i have
years from 2010 till 2017.
let me just squeeze this
and i'll place it somewhere here
on the
right now let me go ahead and create a
few slicers for my profit dashboard so i
have selected one of the charts
under insert i'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which
i want to create slicers
so i'll create a region
let me also select
country
let's say i want
the representative's name or the
customer's name
and i'll click on ok
so here i have created three slicers
let me
first
resize it and
i'll place it on the right
similarly i'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
i'll
resize this and i'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
i have to
connect all the slicers and the timeline
to
the pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so i am going
to click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here
i am going to select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here i have selected four and i need
one more which is
pivot table number 10 i click on ok
similarly let's create
or connect my region filter to all the
pivot tables so i right click go to
report connections
here i'll
choose all my pivot tables which are
based on profit
i'll click on ok
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on ok
and similarly i'll connect my
timeline as well i'll go to report
connections
and i'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then i'll click on ok
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so i am
selecting one of the pivot charts
i'll go to insert click on slicer
and i'll select
sales channel and hit ok
so i have my sales channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on ok
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing i want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017
now suppose
you want to know the profit that was
generated in the year 2012 so i'll just
click on
this range and now you can see our
charts only show information for 2012 so
this dot represents there was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
the profit by sales channel for 2012.
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit
each of these countries made in 2012.
if i scroll down you can see
the revenue and profit by items
now
if i select
another year let's say 2013 i can just
drag this to the right and
now you can see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it
went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly our map has also changed now
this is a sort of an information that we
have you can click on this and
check the information that
excel has prompted
all right so this is how you can use a
timeline now as i said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
i'll
send it back to the place where it was
and i'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose
you want to check the profit made by
different representatives you can select
them one by one
let's say adam churchill
this is the
profit generated by
adam churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
now suppose you want to see the profit
by different countries so you can use
the country slicer
let me just bring this to the middle
and
let's expand our chart a bit
okay so here you have
profit by different countries chart i'll
just
bring this to the front so that you can
see it clearly
okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say united kingdom you can
select united kingdom so this is the map
of united kingdom and it
tells you the total profit that was
generated in united kingdom
and
below you can see
the revenue and profit
for all the items that was sold in
united kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item made the highest
amount of profit in
united kingdom
now you can also select
multiple countries let's say
i want to know for france as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now i
have
united kingdom and france selected and
the other charts present
in my dashboard change accordingly
now i have my
country selected as india you can see
the map of india here
and these were the respective profit
values
now one thing to note here is this is
actually not millions that should be in
k that is thousands so please mark this
as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually k and
naught
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
pivot charts based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing
you can also change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select
another theme let's say facet
you see
the colors have changed and it looks
really beautiful similarly let me try
out
another
theme let's say organic you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay so now once you change the
theme the text also change a bit you can
see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore one more theme let's say
this time i am going to choose
depth and
this is more
of a
green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my revenue
dashboard and see how it looks
there you go
so since we changed our theme even our
revenue dashboard is also impacted so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and
play with different themes colors fonts
and effects
all right
so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart
horizontal and vertical
bar charts and then we learned how to
add slicers and
connected to different pivot tables
and we filtered our data to see
revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so here i'll be discussing some
important questions that you will come
across
when you face interview for excel
and
we will start with the basics the
beginner level
and
most of them will be discussed here will
be the beginner level at the beginning
and then we'll discuss it for at the
further left
okay so of the first question that you
might get asked is what is a cell
address in excel
so
a cell address is a combination of
column letter and a row number that
identifies a cell on a worksheet
basically each cell will have an
associated column number
column letter and a row number so you
have to keep in mind it will always be
a column letter and a row number each
excel sheet will have suppose for
instance if you take row 5
rows will be in numbers and the columns
will be in letters column a column b
column c
d and so on
and the numbers will be for the rows so
for instance
if you take this particular uh
cell
the cell address is d5
column d and row five
so this is the cell address
now
let's move on to the next one
now you will be asked what is relative
cell referencing and absolute cell
referencing in
excel
so relative cell referencing is usually
the relative references change when a
formula is copied to another cell
depending on the destinations row and
column
okay
so this is called relative cell
referencing absolute cell referencing
irrespective of the cell you know you
don't have to depend on the value of the
cell destination there is no change when
a formula is copied
so this we i'll explain it in the next
slide the basic difference is this type
of referencing is there by default in
excel relative cell referencing you just
insert the formula you don't need to put
a dollar sign in the formula whereas
absolute cell referencing if you don't
want to change in the formula when it's
copied across cell then absolute cell
referencing requires you to add a dollar
sign before and after the column
and
row address so
see for instance
this is relative referencing you know if
you see this this particular cell is
having we put the value as a3 into b3 so
what it will do is it will multiply a3
and b3 and it will give the product this
is the relative cell reference whereas
absolute cell referencing is again the
same thing but you have to put a dollar
sign
before the column and the row number so
here you are specifying
this as a3 into b2 okay
a3 into b2 and it will give you this
particular answer irrespective of that
it will give you it will calculate what
is there in this and it will give you
the answer
okay now we need to move on to the next
point is basic question when you
scroll across an excel sheet sometimes
you have a header on the first row and
if you scroll down you will not be able
to see the first row so there is a
process uh or the there is a
trick to freeze the paints in the excel
so you just need to
have the rows locked so how do you
freeze paint this is the question so
what you need to do is you need to
select the view tab go to the view tab
and go to freeze panes it's a basic
thing and you will see this if you see
here
select the third row and click freeze
panes so you just select this and click
free page
okay
so you're going here and you're going to
the third row and you are going to view
tab and you are selecting freeze pane so
what happens is first two rows will be
locked
okay
these two rows will be
locked similarly for
if you want to freeze the columns okay
it's the same thing i am going to select
this particular column
and then click on view and then click
freeze pane
so what happens is the first two columns
unlock a and b will be locked and if i
scroll right you will always see the
customer name and category column so
these two we have logged and the next
will be scroll so this is the
function of freezing panes okay
now coming on to the next one
and you will be asked
and you have an excel sheet or a
spreadsheet
and you want to restrict you want to
protect the data
for from anyone or from someone cop from
copying the cell for your worksheet so
how do you do that you need to select
that particular data that you want to
protect
and then click ctrl shift f
and then you will see the
protection tab okay
you just need to go to the protection
tab and select lock
okay and you will be asked to put a
password wherein you will be getting the
review tab where you
need to select the sheet put a password
and just save it so i will show you
across
one of the examples here so this is
particular uh data that you have and you
need to protect you select it
so here
as i said i selected it and then i just
press ctrl shift f
so here you see the protection click the
protection tab and then click select and
then locked
then click ok and then you need to go to
the review tab and then click on the
protect sheet
and you are having the you need to
select this protect worksheet and
contents of locked cells so you are
selecting these and you are protecting
the content and you just need to put
some password
okay
and then click ok
okay so this is how you protect the data
on a worksheet and you are selecting
this area ctrl shift f
and
just put up a password and select lock
sheet so this is how you protect the
sheet from anyone to copy it
now the next question that you might be
asked is what is the difference between
a function and a formula in excel
so you will be asked this question and
you need to remember this formula is
like an equation which is typed in by
the user you are typing it suppose a
1 plus b 2 you are typing this formula
in one particular cell okay whereas
function functions are predefined
calculations it is like a formula which
is already there in excel and you can
use it so as it says here it consumes
more time and it has to be typed in
manually you this is as per the need
basis and this is particularly it's very
quick and very efficient you have
inbuilt formulas in excel the sum and
multiplication product and
various other things that you will come
across so this is the basic difference
between a formula and a function in
excel okay
the now the next question that you might
be asked is uh or you need to know
basically is
the order of operations used in excel
while evaluating the formulas so what is
the order you need to remember this
acronym
pad mass p e d m a s or in other simple
terms you can use this also please
excuse my dear and sally
so these are the acronyms p
e d m a s now let's see what happens
first and you uh in math when you do
some calculations you have order of
operations okay board mass is the one of
the order of corporations now in excel
similarly in excel when you put up a
formula
you excel will calculate it
in a particular order and this is called
the order of operations and the order of
operations is first it will calculate
what is there in the parenthesis it will
perform this function and then it will
see if there are any exponents in it and
if it is there it will do that
calculation the next and after that it
will see if there is any multiplication
or division so p e d and then
it will see
if there is any addition okay and then
the last one will be the subtraction so
excel knows this and you have to know
this so that when you put up a formula
you will know what is going to happen
first and you will not mess up with your
formula okay this is the order of
operations it is one of the important
questions in the interview for a
beginner excel
level now the next one is uh
how will you write the formula for
following multiply the value in a cell a
1 by 10 and add the result by 5
and divide it by 2. it is quite simple
okay so i'm just giving it an example in
the slide and you might be asked
something else so you will be given a
task to
calculate or put up a formula for this
so when you are asked multiply the value
in a cell by of a 1 by 10 so this is
particularly
okay a 1 is the particular cell that is
being given and you are multiplying it
okay you put it in parenthesis
and then
add the result by 5 so it will calculate
the parenthesis first okay and if it
sees if there are any exponents you have
to think in that way if there are any
exponents in it or not and then
first it will see the parenthesis and
then exponent there are no exponents
here and then it will do the
multiplication and then the
addition and the division okay
so you will get this particular answer
and if you put it simply in this way
your answer is wrong because
it will multiply it into 10 add
5 and divide by 2 so you have to check
which one is right and you have to make
sure that you are putting the right
parenthesis okay
so
this is the formula
okay
the next question is uh there is a
different what is the difference between
count counter and count blank these are
three particular important things that
you need to these are similar but they
are quite different when you actually
see it okay so first we will see what is
count
count is basically it counts the number
of cells which have numeric values as
the name suggests it is count it will
count the number of cells which has
numeric volumes okay if you see per this
uh column
and
at a 11 we are putting it as
count equals to a 10 to a 2 to 8 n so
you're taking this range and you're
finding out what are the number of cells
which have numeric value if you see this
one two three four
five
so five cells have numeric values it
counts the
cells which has numeric value and the
next thing is the counter
okay what counter does it counts the
number of cells which has any form of
content it can be anything it can be a
number it can be a alphabet it can be
anything it will see what are the uh
number of cells which has any form of
content okay for example this is the
same example we here taken here and we
have put the function as counter a2 18
now see one two three four five six
seven so it sees that there is
no seven cells have some content in it
it is numbers and
letters it can be anything but it has
some content so counter is the pension
for this now the next one is count blank
okay as the name suggests it will count
the number of blank cells only
so again the same examples count blank
a2 to a10 okay it will see what are the
number of blanks okay if you see this is
blank and this is black so two cells are
blank so it will count the number of
blank cells only okay
now the next one is uh what is the
shortcut to add a filter to a table
why do we use filter and it is one of
the basics
function in the excel where you need to
do some sorting and it can be done by
using a filter what is the shortcut key
it's very simple ctrl shift and l
this is the key that is used to put up a
filter you just press this
ctrl shift l all together and you will
find the filter and you can
sort it now the next question that
you'll come across is how do you create
a hyperlink in excel so it's quite
simple there is a simple shortcut ctrl
k you press these two together and you
will get the option you will select the
it will select the cell where you have
to insert the hyperlink hyperlink
basically it redirects to any other
document it can be a web page it can be
a word document it can be another excel
sheet or so on okay so these are the
things
okay
now another important question
that is
how to merge multiple cells
text strings in a cell so how do we
merge the text strings in multiple cells
into one cell
there is one particular simple function
that you can use which is called called
as concatenate concatenate function is
used to merge text strings present in
multiple cells
okay and it's a very simple thing you
just need to put this equals to
concatenate
and then if for example this is the
formula concatenate text one text to
text
or this is
concatenate a1 comma b1 comma c1 this is
the data in our
three cells excel is fun in a1 b1 and c1
so now
if you want to put them all in one
and you can merge it in one cell using
the concatenate function and it's very
simple concatenate
and parenthesis a1 comma p1 comma c1
okay and you will get it all merge in
one particular cell
okay
so this is how you use the concatenate
function and you can also use the and
operator to combine cell values it is
the same thing you can use the and
operator instead of commas okay
and i will show it to you in the example
here
okay now we have this i'll just copy
this thing to
here
okay
and let's make it simple
and now i want to put this here equals
on
concatenate
and a one
comma b one
comma c
i just close it and i put enter so
you see this this all the the different
text is merged in one particular cell
and it will you can perform various
merge functions using the concatenate
function it's a very simple thing and it
is a frequently asked questions in the
interview okay
the next question uh it is very a very
important one again
and very basic as well so how can you
split a column into two or more columns
you have some particular text or a
sentence written or data written in your
cell or a column and you want to put
them across in two or more or many
number of columns so how do you perform
this function it's very simple again you
need to select that particular cell so
for instance we have it here is india is
a democratic country india space is
space a space democratic space country
so the it's a different text here and
you want to split this particular
sentence into different columns okay you
need to select that cell
and then go to the data tab and then
choose text two columns there will be an
option and you need to select text to
columns okay and you will see this
screen okay
and you need to select the choose the
delimiter here and what we are
specifying here is first it is a
delimited and then we are selecting a
delimiter as space because we see that
it is
space here which is very common and we
want to split it so you will see a
preview here which shows what your
output will be like india in one column
is
a democratic country so the denominator
is space here
and
t you need to select this and then click
next okay
so you will see the options select the
columns data format and choose the
destination now you see the data preview
and you need to select the destination
where you want to put this output as and
you select that and then click finish
and this one what it does it it's it
splits the text into multiple columns
okay so you see this you have selected
this as the output and it starts here
india is a democratic country so
you will come across some data which is
you know huge and there are spaces or
obliques or anything that is
differentiated it with and you need to
put them in different rows or different
columns so this is the
function r that you need to use to split
the text into different or multiple
columns okay
okay the next question can be very
simple one or most widely used in fact
and what is the use of vlookup and how
do we use it so what is this particular
thing in excel vlookup function is used
for looking up a piece of information in
a table and extracting some
corresponding data or information so you
have some set of values in one
particular column and
you want to retrieve or extract the data
corresponding to that particular
column or a cell
in the whole sheet okay so the syntax is
something like this it is you need to go
to one particular
cell where you want the output as and
you type the function
we look up and
you are selecting the value of it is the
cell exactly where you want the output
to be and you are selecting the table
here
and the you're specifying the column
index
and range lookup so value this indicates
the value that you have to look for in
the
first column of a table okay
and then the table table basically this
refers to the table from which you have
to retrieve a value we will show this in
the example in the next slide
and the column index column index it
provides the column in the table from
which vr
to retrieve a value okay you will
specify the column index which one you
are looking for
the next thing is range lookup which is
optional true
with
if you put true it is approximate match
which is default and false if it is
exact match if you are looking for the
exact match so what is the use of
vlookup and how do we do it okay so
prime the product related to a customer
name richard okay you have this sheet
and in this one you want to see what
richard has bought okay what is a
product that he has bought and you can
do this with the
vlookup function okay so you just go
here and you type in the function
vlookup you're naming it as richard
and
first thing is the value it is h4 okay
and then the next thing is the table
okay table is a2
because this is the
table okay and you're looking for
customer name richard
okay
and then you're selecting this
the whole
column index which is e15 i mean you're
selecting this whole table then 15 okay
e 15 you're selecting this and then the
next thing is optional which is giving
you the
uh
range lookup okay what it does is it's
optional it is you're looking for an
exact value or an approximate by default
it is
approximate map so how it performs the
function okay
so it gives you the answer as camera it
goes and look up for richard in this
particular it will give you the output
here and the
a2 is the table that it will look for
the customer name
and it will search for richard and then
it will give you the
output as camera now the next thing will
be vlookup different from lookup
function how different they are vlookup
lets the user look for a value in the
leftmost column of a table so as we have
seen in the example it
allows you to look for a data in the
leftmost column of the table and returns
the value in a left to right okay it
starts in left to right well lookup
function lets the user look for data in
a row column and returns the value in
the another row or column it will give
you the lookup function in the next
workout okay not very easy to use as
compared to the lookup function okay as
we see uh it's a bit complicated when
you compare it to the
lookup function it's quite simple and
it is used to replace the
v lookup function okay
so this is the
different
lookup and vlookup function
now excel is basically used for
reporting mainly used for reporting to
management you have to extract different
kinds of
reports and what are the report formats
that are available in excel this is one
of the uh important questions again
for a beginner level and there are three
formats basically compact form
outline form tabular form okay these are
the three formats
that are available report formats that
are available
in
excel okay
the next question is about a function
which is how does if function work in
excel okay the f function in excel it
actually performs a logical test
and you will give a condition it
performs the test and returns a value if
the test evaluates to true and another
value which you again will specify if
the test result is false okay for
instance
we have here a simple example which is
shown in the slide and what we are doing
here is written record is valid if age
is greater than 20 we have age here
specified
and salary is greater than 40 000 else
return the record is invalid so we are
giving two conditions and it actually
checks and evaluates whether these
conditions are met and it will give you
the output whether record is
valid or invalid based on the two
conditions that are specified okay
and f2 to access which is this these
column we are specifying it should be
greater than 20 and g2 to g6 which is
the salary column and we are specifying
the condition to be greater than 40 000
so based on this two things it will
check and perform if these conditions
are
met then it will give the desired result
okay so this is the function that is
used
in excel if function okay
the next thing is sum if function
okay again the sum function adds the
cell values specified by a given
condition or a
criteria so you are giving a condition
and you are actually doing another
function which is performing the
addition okay it will add the cell
values based on a condition again it is
shown here the total sum of salary where
salary is greater than 75 000 again for
example the salary column is g2 to g6
and we are doing a sum if function what
the result will be it will
perform the addition of salaries which
are greater than 75 000 so it will see
which values are greater than 75 000 and
then then the output will be it will be
adding these
salaries which are greater than 75
000 okay
now coming to the next
slide we will discuss another important
function counter and we'll find the data
um result based on the data that we have
and the context function so we have a
slide uh the data here and using the
kovi data find the number of days in
which the number of deaths in italy has
been greater than 200 okay it's not
shown here for some reason but i will
show you in the exact sheet okay so this
is the data that we have and we will try
to find the function so we'll use the
countdown function and counter function
is again simple counter you are
specifying the
column that is the uh source that you
are looking for that is g2 the column g
and it is two it starts from two pro two
g two till g three five triple seven
which is the end of the column and what
you're looking for is italy you are
specifying it in codes
italy and then the next column that it
will look for is the e column the number
of cases okay here we have the number of
cases e2 again we are specifying the
range and what we're looking for is
number of cases which are more than 20.
so we'll perform this function and we'll
show you the
output okay i'll show you to you the
excel
so here is the sheet and i will uh try
to get the
answer here
and
the
so we are performing count
and okay
count
and you are giving the
brackets parenthesis g2 which is the
countries column okay countries column
here who are specifying the whole range
three
five triple seven
that is basically uh
a long list of
data and you're specifying the range and
what you're looking for is particularly
any country you can pick up like
algeria
okay
algeria
and you specify it in codes
okay
comma
then what is the next target that you
are looking for is the column e variable
it is mentioning the number of cases
okay
so you specify the
column range for the number of cases
which is again e
and then
uh
the three
five triple seven i mean it's a
basically
long list of data that you're looking
for and then
you are what is the condition that you
want to know and you have to specify the
course and what you're looking for is
number of cases which are more than
can you hit enter
okay so it gives you the output as 143
so there are 143 days in which the
number of cases were more than 20. so
let's uh refine our search further let's
see 30
and it gives 140
so another example that you can take is
let's pick afghanistan
afghanistan and
so there are about 19 days that
you will see the number of cases where
more than 30
and this can be done with the
count if function
so the next question is uh about
the pivot table
so what is a pivot table
it's basically is a summary of table of
the data set i mean the data that is
there that can be you know multiple
number of rows and columns which has
different
uh data
that has to be that is there in the
reports and you need to analyze those
trends and you need to create a report
and basically present it to the
management or in a presentation
so pivot table is a summary of table you
know whatever data is there you can put
it in a summarized format they are
useful if you have long rows or columns
that hold values you need to try okay so
you have long list of data and you need
to summarize it and
put it in a
presentation or a
you need to track the values so
it's very simple you have to select the
data and then go to the insert tab and
select pivot table
okay
and then it will show up like this and
you need to
select the table which is a
table or range and then you need to
specify where you want to put up this
pivot table okay and it's quite simple
and i can show it to you in one of the
examples okay
so
what you need to do is you need to
select this and once you generate or
as we have seen in the previous slide
you need to select this and you need to
select the output where you want to put
the pivot table and then once you do
that
you will see something like this and you
need to select these particular fields
and put it in value so it will for
example you need to select the depth
number of death you can just simply say
click this select this drag and drop it
in the values okay so these are the
different fields that can be put up in
the table okay we can show it to you in
the example here
so this is our data and we need to
show it in a pivot table okay select
this
and then go to the insert tab and click
private table okay
select that
and it will show you the
uh table or the range and now where you
want to put it okay i will put it in the
existing worksheet okay
and i'll just select which column i'll
put it
here for example and it will show you
this and click ok so this is the table
and now you need to select the fields
that you want to show in the table for
example we need to see the continents
the number of cases as per the
continents okay i selected and put it in
the row and we see the immediately we
see it in a table
where you see the number of names of the
continents and now i want to see the
number of cases
and
i simply select it
and put it across the value so this is
quite simple and very informative very
short and crisp
form of presenting the data in
a private table okay
so this is how it is being used and it
is being presented
you just need to go to the insert tab
pivot table and it will generate the
table and then you can select the fields
all right
so the next question here is uh how do
we create a drop down list in excel
this is particularly useful when you
need to sort
particular data with the drop down list
where a number of
different variables are there and you
need to select one particular
field and sort the data so you can do
this by creating a drop down list using
the data validation
present in the data tab it's quite
simple you select the data and you go to
the data validation tab in the data and
click select data validation
so once you select that it will ask you
to specify a range so you need to select
what data you need to
sort and put a drop down so you need to
select this and click
data validation and you select the list
option which shows you that there is a
different option okay i'll show it
across in the excel for example what we
have here is uh some particular data and
we have different
variables we need to sort or put a drop
down list so just go to data as in as
said in the slides and go to data
validation
and click data validation now as you
click it it will ask you to data
validation settings okay and in the drop
down go and select list option
so it will ask you to specify the source
so when you asked
to specify the source
just click this particular column and
click ok so here dimensioning the source
is
column b okay b
3 t
b 14 okay
click ok and then it will give you the
option so here you can
you can put this in anywhere across the
excel
and click the option okay
so this is the way to drop down using
the data validation option so in the
next example we will see so how do we
apply advanced filters in excel
we use the advanced filter option
present in the data tab so
this is the scenario wherein you have
multiple set of data
and you need to sort it and it's here
it's actually huge data
and you need to sort a particular column
or a field
with this criteria
and you can select it and specify the
criteria and specify a range what you
want to
select or based on what criteria the
range can be specified
and you can just get it in a single
click
so this is the option you have to go to
data tab advanced and you have to apply
the advanced filter and then you need to
specify the list range that is the
basically the source
and then the criteria where you specify
the criteria
present here i mean you are specifying
in this case we will take an example
wherein we are trying to sort the data
or the number of cases based on number
of deaths
and in a particular country and we are
specifying the
output we the copy to field is the
output where you will see the output
so i'll show it to you in the excel so
here we have a spreadsheet wherein you
will see all the
uh data kobe data that we have and based
on the countries and the continents and
the number of deaths number of cases and
so on
okay and it also has different fields
like the date year and month
so so here i am going to sort the data
which is particularly for europe and
which has deaths of more than 200 in a
day so how do we do it go to data
advanced and
the
you need to select copy to another
location okay and this is the list train
so it's basically given in this
countries okay
and the criteria range you have to
specify this so i am going to select
this as my criteria okay
and then
i have to put the output in one
particular cell so i need to select it
again
let's say here
okay
and then i just click okay
see
it's quite simple instead of running
through the whole thing
we can just do it with a simple
function okay
so it shows me the deaths which are more
than 200
and
for which particular country and for
which particular
continents all right so this is
basically
made very simple with this option the
next question is
you know you need to highlight some
particular cells using a particular
criteria in this case we are trying to
analyze or highlight those cells where
the total sales is more than five
thousand dollars so what we do is we use
conditional formatting to highlight the
cells based on the criteria
it's a very
useful tool in analyzing data and
visually it helps you know you can have
a look at the
data in
quick flash you will see the
data and it's quite visible using the
conditional formatting so how we do that
is i will show it to you
now
so as said in the slide we have the data
of the sales that is provided to us and
we need to see
who has done more sales which is greater
than the five thousand dollars so just
go to home and you need to say go to
conditional formatting so for that you
need to highlight or select this go home
conditional formatting highlight
okay and you have different options here
you select greater than
and you specify the value right here my
criteria is five thousand
dollars okay we can select which color
so let's go for green
okay
see this you will immediately see
the
option you don't have to dig or looking
deep into the data and find out which
one is more than 5000 or any particular
value okay so conditional formatting now
moving on to the next question the index
and match function you must be familiar
with the index and match function and
why it is used basically index
function is a very powerful tool
wherein you know you for example you
have a table of
planets in our solar system and you want
to get the name of the fourth planet
mars so you can do it with a formula
using the index function and at the same
time
you can use the match function okay with
the match function together you can play
wonders with it okay match function is
another
function that is designed to find the
position of an item in a range for
example we can use the match function
to get the position of a word or
look or
in this case we have a name and we can
use the index and match function to
find the city how we do that is
shown here
okay
it
it looks quite complicated here when you
see the formula but
i can show it to you in the excel and
explain it further okay
so here i have and i want to know
where these people are and where they
belong to
okay
so
let's see how it goes as we have seen it
and
we use the index function okay
index okay
now when i have to specify the
range okay
so the range is a2 and it shows it
selects the
name and i want to select it from a2 to
a7 okay e7 circuit
e
column e
7
okay so as you see it highlights the
whole table okay now what i'm going to
do is i want to match it okay
match it with a condition i have i am
specifying a condition
a
10 why
because i have to specify a name here
and it will show me the
city where he belongs to okay
where it shows is a
two okay if you see a2 it shows the name
through a7 i have to specify the range
here okay not just one name we are
specifying the
whole range as you see if you put the
values it will show you the selection
okay
it's in and what it should be it should
be the
exact match so
zero denotes the exact match parenthesis
is closed
and i am putting another match condition
okay what is this and this will give me
the output
what output is
okay
nine okay this is my
city b9 is the city where i'm trying to
find from okay and what it should look
for is a column a a one through
e
one okay
let it select these
this particular
row and
what it should be it should be the exact
match again okay
let's see how it goes it will give you
an error because you haven't put the
value here okay so let's see
andrew okay
hit enter and you will see
the city where he belongs to okay
now let's see where anna belongs to
enter let's use dallas okay so this is
the
one other function index and match
function being used and it can be asked
in frequently in the interview questions
okay the next question will be uh how to
find duplicate values in a column
okay there are two ways that you can
actually do this and one is
basically the very simple one which is
the conditional formatting and the other
one is we have seen this before count if
function okay how we do that you need to
simply select the data
and
go to conditional formatting
and select duplicate values
it's quite simple and there is another
way
which give you the color coded
conditional formatting again there is
another way is the count if function how
we do that is again the
you have to put another column and put
up a
counter criteria content function
wherein you see that you are specifying
the range
and
the
the value which is being twice or
entered duplicate
and you have to put up a condition i'll
show it to you in the x
so here we have the data and i need to
find the duplicate values here so i just
select this
and as i said it's quite simple go to
conditional formatting
home and then go to conditional
formatting and select highlight cell
rules and
simply go down and select the duplicate
values
okay it will give you what color you
want you can simply select red or
anything as you see the moment you
select you will see the
duplicate values highlighted okay so i
just cancel this and there is another
way then count a function so
i'll put another column
where it says duplicate names and
i will put up a counter function here
okay
so let's see how a countdown function
works here to check the or find the
duplicate name
so as i said i will put up a formula a
function here for the count f
and we'll drag it to other cells okay
count it and uh
since it's an absolute
reference
i have to put up a dollar symbol
okay my reference here it will be h the
column here h
two
okay
and again dollar because i'm using it as
an absolute reference
column
through
dollar symbol again
nine
okay so it drags still at the whole
it drags till the
all the names okay that h9 all right
and then
what i'll do is i'll put a comma
in
why i want to do is i have to
select
h2
okay this is my criteria i mean it is
repeating twice all right
and
i have to
close the parenthesis and if it is more
than one okay
so this is my formula i just put enter
and it should say true so this is the
condition
and it is true okay i simply drag it
the whole thing
and whether events is uh repeated yes
it's true
andrew it's a duplicate entry false
me
is a duplicate entry and it says true
and as you see me and evans are
duplicate entries so this is how we use
the countdown function
and the conditional formatting to sort
duplicate entries in the date
now let's move on to the last question
for the beginner level and since we have
duplicate entry there is also
a problem to remove duplicate entries so
how can you remove duplicate values in a
range of cells okay to simply do that
you can delete the duplicate values in a
column by simply selecting the
highlighted cells and press the delete
button so you go in each column and you
see the duplicate values
select it and delete it okay
and this is one tedious way of doing it
and you can also after deleting the
values you can go to the conditional
formatting choose clear rules to remove
the rules from the sheet so this is one
way okay the next thing is again a
simple button that is there in the
data tab that is the
is one of the tools present in the data
tab which is simply called as remove
duplicates it's quite simple
and it's there in the data tools let me
show you in the excel
so here we are and we have this data and
we need to check and remove the
duplicate so as i said go to the
data tab and simply click on remove
duplicates and when you click on it it
will ask you you want to continue or
expand the selection i just say continue
with the current selection and remove
duplicates okay
select all click ok to duplicate entries
that were removed previously we saw that
events and
[Music]
and away there any weather so that has
been removed
okay
so
that's it for the beginner level and
we'll go to the intermediate level in
the next slides choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so here we are at the intermediate level
questions and these are like higher
level or intermediate level
compared to the previous things that we
have discussed with the basic level
questions uh for the excel interview so
let's move on to the next thing
and
so there are there are some scenarios
where you enter the date or
some dates in particular data sheet
and you need to find out
what is the
day of the week okay so you might be
asking a question how do you find out
the day of a week for a particular date
so that is the function we we have a
specific function and that is the
weekday function to find out the day of
the week for a particular date
okay
so as we know these are the seven days
of the week
and
we just put the
function as it says
equals to weekday and we need to enter
the
column or the area or the cell address
here so weekday is the function and it
will give you the
which which day it is of the week okay
we go as it says one it denotes sunday
okay
and three is again tuesday okay
so this is the function that is used to
find the day of the week
so now we move on to the next one
and there is a there might be a question
what are the wild cards available in
excel so basically excel sports three
types of wild cards which are
asterix the star it represents any
number of characters it can be used in
different formulas and all like
multiplication and all so it represents
any number of characters okay the next
one next wildcard is the question mark
it represents one single character okay
you just need to memorize this in the
back of your mind that it represents one
single character okay whereas asterisk
is
it represents any number of characters
and the third one which is really used
in excel it is the tilde
it is used to identify a wildcard
character that is a
tilde asterisk question marks in the
text okay and it is very rarely used so
you need to memorize these three things
that the there are three types of wild
cards we can see the functions of these
in the later sessions okay
the next one is
we have a
question here what is the data
validation illustrate with an example
you might be asked this question and you
have to know what is data validation
what is what is it used for and you you
should know how to set up in an example
okay data validation is a feature in
excel that is used to control what a
user can enter into a cell okay so you
have with the data validation you are
not allowing
a data kind of data that should be input
in the
cell okay for example
you
have the authority
and by setting up the data validation
that you can enter either a number or a
text or a just number
and so on okay using the data validation
and where is it available it is in the
data tab okay select data validation
option present under data tools
okay and you just need to select the
particular
cells where you want to set up the data
validation i'll show it to you in an
example so this is how it looks like you
just need to go to data tools and click
on data validation and it will show you
and you have the options here allow and
if you click on the drop down you will
see different options like i will show
it to you in the example here
okay
for this particular thing if i want you
know this column should have only
names and it should have if you insert a
number you will be thrown with an error
okay you will get an error message
saying that this is not a valid option
okay
so
there are some columns where you have to
put only names or you have to put only
number so you can set this up with the
data validation
technique okay you just allow it or
customize it as per your requirement so
this is how it looks like when you set
up an app so here we have set up a data
validation saying that it should not
allow you to put any text okay so you
will get an error when you put a number
here the value does not match data
validation restrictions defined for this
cell okay
so here as an example i have some data
where i am putting the names here and
i'll put the salary here i want to make
sure that you know we cannot
enter any
numbers here okay it should be only text
it should have only name so how do i
perform that how do i restrict any user
to
that they should not be able to enter
any number and you should only enter the
text okay so there is a function okay
you just need to go to data validation
click data validation
and here in the settings i'll go to
custom there are different options here
you can you can choose whole numbers
decimal list
date time so your these are the options
and i go to custom and i'm giving a
particular formula here okay what is
that it should be only text okay so it's
a simple thing it should be text and i
need to define the range okay so how
i'll define the ring i just select this
okay and
i select the range okay
so i have selected the range here and if
you go to input message
and error alert you can customize it and
here we are taking the default one
and this is the input message if you
want to set or customize something okay
so let's see how it works okay i have
said this and then i try to put a number
here
and it throws me an error the value
entered is not valid because we have set
a restriction a user has restricted
values that can be entered into the cell
so this is how the data validation works
okay the next thing is
you will be given a situation wherein
you have to
uh you will be given data and you have
to
perform a function like
in this example we are taking a
condition wherein you will have data and
you have to specify the result based on
the data you have to
formulate it okay so given below
is a student table write a function to
add password fail to the results column
based on the following criteria you will
be given a criteria so this is the
student table you are giving the student
names marks and attendance and then
based on that
you will have to specify
a
next uh a formula
wherein you will see the result okay
based on the past uh student data you
have to put a pass fail results in the
column based on the following criteria
what is the criteria and for example
here in this example what they're saying
is
you have to
say this the student is passed if his
marks is more than 60 and the attendance
is more than 75 percent okay so how we
perform this function as it says you
have to use the if function and check
with the and condition to fill the
results column okay
so let's see this in the example here
so here is the example and we will
perform the
if function and check with the and
function so how we do that is here okay
so i have to
put the if function here
okay and check with the and function
okay
and i have to specify the conditions i
have to satisfy where it should see the
or check the
conditions okay so we are checking the
conditions here and the
marks should be in row um in the column
u
and it starts with u5 so let's see
u
five okay it will immediately go to
column u and five row five okay
and then what is the condition we are
satisfying here it should be greater
than
60 okay
and the other condition is
uh the column v that is the attendance
column okay and what is the condition we
are specifying v
5 should be greater than
75 okay
and we just close this conditions with
the parenthesis and now we have to
specify the result whether it is pass or
fail
[Music]
pass
comma
in quotes again
wait okay so let's see how this works
okay
okay see this works okay the marks is 50
and attendance is greater than 80. so he
is
failed because his marks are 50 his
attendance must be more than 75 but yes
he is he has not scored marks more than
60. so we drag the same formula to the
whole thing and you will see the result
okay this is quite simple and you will
see this
formula and using the if and
check and check with and condition okay
now moving on to the next uh question
you might be asked to
you know this is a simple function
wherein you can
you will be asked to calculate your age
in years from the current date okay so
how we do that there is a particular
function and it's very simple use the
year frag or dated if function to return
the number of whole days between start
date and the end date so you specify a
standard which will be today's date and
the
i mean the birthday and then the end day
will be
today's day for example okay and you
will get to know the age using the year
frac function and dated if function okay
so here is a small example and this is
how we use the
ear frag function okay you specify this
uh function and then specify the input
tips that is the today's date and the
date of birth and the
today's date okay and this is one of the
ways to get it and there is also dated
okay this again it is day-to-day
function and you specify the input cells
okay so let me show you an example for
the same
so here we are and
we have today's date that is the fourth
of may
and date of birth for anything it could
be
so i will specify the
ear track function okay
equals
here
rack okay
and then i should as soon as you enter
you specify the start date and the end
date okay
and i will specify the start date as
today's date that picks the column and
then i put the
comma
and then the end date should be this
thing okay
and just close it and it will give you
the
age
okay so this is the age for example if
you want to find out my age i don't want
to reveal my body but it's okay
okay
let's see if it calculates
i'm 32 years old okay all right so this
is one of the ways and similarly you can
use the dated if function shown in the
example all right now moving on to the
next question
you have nested if statements this is
very important and you will definitely
be
coming across this question how are
nested if statements used in excel what
are nested if statements the f function
can be nested i mean it can be loop when
we have multiple conditions to meet okay
it can be nested the false value is
replaced by another if function okay
you have specified some condition and
you are
putting up a condition and if that
condition is not there or not met then
if it will be replaced with another
if function so
the syntax will be like this below is an
example so we
actually we use two if statements in
conjunction okay so here is an example
here we are specifying a condition
wherein you know
uh the result is excellent if it is more
than 80 and if it is less than 16 it is
bad or average
so this is very simple you perform one
if condition and if that is not met
it will go for the next if condition so
we are nesting two if conditions we are
joining two if statements
okay
i'll show the same example here in the
excel
so here we are we have some data and the
students and their marks okay and we are
specifying a condition wherein
if the
result or marks are more than 80 the
result is excellent and if it is
less than 60 it is bad or average okay
so how we get this is we use two if
conditions if
statements
so
ah as we have seen it
if
if now the first condition is uh our
source or the
source is b
two okay so b
two
and what i'm specifying is it should be
greater than
eighty
all right i just close this
and the result should be
excellent okay
excellent if it is more than 80 and
if this condition is not met it will go
to the
next
if statement okay we are nesting another
if statement what is the condition here
for the next statement it will check b2
is
less than or equal to 60 you can specify
any marks all right so if it is less
than 60 it should give the result as
bad
or
average okay
specify anything and you
okay
and just close the double parameters so
let's see how it works okay see
it works like this
now let's pull up the same
formula the for the other results okay
see
if it is more than 90 it is 90 it is
excellent so it is checking the first
thing if it is greater than 80 it is
excellent okay and now in this case for
mark it is bad why because it will first
see whether it's excellent or not if it
is not excellent then it will check the
other condition if it is less than 16 it
will give you the
bad result all right
and similarly so on for the
other
marks all right
so this is how we use the
nested if statements
you are adding two if statement the
first condition and the second condition
with another if statement okay
okay when it comes to excel it is
basically involves a lot of data and a
lot of data to be analyzed
and we have some powerful tools which
are used in excel to analyze the data
one such
important tool is descriptive statistics
that is used to analyze the data so
we might come across a question and you
will be given a data or a table and you
need to find the descriptive statistics
of the columns using data analysis too
okay so you will be given us maybe for
example anything and you will have a lot
of data you have to use the descriptive
statistics
option
in
excel for the data analysis okay how you
do that is you have to add a pack okay
you should be knowing that you need to
add a
pack which is called the analysis tool
pack which you go to
uh file options and then just click on
the add-in and select the analysis tool
pack click
excel add-in and just click go
then it will add the
option
and then when you select the data you
have to go to the click on the data
analysis option which will be
which will show up when you select the
add-in or when you add the
adam okay then you need to select the
descriptive statistics what we need to
do is we need to analyze this data and
it will show you the values like mean
and the
you can also customize you can you see
you have these data and for you to check
each and every row and find the mean the
smallest the
maximum number
and things like that so this can be
easily done using the descriptive
statistics for the data analysis
uh i'll show the same thing in the excel
how it can be performed so here we are
and i'll show you first how to
add the
option to it okay go to add-in
select analysis tool pack
as shown in the slide and you need to
click go if you just click ok it will
not add so just click go and then you
need to select analysis tool pack okay
it will give you these are the different
options uh
for now we are selecting analysis tool
back and then click ok as soon as you do
that you will see the data analysis this
option gets enabled
when you add that back so this is the
data that you have you need to find or
analyze using the descriptive statistics
so as you see it
click data analysis and click uh select
descriptive statistics okay and it will
show up the option like this and you
need to select the input range okay for
some reason it's already there
and
if you want me to show i will show it to
you across you have to select the whole
date
okay this is my input range you need to
select this labels in the first row so
that you know it doesn't take the first
row okay i'll show you
okay and now i'm putting the output in
another worksheet okay you can specify
or you can push by a new worksheet and
these are the
options that you can select so you can
you are getting a summary statistics
which is the
default and you can select the
confidence level that is the mean value
and you can set it up by
whatever value percentage you want and
you are selecting the largest one and
the smallest number so all these data
will get analyzed and it will open up in
a new sheet and just click ok and you
will see this so these are the if you
see this is our data paid organic social
and revenue so this is uh
okay
let's make it more precise
okay
so with a single click
there all our data is analyzed okay this
is the mean value and this is the
minimum is zero maximum is so concern
this is the total and the number of
count is thousand so you don't need to
scroll down and check what is the
largest
amount that is paid so this is the
largest amount for the
paid okay and so on so
the largest revenue generated all these
things are
generated with a descriptive analysis
okay
descriptive statistics with the data
analysis too so the next question is
about a pivot table and this is more
refined or more advanced compared to the
last one that we discussed in the
beginner level so here you are asked to
create a pivot table to find the total
cases in each country belonging to their
respective continents you are giving you
are being asked to
put up a table of pivot table with two
variables basically each country and
their respective continents so again we
have the same data
and we need to set up a pivot table
which shows the continents in the
countries with the respective continuous
the number of cases
okay so let's see how we get this in the
example
so here we are we have the same data it
shows the days months here cases
countries
and their
continents okay
continents here and so on okay so i'm
i'll go to the insert tab and select the
pivot table okay again the same thing i
will be asked to enter a input range
okay
so i select this
and since it's huge i'll just
put the number to be seven seven seven
seven
okay let's assume
now this is our input reader and
where you want the output to be it's
already selected you can put it anywhere
i am putting it here okay just click ok
and it will give you the option to
select the fields now what we want is
number of cases okay which will show you
the value and the
countries
and
territories their respective continents
so okay so this is how it looks like and
we have to check
now it is asking us to find the
countries okay so
with their respective continents
you see this you see africa as a
continent and you will see
okay
you will see africa
if you just remove this you will see the
number of con i mean the cases with the
respective continents and if you want to
include these countries territories
where their respective continents you
will see
as such if you just expand this
you will see the countries that are
having the cases in the continent africa
okay so country wise sorted with the
continents okay this is
the other advanced step to get the data
or show the data in the pivot table okay
another question that you might be asked
is a basic and we have already seen this
in the previous example that i have
shown how do you provide the dynamic
range in data source of a pivot table
you have to select a particular data
source in your input table
have to show up in the pivot table so
you have to select the input range but
how do you
create or how do you create a provide a
dynamic range in this data source so
just need to create a name table to
provide a dynamic range so
where is the data of your table so as we
have seen in the previous example you
will be
able to select the input range and you
just need to put this value any number
so that you know it will pick up the
dynamic range for your input source for
the table okay so now we move on to the
next one and this is about about the
pivot table again is it possible to
create pivot table using multiple
sources of data yes
yes you can create a pivot table from
multiple worksheets sometimes you will
have different data in different sheets
can you create a pivot table for
all the worksheet in a single pivot
table yes you can but there is a
condition there should be a common row
in both the table so you cannot have
different types of data there should be
a common row okay
so then only it will act as a primary
key for the first table and the foreign
key for the second table okay
so this is something that you have to
remember and you need to create a
relationship between the tables and then
build the pivot table so you have to
analyze what kind of data it is it
should have a common row in both the
tables on both the sheets
and then you have to establish a
relationship between this table and then
build the table okay there is a visit
for that we'll
see that later now let's move on to the
next question so the next question is
again you know with the pivot table uh
wherein you will be asked to further
refine or
you know refine your search and show it
in the data so here we have with the
kovit data example again you will be
asked to create a pivot table to find
the top three countries from each
continent based on the total cases using
the
coveted again we have done this before
we have created a pivot table for this
and we need to further refine it showing
the top three countries with the number
of cases
and i will show that same thing in the
excel and we already have created a
table and we'll refine it further to
show the top three countries which are
having the
highest number of accounts in the
respective context so here we are we
have the uh table uh already with us and
i just click on the
show field list it will show me the
countries and territories what we are
asked is you know to show the countries
with the top three that is number of
cases
so
you just need to go here and you need to
select the value filter there is a
filter which you can select with the
value and how i select top 10 and what i
need is top three it's very simple and
you just need to know these things okay
and based on the number of cases okay
this is our field already then just
click ok and it will show you the top
three countries so it's quite simple and
it is very important to know this
field and how you play with the value of
the filters for each particular
field in the pivot table so it shows you
these things all right and now you can
refine it further with the continents
and all
okay
so different continents and you can see
this so you go there and there is a
value filter you can set up all right we
have set up a value filter okay
okay now there is another one
how do you create a column in a pivot
table okay like you will be given a
situation where you need to add one more
column and show it in the pivot table
with a particular calculation or with a
particular value
and you have you don't have that actual
value in your
data but you have to calculate it and
show it across in the table so there is
another option which is called pivot
table analyze and you need to create a
calculated field from pivot table
analyze option
so when you go to your table and then go
to pivot table analyze you will see the
option
to add a calculated field
okay
just go there and click select
calculated field and you need to define
so in this example we are going to
define another
column where we calculate the bonus of
the sales and there is a particular
formula the formula is you put an if and
statement
and then you calculate the formula you
specify what is the bonus and what is
the way that you are calculating the
bonus and it will
particularly added another column to
your table so let's see how we do that
in the
table net so here we are we have this
table and i have inserted a
pivot table and i am putting it in
output here
okay
and then
you will get the table okay
now you need to select the
customer name
and the unit sold unit price sales
okay so we'll add another column to it
how we do that is this
go to pivot table tools and then you go
to analyze okay
click on field items and set okay you
need to select calculated field here
select that and we are defining a new
field here which is the bonus
bonus and
as i said we will put up a formula for
this and we will define it how we
calculate the bonus okay with an if and
statement which we have seen before how
we
uh put up a
and if and statement okay now i'm going
to say it as uh
[Music]
like this sales my sales
should be
i'll specify a condition how they will
calculate the bonus if sales is greater
than 4000
and
the units sold okay i am trying to put
it as a the units which also depends on
the units
sold
is greater than
thousand okay for example let's say a
thousand a person who is uh
able to
do uh
sales of thousand four thousand and the
unit sold should be more than thousand
then the sales
what is this the bonus will be
sales
into that is the amount of sales he has
done
into five percent okay let's say five
percent bonus
and
sales
is
if it is two percent okay
okay
we are adding this field bonus
click add
okay
so we have added this and we have put up
a calculation for the formula and you
will see this
so this is simple way of adding the
column to your existing data and we are
doing the calculations and showing it up
okay so this is one way go to pivot
table analyze and field
items and sets you can select this
option and add it
okay you can customize this as i said
with adding different fields this is
pretty handy in analyzing the data which
does not exist in the table and you add
some value to your pivot table okay
the next uh question will be about
slicer you must be familiar with what a
slicer is in a pivot table and how do
you use it for the purpose of using it
and how do you
put up a slider in the pivot table so
how does a slicer work basically slicers
are used to further filter data in the
pivot table suppose you already have
some data
and it's for ease that you can do it by
just adding a slicer you can select
particular uh
data in or a field and you can see the
output for that particular field that
you have chosen in the
slicer okay so it's very simple go to
the insert tab and select slicer under
filters okay
and then it will be like this okay
and here if for example you see this is
our period table we have added two
slicers
to filter our table that is month and
countries and territory so this will be
the general pivot table that looks like
and we haven't added another two slices
that is month and country so if you go
for example if you want to see
what is the
number of cases and some of the debts
for a particular month and for a
particular country you can just do it by
a single click and it will show that
particular data only in the table let's
see
and do this in our excel
okay
so there is a table uh pivot table
already created for this and i want to
add a slicer
so how do i go ahead and do this is i go
to the
options and
insert slicer okay at the moment you
click on it you will see what are the
options that you want to add you can
select different fields and
select the slicer for it uh for this
example we are choosing month
okay this is one of our sliders you can
just put it here
adjacent to the
and again
this will be our slider okay
let's add another slicer here
okay
and this will be the countries and
territories okay
click on that and you will see two
simple
badges here that you can choose from so
if i want to know in the month of feb
how many number of cases were there for
particular let's see the moment i choose
the month it will show that particular
number of
the corresponding table for the whole
and now i want to further refine it to a
particular country so for example
australia okay so there were total
number of 18 cases and zero deaths
at the same time if i go for algeria it
is like this
so
as you see
it goes like this okay so this is one of
the very important tool that you can use
to show the data in a much simplified
manner and
ease
okay so the next question is about the
pivot table again what is the percentage
of contribution of each country and
continents to the total cases again the
same example for our code the kovid1 in
this time we want to show the output as
the percentage of contribution for each
country and continents to the total
cases
so we have the same data and we generate
a pivot table and we should show it as
the sum of the cases to be percentage
okay and this is how we do it
this is our
data and i'm going to create a pivot
table for this
okay
so it shows the table
and here i have to show
what is the
fields that we need to select okay
first is we're just selecting
the
cases and the countries and territories
okay
so
cases to be the values okay
okay so this is how it looks like
now when i see
let me show it to you see it shows the
number of cases now if i just want to
refine it further and see it as number
of
percentage percentage as the number of
cases okay so how i do it show field
list
i go here
and i go to
value field settings okay
then
again
number format
show the value as okay
sorry
show the value as you need to select
this thing
percentage of grand total and then just
click okay
and you will see
this to be the percentage so
it shows the data in the form of
percentage
okay this is very simple and you just
need to remember as we have seen before
show far field and then value field
settings okay this is the thing that you
need to check okay grand percentage
there are other options also
and you can select from whatever you
want to get in this case we are showing
it to be the percentage okay
okay guys now the next question is about
uh in a very important aspect of
presentation when we come to
pivot charts how do you create a
favorite chart in pivot tables
this is very
basic or very you know
important aspect of pivot tables that
you can represent uh data in a in the
form of a chart and there are different
types of charts which i'll show it to
you in the
uh example okay so we have a data here
and we want to show it at in
right now it is in a table form
okay we have put up a pivot table for
this and now the same thing can be put
up in a pivot chart okay so what you
need to do is go to the insert tab and
select the pivot chart it depends
on different versions of excel that you
have different uh forms or different
buttons
so i will show it across to you and this
is how it looks like okay it's very
simple it can be a pie chart it can be a
bar chart it can be
different forms and we can see that in
the example here okay so let's go to the
example and
so we have the
pivot table generated here already what
you need to do is you need to select the
table
and go to
insert and
see the options there are there is a
column chart there is a line chart there
is pie bar
area scattered and other parts okay
there are different pumps okay so right
now what we do is we will select the
column chart here okay you need to
select the pivot table and click on the
column chart again there are different
forms which can be seen
in some time now
so this is the basic form okay and it
will show you the countries i mean that
and it will show it as a form of a chart
okay
again you can change the chart type you
can change it to pi
okay
this personally is very good in
presenting or doing presentation
and you can select different forms
different styles okay we'll also show
you the percentage
so this is one form of presenting your
table
into a chart okay again bar type is also
there
so this won't suit here in our example
[Music]
there are different ones i'm just
showing it to you
as how it looks like
so depending on your
i mean the aesthetic you can see and
select what kind of chart is best
suitable
okay
so this is how you put up a pivot chart
in
pivot tables
okay
so this is one last for the intermediate
level and
what are macros in excel create a macro
to automate a task basically
you have some daily tasks that you
perform in excel okay
and
you can do this with quite ease using
the macros okay it basically is a
program that resides within the excel
file and it is used to automate tasks in
excel some daily tasks that you run like
running when you come across in any data
and you have to scrub that data and you
do some daily
routines and by removing some columns or
adding some formulas
and you know
doing some adding some colors and
changing the fonts or be it anything
that you perform and you have to do a
repetitive task so all that can be done
by recording a macro and this is what
macro is used for in excel so
how you capture those steps in excel is
through a macro to record a macro you
can either go to the developer tab in
the excel and click on record macro or
you can use or access it from the view
tab okay so
these are the
ways to access macros okay just go to
the developer tab
and click record macro when you know
when you click record macro it will
record the steps that you're performing
in each step and it will capture that
and you can save that it is like a
daily routine that you run and you can
do all these multiple steps maybe n
number of steps within a single click by
running that macro later on
okay
so you record a macro and run that okay
you do it through the developer tab go
to developer tab and click record macro
and it records all the steps that you're
performing okay you need to name it
and you just need to perform the actions
and it will record the macro and you
just save it later on whenever you come
across the same daily task that you run
you can just click it by running that
macro okay
wow so in a single click it will perform
all the
actions that you have done or steps that
you perform on that particular excel
sheet or any other excel sheet
okay this is very handy when you have
similar data and you do the similar task
each day okay
so this ends the
intermediate level and in the next v
slides we will see the advanced level
so now we discuss the advanced level uh
interview questions for excel
and when it comes to the advanced level
you will come across definitely you will
be asked about
what if analysis how does it work how
does it how does what if analysis work
in excel so what if analysis as the name
suggests
you
have to have
an analysis done
okay with the help of different complex
mathematical calculations like formulas
and
using different formulas and
calculations
you can experiment with the data and you
can
analyze if this particular input changes
what will be the scenario
how will your output turn out to be so
as you
can see it is about different variables
to see how your changes would affect the
outcome of a situation so
this is what what if analysis is and the
same thing can be done with xn and how
it is done is you need to go to the data
tab and click on the what if analysis
under forecast okay so there are three
options and
one is the scenario manager goal seek
and the data table so these are the
three situations or three tools which
are available in the what if analysis
in the data tab okay so goal seek is
basically for reverse calculations okay
and you have some
idea you have some set goal in mind
and you have certain variables and
what you need to do
and what you need to achieve
to have certain set goals okay you have
you will set a value for the goal and
with the goal seek option you can get
to know what value you have to achieve
to
come to that
level okay
so
this is what goal seek is
it is one of the simplest sensitivity
analysis tool
and
so for example you know that you know a
single outcome you would like to achieve
like you have a set goal that you have
to achieve this particular grade
okay and the goal seek feature in excel
allows you to
arrive to that goal by mathematically
adjusting a single variable within that
equation so you set the goal and you
will do the what-if analysis goal seek
option
to
know what you have to do or what you
have to achieve for the set goal
the next option is the data table and it
is basically used for sensitivity
analysis
okay so
in this
scenario
you
the data tables allow the adjustment of
only one or two variables within a data
set
but
each variable can have unlimited number
of possible values okay so basically
they are used for side by side
comparisons
in it makes it very easy to read the
scenarios okay one but you need to set
up the
data table correctly okay and what you
do is
you give the input in the table and then
you set up the formula and for instance
you need to calculate the monthly
payments for a loan okay you provide the
principal amount like
whatever amount you're taking 2 lakhs 3
lakhs
and you set the interest rate in a
formula okay
and you set the term
in
and then you need to
provide different input options like
what loan amount that you're taking
and
you set the formula and go to data table
and
i mean go to what-if analysis and select
the data table stretches across
and then you will see the monthly
payment options or the monthly emi that
you can calculate there are different
things that you can calculate you can
calculate the target or the sales bonus
or things like that okay giving
different scenarios in the
variables okay but you need to set up a
data table it might be a little
challenging but yes it is a very
powerful tool okay so the next one is
the scenario manager it is a bit more
complicated compared to the other two
but then it is uh more advanced than
goal seeker as it allows you
the uh to adjust the multiple variables
at the same time okay
and
this is very complicated compared to the
other two
and it is even i mean it gives more
better output when it compares to the
other two what-if analysis tools
so here when you go to what-if analysis
and the scenario manager you have to
select the data and provide different
scenarios that is different values for
each scenario and then it will create a
it will analyze calculate and create
different scenarios okay so it becomes
very easy for you to
analyze what if you are changing the
value
of your interest amount or the
term of loan or
your targets like
monthly targets or an early targets and
things like that and you just have to
uh see what the scenario will be when
you set this particular value
for a
table or for data whatever targets that
you need to set you can use this what-if
analysis in
excel for the different
scenarios and different calculations
okay these are very powerful tools and
you need to know this
now as we move on to the next one you
might be asked what is the difference
between a function and a subroutine in a
vba
okay
even though these two are used quite
frequently
there is a
pretty much different from each other
okay so a function always returns a
value of the
task it is performing okay so when you
are writing a module you will have a
function when you have a function it
will always give you a value okay for
example you are performing an addition
it using the function it will give you a
value for sure whereas subroutine it
does not return a value of the task it
is performing functions are called by a
variable okay
you can
set up a variable and you can call the
function okay but a subroutines can be
recalled from anywhere in the program in
multiple types okay in many different
ways you can recall a subroutine like we
have seen
we write a subroutine and we put up a
button
and we can when you click the button it
will recall the subroutine functions are
called by variable okay you have to set
up a variable and when you enter it it
will come up okay functions are used
directly in spreadsheets as formulas
whereas sub cannot be used directly in
spreadsheets as formula okay this is
very important difference
and the next thing is the functions can
be used to perform repetitive tasks and
return a value whereas users must insert
a value in the desired cell before
getting the result of the sub so this is
particularly limited okay whereas
functions can be used to perform
different repetitive tasks and return a
value user input is not required whereas
if you see the subroutines user must
insert a value okay in the desired cell
that too in a particular cell which is
defined in the subroutine to getting the
desired result okay so these are the
differences between functions and
subroutines now the next one is what is
the difference between this workbook and
active workbook in vba
so when you work on modules and
different excel spreadsheets and
workbooks you will have these different
workbooks open
and
there is a particular difference and you
might be asked what is the difference
between this workbook and active
workbook so as the name suggests this
workbook refers to the name of the
workbook where the code is actually
running from okay you are running a code
vba code and it is the actual
workbook where you are running the
code from and that is this workbook okay
and you have multiple spreadsheets open
and you are working on particular
suppose for example you are working on a
sheet x okay
and you active workbook is the workbook
that is currently active from the
different open workbooks you have
different
open workbooks but you are working on
one particular
workbook and that is called the active
workbook so this workbook is the
refers to the name of the workbook where
the code is actually written whereas
active workbook is the one that is
currently open currently active okay so
this is the difference between this
workbook and the active workbook in vba
as shown in the example this is a simple
uh sub that is written a code that can
be written to find out which workbook is
the
uh
which workbook is the uh this workbook
in the vba and the active work processor
okay so this is a simple thing that you
can run to determine okay it shows the
active workbook and the this workbook
okay
so as we move on to the next one
so this is the question how will you
pass arguments to a pbf function okay
there are two ways basically arguments
can be passed to a vba function as a
value or as a
reference so
this is uh an example that you can see
it is by reference the key word for this
is by reference okay
so when you are passing an argument
by reference the keyword should be by
ref
whereas
by value you are specifying a value and
the keyword is by
val value okay so these are the two ways
that you can pass an argument in vba
so when you pass an argument by
reference in a procedure the variable
itself okay the variable itself is
accessed by a procedure and it is to the
location or the address in the memory
okay the value of the variable is
changed permanently by the procedure in
this case all right okay so to pass an
argument by reference you should use
bira that is the key word before the
argument okay so in this example it is
clearly shown what is the key word that
is being used okay and by reference is
the default
in the vba
unless you specify something else which
in this case is by value okay and as i
said the keyword for by value passing
the argument by value is by bal okay
so when you set the keyword by val
the variable
what happens is the
by value argument function or argument
is passed through by value okay the
number function is called here which
means it assigns a value to the variable
x here okay
because the variable was passed by value
in the function any change to the value
okay any change to the value
of the variable is only the current
function so it ends after it performs
the
function okay then it revert back to the
value when it is declared again where it
is set to zero so if the variable has
been passed by reference in the function
then the variable would have permanently
assumed the new assigned value so this
is the basic difference by reference and
by
value so now we move on to the next one
so there might be a question that you
will be asked that how do you find the
last row or a column in a vba okay so to
find a
last row sometimes you have long list of
uh data and it has
like n number of rows and n number of
columns so
instead of scrolling down all together
to find the
last row you can use this vba code you
can write this code it's a very simple
one and it will give you the
last row you will find the last row with
a single click okay let's see it in the
vba so here i have a sheet which you
know it has long list of
rows and instead of scrolling down i can
just find out the
last row with this
vba code okay i just click on this and
as seen in the slideshow i have just
returned it
and
you will see that you just run it and
you will see the number of rows it will
give you the last row in the sheet okay
similarly we can do this for the column
as well okay in case if you have a long
list of
large number of columns instead of
scrolling right
you can just uh run this vba and you can
see you can know the
last number of columns okay number of
columns so as we've seen in the last row
now we'll see the code for the finding
the last column it's the same thing uh
instead of row you will see it as column
all right and it when you run it you
will give the
it will give you the last column okay
now let's move on to the next one so you
might be asked this how do we check
whether a file exists or not in a
specified location
there is a code simple vba code that you
can write and you can run you can use
this utility to find out whether the
file exists or not okay and you need to
check whether the file exists and if it
does it will give you a message that the
selected file exists and if it doesn't
it will pop up with a message box saying
that the file selected file doesn't
exist so what you need to do is you have
to specify this
function okay and
check file exist this is what it does
okay you have to specify a variable that
is the store file name where you will
give the
location the location of the file and
the
name of the file okay and then you will
also specify whether the file name is
there or not now
so it runs this and it will see
either the file name exist or the file
actually exist or not
and it will give the appropriate message
box we can run the same thing in my pc
and we can check it
so here we are i have put this and i
have done the same thing and what i'm
looking for is this book two okay let me
maximize it this is what i'm looking for
and the location is desktop okay so let
me run this and you will see whether it
exists or not okay
and it says this selected file exists so
it goes and checks whether the file
exists and then it will give you the
message so this is how we check using
the vb
so the next one is uh
you know there is a powerful tool called
debug and you need to
you might be asked questions about how
debug works or how
you check the debug
okay to debug a vba code line by line
you can use the f8 key okay you can also
create a breakpoint to terminate the
execution so for this if you go to your
vba you will see the option as debug
okay you can use this
by clicking on debug or by pressing the
f8 key okay so what debug does is it
will show you the step-by-step execution
of your steps okay it will check each
and everything and if there is an error
it will pop okay
and the what is breakpoint is at some
point of time
you can check one particular step okay
you can stop the if suppose if there is
a thousand line codes and you want to
check on one particular step like maybe
800 step so just go to go to that
particular step and you can enter a
break point and it will show you what is
actually happening
at the that point that particular step
and you can see this in the locals
window or the watch window okay so let
me show you some simple example of how
this debug can be
used to check our codes okay
so here i have written a simple code for
this and it is basically
let me show you how debug works okay
this is the
let me maximize it and we'll see
okay so this is the debug option that
you can run and you will see what
happens okay this can be done by
clicking f8 all right so step into is
the option and you can check
f8 and you can press f8 again it will go
to the next step all right and it will
show you what's happening actually uh
you can see this in the
locals window what's actually happening
let me see
let me
maximize it a bit
so that you can actually see okay so
when i press f8 okay
step into
you will see what happens in the next
step okay this is what is happening a is
empty b is 0 i is 0 okay i step into it
the next step again so it goes here you
can see what changes happen
i press
f8 again
so this is what is happening
all right so it is checking each and
every step so debug is the tool that you
can use to check the course whether this
is a very simple program but then you
will have some different codes where you
functions or routines that you can have
where you have thousand line codes and
you need to check each and every step or
some particular step so this comes in
very handy okay let me press f8 and it
shows what happens in which
you can step into each and every step
and
see what happens okay and now if i show
there is something called as toggle
breakpoint okay this one particular is
used by uh
pressing the f9 key wherein you will see
what is actually happening at some
particular step okay so how you do that
is you just need to go to a particular
step and click on the bar here and it
will get
highlighted into red so this is what is
happening okay so in the watch window
you will see that particular step will
be
magnified or you can see what is
actually happening in that step okay
so let me start it again
see what happens
i press f8 again
so here it sees
it actually shows you can toggle and you
can see what is happening in the watch
window at that particular step so module
1 abc the variant is empty so expression
is b this is what is happening at this
particular step okay so this is how
debug can be used
so now as we move on to the next one
well you might be asked to create a bar
chart with the given data using vba so
you will have some data
and
you can create a bar chart or a
any kind of chart
with the vba we have done it with the
pivot tables and all but then we can do
the same with the vba so it's a simple
thing a simple sub that you can write
and create embedded chart using chart
object this is the
sub that you can use okay you are
specifying a variable here
and m budget chart you need to specify
the
embedded chart and which sheet you're
using and this is very basic and they
charge a chart objects like the length
the dimensions of the chart okay
and you need to specify the source okay
the source sheet for range so and so you
can specify the range here so uh let's
go and do the same thing in the vba
so here i have the
data and
let i have already copied the
vba for it and let me simply
run it okay
see
it creates a chart so this comes in very
handy
and you can see the as i have mentioned
in
you have to specify the source the
dimensions of the chart and so on so and
so on okay you are specifying where it's
picking up the data from
and the columns i'm in the range and the
dimensions of the chart okay you can
play with this and you will generate a
chart so
well this ends our presentations
and
so
this is how it looks like and we have
seen that so next question is about a
vba code again to calculate the area of
a rectangle using the vba function how
do you include a function to calculate
the area of a rectangle we all know that
the area of a rectangle is length into
width
okay that is the formula we can execute
it with the way by defining a function
in the vba
and we'll define the same function
function is equal to area and it is area
as length into bit in this scenario i'll
again show it to you
how we do this in excel and
let's go ahead and do this so here we
are i will just go to the developer tab
and open the vpn
and i insert a module okay
so here we will define the function okay
function
as area okay
this is my function
and now i'm going to define the
variables okay
length
as
double because
we want to make sure that it takes the
decimals as well okay
and width
okay now what is the uh area
formula for example a equals to
length
into limit
okay
very simple
okay now
i go to my excel and
i'll define the area from function okay
let's take the
length to be
put in
a1 and the width to be put in b okay
now if i just put the value here
it will take 12
and my width is 36
3 and it shows the area to be
36 okay
11
so this is the area if you just go and
define it i mean try to enter area a1
and b1 it will not so we have to define
the function here we're using the vba
code okay now let's go back to the slide
and we'll discuss so here uh it has been
shown as if you know we
have a
rectangle when the wind width is not
provided that is if the
rectangle is a square they will not be
given the width so
we are defining again length as double
optional optional is we are giving an
argument that it is optional width as a
variant width as a variant means it can
be zero okay so we are defining it as if
missing width then the area should be
length into length
okay else the area is length into width
as we have seen okay so this is one way
to define a function for the area of a
rectangle
okay let's go to the next slide
so
you might be asked about a vba function
to check if the number is prime or not
we all know what a prime number is a
prime number is divisible by 1 and
itself for example 2 3 5 7 11
13
17 and so on
and these are the prime numbers and
anything which is divisible by any other
number like 8 or 4 or 16 which has a
divisor is not a prime number so
we all know this and we will write a
vba code to
check if the number is prime or not so
this is the one that is given and we
will do the same in the
vba okay before moving ahead i will just
uh explain these uh the code and what we
are doing here is basically we are
defining three variables okay we are
declaring three variables one integer
variable
okay
and we call it as divisors all right and
then the next one is the one long
variable long
as the number and i as long okay here
long specifies variables
because uh it has got the larger
capacity than the integer values okay
the divisor will be zero we are
initializing the
variable divisor with the value of zero
okay the next thing is we use a input
box input box to get the number from the
user that is you will input a
number when you are asked to
uh